THIS BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT FOR US THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
IN ITS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT BE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND HOUSING
AND NOW THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING ROOM OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THAT. TEN TWENTY
ONE- STREET BUILDING AND I ASK
ALL MEMBERS FOR SUBCOMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT. SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MAKE YOUR PHONES ARE
NORTH COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN LIMITING ANY
ACOUSTIC FOOD FEEDBACK. AND I
HAVE SAID EVERY TIME YOU WANT TO
BE QUICKER. THE RAISE YOUR AND
FUTURE- BONTA RECKON- POP UP.
WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE
TO AND MUTE. IS TO THAT AND THEN
OUR I. T. PEOPLE PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. IT'S
RECOGNIZED SPEAKERS MAKE SURE
YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. COMMENT WILL BE HURT
AFTER. ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. BEFORE WE BEGIN
LET'S- T. WHO'S HERE MR OAK IS
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE BEEN HERE
MELENDEZ AND PRESENT THEM
PRESENT OKAY FOR THE RECORD OF
MYSELF AND SENATOR PAN ARE IN
THE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM-
CENTER MELENDEZ IS NOT HERE- WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL THE
ISSUES LISTED IN THE DISCUSSION
SECTION OF THE AGENDA TOGETHER.
I WILL BEGIN WITH A DISCUSSION
OF A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL AND
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SUBMITTED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APRIL FINANCE
LETTER. WE HAVE WITH US JOHN WAS
SELL CHIEF TECHNOLOGY OFFICER
AND DATA MORE DEBRIS DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
AND INFORMATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WELCOME M. SEAT WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. I DATA MORE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS CHIEF DATA OFFICER
AND CALIFORNIA STATE REGISTAR.
IT CANNOT BE OVERSTATED THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ELIMINATED THE NEED FOR
INCREASED INVESTMENT IN CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES AND
RELATED GAPS. TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THESE GAPS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR THIS SERIES OF MULTI
STAKEHOLDER FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS. THIS WORKGROUP
IDENTIFIED KEY INVESTMENTS IN
DATA SCIENCE AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY FOCUSED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNCTIONS THAT WOULD MAKE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN ACHIEVING
AN OVER ARCHING VISION OF
POPULATION HEALTH IMPROVEMENT.
THE CALL FOR THE INVESTMENT.
WITH THE DATA AND TECHNOLOGY
WORKERS INCLUDED IN DEPTH
DISCUSSIONS THE BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS FOR EXAMPLE CITY
COUNTY AND STATE RIGHT SURVEYS.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT EMERGED
FOCUSED ON THE INVESTMENTS
NEEDED IN DATA AND TECHNOLOGY
CAPABILITIES TO ADDRESS BOTH
RECENT CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
FORWARD THINKING STRATEGIES TO
REPAIR CALIFORNIA AND ITS
RESIDENTS FOR A HEALTHIER
FUTURE. DID YOU MISS ME NO
SUBSTANTIAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA AND TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS TO
SHIFT FROM A CATEGORICAL AND
CASE BASED APPROACH TO A
FLEXIBLE ECO SOCIAL LIFE
PERSONAL THAT EMBEDS EQUITY IN
EVERY COMPONENT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. THE GOAL OF THESE
INVESTMENTS IN TECH AND
ANALYTICS IS TO TRANSFORM PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA SYSTEMS INCLUDING
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT STRATEGIES. THAT
EMPHASIZE EQUITY PERMISSION AND
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. DISSIPATED COMMANDER OF
THESE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
IMPROVED INFORMATION SYSTEMS.
CONNECTION WITH HEALTH CARE AND
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEMS
AS WELL AS OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING IN
PREVENTION AND EQUITY. TAPANULI
CHIEF ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
INVESTMENTS IN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND DATA SERVICES AND
INFORMATICS IS ESSENTIAL AND A
CORPORATION OF THIS WORK TO
SHIFT FROM CURRENT SIDELOAD
PROGRAMMATIC SYSTEMS THAT LEAD
TO COMMENCE OUR DECISIONS TO
EXPANDED DATA ACCESS ENABLING
ADVANCED PUBLIC HEALTH IN
ANALYTICS CAPACITY. JOHN THANK
YOU DINNER. MORE YOUNG JOHN
HERSELF ON THE ACTING CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ENTER THIS SPECIES WE HOPE TO
ATTAIN THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
BUILT ON THE EXISTING FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED DURING THE ENDEMIC
IMMATURE THE CDPH PUBLIC HEALTH
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE SCALABLE AGILE
AND SUSTAINABLE. ADDITIONALLY
RESOURCES REQUESTED IN SPECIES
HE WILL ALLOW US TO INVEST IN
STRENGTHENING THE CAPACITY AND
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY
AND DATA SOLUTIONS. ESSENTIAL
FOR ADDRESSING EXISTING AND
EMERGING COMPLEX PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS IN PROBLEMS. THIS FIVE
YEAR TRANSFORMATIONAL EFFORT
WILL FOCUS ON IMPROVING
RESPONSIVENESS AN ESSENTIAL DATA
IN DECISION MAKING FUNCTIONS
CRITICAL TO REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AMONG THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AMONG
THE STATE THROUGH. IT YOUR
TRANSFORMATION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
. STATION AND INTEGRATION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA FOR
MEANINGFUL INSIGHTS. LEVERAGING
PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS EIGHT IN
PROACTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISIONS AT ALL LEVELS FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL. TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS CVH MUST ADDRESS
FOUR KEY AREAS PEOPLE AND
CULTURE ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN THE RIGHT
PLACES FOR THE RIGHT SKILLSETS.
WORKING TO BUILD A CULTURE OF
DIVERSITY INCLUSION AND
TRANSFORMATION. DECISION
INTELLIGENCE UTILIZING NEXT GEN
TECHNOLOGY TO BECOME A LEADER IN
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA SCIENCE
INFORMATICS. KNOWING YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON THE RIGHT DECISIONS
FOR THE RIGHT DATA. IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME. DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION USING DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES TO TRANSFORM
EXISTING MANUAL PROCESSES
ANSWERS OR CREATE NEW MORE
EFFICIENT ONCE. TO ME OF ALL THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS AND
EXPECTATIONS. NINETY SIX-
SYSTEMATIC SYSTEMIC SUSTAINABLE
THROUGH LONG TERM STRATEGIES
ROADMAPS IN FUNDING PLANS THAT
WILL AID IN MATURING OR
OPERATING MODEL TO BETTER ALIGN
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. CDPH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION I
JUST YOU AND THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS CHEESY REQUEST
THIRTY THREE POSITIONS AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND THIRTY THREE POSITIONS AND
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR IN ANY THEREAFTER
FOR THE GENERAL FUND. THANK YOU
. SO WHILE CDPH DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS IN DELIVERING LARGE
SCALE RAPIDLY DEPLOYED COMPLEX
IT SOLUTIONS TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE IN NINETEEN AND
I MAKE INVESTMENTS ARE STILL
NEEDED TO MODERNIZE AND SUSTAIN
THIS TRANSFORMATION OF OUR IT
AND DATA SCIENCE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS INVESTMENTS WITH SUPPORT IN
ITERATIVE APPROACH TO MUSIC
USING THE FOLLOWING FOUR PHASES
PHASE ONE IS PRE PLANNING WHICH
CURRENTLY INCLUDE ACTING
SUSTAINABILITY SUSTENANCE. POST
CODE REVIEW. RIGHT YOU NEED TO
ME. SYSTEM ANALYSIS. AND CLOUD
MIGRATION TECHNICAL AND DATA
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES. PHASE TWO
YEARS THE PLANNING PHASE WHICH
WILL PROVIDE THE OVERALL
FOUNDATIONAL STRATEGY AND
ROADMAP SUPPORTING OUR OPERATING
MODEL AND IT GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. A CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF THIS PLANNING PHASE IS
WORKING AT THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS. COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF LOCAL HEALTH DATA
MANAGERS AND EPIDEMIOLOGISTS.
THESE STAKEHOLDERS STAKEHOLDERS
WILL PROVIDE THE INPUT NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
IS INCLUDED IN CDPH IS
UNDERSTANDING OF DATA AND
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
AT THE STATE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
LEVELS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL ENGAGE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK ENSURING THAT ANY
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA SCIENCE AND
RIGHT T. INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THIS KEY
INITIATIVE. PHASE THREE IS THAT
IT WILL PHASE THIS WILL BE SPLIT
INTO TWO PHASES. FIRST ARE THE
NEAR TERM EFFORTS WHICH INCLUDED
STATE AND LOCAL PROJECTS. I NEED
LEARN ISSUED ITS AND PLATFORM
SERVICES. FOLLOWING THESE
EFFORTS TO BE THE MID TO LONGER
TERM INVESTMENTS WHICH INCLUDE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF TECHNOLOGY ECOSYSTEMS AND
FRAMEWORKS APPLICATION AND
SERVICES CONSOLIDATION. AND
ENTERPRISE PORTFOLIO AND DATA
GOVERNANCE. LASTLY IS SPACE FOR
CONTINUOUS MATURITY AND PROGRAM
VALUE DELIVERY. ONGOING PHASE
DELIVERS INCLUDES SYSTEM
STABILIZATION CONTINUES PLANNING
EFFORTS TO ENSURE FUTURE
BUSINESS NEEDS AND SERVICES ARE
BEING MET. AND THE DEVELOPMENT
AND MONITORING OF KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS AND
METRICS. THIS PHASE WILL ALSO
LET ME INFORM FUTURE NEEDS AND
REQUESTS A PUBLIC HEALTH AT ALL
LEVELS. THE INVESTMENTS
REQUESTED IN THIS B. C. P. AND A
PATH TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION OF A
MAJOR TRANSFORMATION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH D. NINETY TIMES. RIGHT
INTO ACTIONS. INCLUDING LABOR
COPING NINETEEN ANGELES. WHICH
WILL TRAINS LOCAL HELP CHORES.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITTEE. PUBLIC
HEALTH STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. HI THIS IS SHIRLEY NOW
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. ILIO HEY
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR- AND
SENATOR PAN- SEND YOU PICK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WHEN WE SAYS THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS JANUARY
FUTURE PUBLIC PROPOSAL WE NOTED
THAT IT LACKS AN OVERARCHING IT
STRATEGY AND SO WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES FILL
THAT GAP WE ALSO NOTE THAT THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL DOES LOOK
PROMISING IT REALLY STARTS THE
PROCESS OF MODERNIZING THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH IT
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPLETE WITH THE
LEADERSHIP TO THINK
STRATEGICALLY ABOUT DATA AND I.
T. NEEDS AND USES- THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER
WILL BE KEEP THE LEGISLATURE TO
MONITOR OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. I'M SO IN THAT- IN THAT
BEING AND WE WILL. FOR LEVEL
RATIONS FOR THE LIKE FEATURE
WHICH PRIMARILY CONCERNED
OVERSIGHT- TO HELP ENSURE THAT
THIS- THIS PROPOSAL IS
SUCCESSFUL WITHIN OUR FOR CUE
SUGGESTIONS RELATED TO SPECIFIC
ASPECTS OF THE PROPOSAL SH SO
OUR FIRST. QUESTION CONCERNS
REPORTING- INTEREST TESTAMENT OF
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSAL WE HAD SUGGESTED
SEVERAL LAYERS OF REPORTING TO
THE LEGISLATURE FROM
IMPLEMENTATION. DATES TO MORE
FORMAL ANNUAL UPDATES AND THIRD
PARTY MULTI YEAR VIEWS SH WE
SUGGEST INCLUDING UPDATES AND
INFORMATION ABOUT PROGRESS
PROGRESS ON IT MODERNIZATION. IN
EACH OF THOSE- I REPORTS SHOULD
THE LEGISLATURE ASK FOR THOSE
REPORTS JOSH- THE SECOND
SUGGESTION CONCERNS- HOW THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
FUTURE I KEEP PROPOSALS SHE SAID
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL REALLY LAYS
THE GROUNDWORK FOR AN IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AT CDPH.
INEVITABLY THERE WILL BE FUTURE
PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD FOR.
ADDITIONAL IT UPDATES OR NEW I.
T. PROJECTS AND WHEN THOSE
FUTURE PROPOSALS ARE MADE WE
SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE ASKS AND
KEEP KEY QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THOSE PROPOSED PROJECTS FIT INTO
THE OVER ARCHING- I'M I. T.
ECOSYSTEMS AND ABOUT HOW THE
PROJECTS WILL BE FUNDED- WE RATE
THIS POINT BECAUSE- H. CRIMSON.
I T. SYSTEMS AS YOU KNOW HOW IT
IS STRICTLY BEEN CHALLENGED BY
THE CATEGORICAL NATURE OF GRANT
FUNDING. AND LOW STATE HE
SYSTEMS CONSEQUENTLY HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED IN SILOS. SO LOOKING
AT EVEN ONE PRINT FUNDING. FOR
PURPOSE CDPH STILL CONSIDER HOW
GIVE PRIDE. IN ALL. I D. FRAME.
AND DEVELOP IT MEANS CAN
CONSISTENT SUCH AS DATA. AND
INNER ALL BUT AND AMONG SYSTEM
THE LEGISLATURE WANT ASK ABOUT
THE ISSUES WITH EACH I. T.
PROPOSED- ARE CAN LOCAL
INVOLVEMENT THE B. C. P. NOTES
THAT THE PLANNING AND DESIGN
INCLUDES CONSIDERATION OF HOW
LOCAL. THIS WILL USE THE KEY
SISTERS AND MISS MOORE DID
INDICATE THAT LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WILL BE INCLUDED
IN THE PLANNING DISCUSSIONS.
THIS IS VITAL GIVEN THAT STATE
SYSTEMS REALLY DEPEND ON LOCAL
SYSTEMS AND LOCAL INPUTS TO WORK
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE MAY
CONSIDER REQUIRING CDPH TO HAVE
THE PLANS THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SUBMIT AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING ONGOING
STATE SUPPORT. AS PART OF THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING.
LEWD INFORMATION THE STATUS AND
ANY CONSISTS OF THEIR OWN I. T.
SYSTEMS. AS WELL AS HOW THEY
WILL USE- DATA AND ANALYTICS IN
THEIR OWN LOCAL STRATEGIC
DECISION MAKING- ARE FORCED HIGH
LEVEL- SUGGESTION CONCERNS.
WHERE SORT OF THE LANGUAGE THAT
WILL BE USED TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROPOSAL WHICH SO BOTH
PROPOSALS ARE PROPOSED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH TRIP
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WE WOULD RECOMMEND INSTEAD
CODIFYING. OF THESE DETAILS
INSTEAD TO BE A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- NEXT WE HAVE JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE SPECIFICS
OF THE PROPOSAL SO FIRST WE NOTE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
THROUGH BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
AUGMENT THE REQUESTED ONE TIME
RESOURCES. ONCE ENTERPRISE
PLANNING AND STRATEGY DOCUMENTS
ARE SUBMITTED TO AND APPROVED BY
CAL EACH EACH HAS FEATURED C.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER A REVISION TO THE
PROPOSED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
ALSO PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD REVIEW THESE DOCUMENTS
WILL BE CRITICAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE FRAMEWORK ENVISIONED IN THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND PART OF THAT
REVIEW. IT. FOCUS ON WHICH-
ROGER X. ARE MOST TO MODERNIZE
THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH. EIGHTY
SO FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH IT SYSTEMS
SUCH AS THE VITAL RECORDS
SYSTEM. MUST REMAIN FUNCTIONAL
EVEN WHILE THEY ARE BEING
MODERNIZE SPEECH OTHER SYSTEMS
HAVE A NUMBER INTERFACES WITH
EXTERNAL ENTITIES SUCH AS THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
INTERNAL SMALLER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO OPERATE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES SH SO THE
ENTERPRISING ENTERPRISE PLANNING
AND STRATEGY DOCUMENTS SHOULD
PROVIDE NOTONLY THE LEVEL OF
EFFORT REQUIRED TO COMPLETE IT
PROJECTS. BUT ALSO CLEARLY
IDENTIFY WHICH PROJECTS ARE MOST
CRITICAL AND HOW ANY RISKS WILL
BE MITIGATED. OUR SECOND
COMMENT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROPOSES IN THE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO CONSIDER. QUOTES VERIFIED
SATISFACTORY PROGRESS TOWARD
COMPLETION OF INITIATIVES ZERO
PLANNING IN THE PROPOSAL SH THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ASK HOUSE
FINANCE WILL MEASURE THIS
PROGRESS AND WHETHER MORE
OBJECTIVE MEASURES OF PROGRESS
SUCH AS COMPLETION OF CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS. AND OR THE REACHING
OF CERTAIN MILESTONES SHOULD BE
INCLUDED WITH POTENTIAL
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE.
SO JUST TO CONCLUDE THE
FRAMEWORK GOALS AND VISIONS OF
THIS GROUP AND- THIS PROPOSAL
HAVE. SH BUT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND EVALUATES THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS TO MAKE
SURE THE COMPONENTS OF THE FREE
MORE ITS GOALS AND VISION AS
WELL AS ANY COMPONENTS THAT ARE
ADDED TO IT BY THE LEGISLATURE.
ARM BETTER TIMELY AND SUCCESSFUL
WAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAPMAN'S FOR THAT THE ANALYSIS
- WELL I THINK WE'VE ALL HAD
EXPERIENCE- BUT THESE BIG I. T.
PROJECTS THAT THAT HAVE  LOT OF
MERIT- BUT THE DEVIL'S ALWAYS IN
THE DETAILS- AND I GUESS BACK TO
THE BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT- CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
YOUR PLAN FOR REPORTING BACK TO
US THE PROGRESS. YEAH OPENS THAT
YOU ENCOUNTER A WAY. YEAH THANK
YOU. YES A WE WILL PLAN TO
FOLLOW ALL- ALL THE ALL THE
PROCEDURES TO REPORT AFTER
CONTROL AGENCIES- AS WE DEVELOP
OUR STRATEGIC PLANS IN WITHIN
OUR STRATEGIC PLANS WE WILL
IDENTIFY KEY PROPORCIONAR HOPE
MUST BE ABLE TO FACELOCK AND
SHOW PROGRESS ON THESE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- WILL ALSO INCLUDE
ARE A LOCAL JURISDICTION
PARTNERS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE- PRESSING.
THEIR CONCERNS NEEDS FOR DATA
AND THEIR TECHNOLOGY GAPS. THE
BROKERAGE SORRY AND APOLOGIES I
SO IT IS CERTAINLY AS I MAKE
EARLIER IN MY TALKING POINTS
THAT THERE WOULD BE MULTIPLE
PHASES AND SO WITHIN EACH PHASE
WE WOULD HAVE KEY MILESTONES TO
ENSURE OR A CHEATING ALSO
INTERACTIVES LAID OUT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS SO THESE ARE KEY
OPPORTUNITIES TO NOT ONLY REPORT
OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO THE
LEGISLATURE OKAY. AND WE THINK
THAT'S A VERY GOOD SO WE CAN WE
CAN KEEP TRACK OF IT AND NOBODY
LIKES THE PROBLEMS AT THE END I
KNOW ABOUT CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO INCLUDE AND INVOLVE LOCAL
HEALTH AGENCIES IN IN- IN
ANALYZING AND SETTING THIS UP
AND ALSO PREDICTING THEIR FUTURE
NEEDS AMONG. THEN COME ALMOST
ANY ELSE I THE IN A- OF STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES WHERE. SO MUCH OF THE
WORK IS BEING DONE WE TALK WITH
MORE ABOUT THAT. YES THE WEEK WE
PLAN ON INVOLVING OUR PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS EARLY ON IN THE
PROCESS FOR THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ROADMAPS- GATHERING THEIR
CONCERNS UNDERSTANDING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTS. AND HOW THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN ART
TECHNOLOGY DATA AFFECT THEM IN
AND THEIR NEEDS GEN. IN ADDITION
I'M- YEAH I YOU SEE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH INFORMATICS INSTITUTE I
HAVE PROJECTS AROUND DATA
MODERNIZATION AND OTHER TOOLS
AND RESOURCES. THAT ARE
STANDARDIZED SO THESE ARE
RESOURCES THAT CDPH CAN SHARE
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. FIVE SO THAT WE
ARE ALL WORKING FROM SIMILAR
TEMPLATES AND PROCESSES USED
AGAIN THROUGHOUT EACH PHASE. IN
THIS MILESTONE IT WILL BEING
INCLUDED THAT WE HAVE BENCHMARKS
IN INCLUDING CERTAIN TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS OR TOWN HALLS OR
IN HI I'M FROM OUR- LOCAL PUBLIC
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. YEAH ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST GOALS IS TO BE ABLE
TO STANDARDIZE OUR TECHNOLOGIES
IN OUR INFORMATION IN OUR
DATABASE SO IT'S INTEROPERABLE
SO WE CAN GET THE- BEST
INFORMATION TO. THE RIGHT PEOPLE
TO WORK ON. OKAY SHE- AND CAN
YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OR ABOUT
CODIFYING THIS AND HAVING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- I CANNOT
AT THIS TIME YEAH. WE WOULD HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU I'M NOT. OKAY
HI THIS IS SELENA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN GENERAL
WE PROPOSE TRAILER BILL WHEN
SUCH LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM TO ALLOCATE FUNDING. IN
THIS CASE WE ARE ABLE TO TAKE
THE STEPS TO PROVISIONAL IN
WHICH- BUT- WE ARE OPEN TO
REVIEWING ANY PROPOSED LANGUAGE
AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OKAY. I THINK THAT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE THE DEFENSE
. I THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I DO HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS
IS OF GREAT INTEREST TO ME- SO
WHAT SO IS YOUR DEVELOPING THIS-
PLAN FOR IT AGAIN PRE SHEET THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS. IS THIS A
THIS IS AN I. T. PLAN FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
THIS IN NINETY PLAN ONLY FOR THE
C. PH. SO I WOULD SAY IT'S FULL
AT BOTH LEVELS SO WE HAVE TO.
THE FRAMEWORKS AND TECHNOLOGIES
AT. AGE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE ENTIRE STATE RIGHT- SO OKAY
NUMBER WE- GOT INTO SOME SORRY.
I AND THAT ACTUALLY WITH THAT IN
ORDER MOVING ALONG THE IS YES
THANK YOU- SO- SO. THE AND AGAIN
PRECIADO PRESENTATION. SO- SO I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IN. THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST AN I. T.
EVALUATION OF CDPH AND CERTAINLY
FROM HEARING YOUR PRESENTATION
AND DURING THE EIGHTEEN
STAKEHOLDERS I THINK THE FOLLOW
UP WITH BOTH Y. ELIA SAID IN THE
CHAIR SAID. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ONE OF WE
ACTUALLY THINK ABOUT THIS
SETTING STANDARDS FOR EXAMPLE
FIRST OF COURSE MORE AT MOST
IMMEDIATELY LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH.
RIGHT SO THERE IS SAID SAID IT
IS CAN THIS SEAMLESS. BETWEEN
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH I REALIZE YOU ALSO
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH CDC AND
NATIONAL BUT AT LEAST WITH IT.
SHOULD WE- INFORMATION IDEALLY-
BUILD THE MOVE SEAMLESSLY
BETWEEN LOCAL AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS THAT IS THAT YOU DO
AGREE WITH THAT. YES OKAY SO
RIGHT SO KNOWS WE HAVE TO SET IT
STAND SO AS YOU'RE DEVELOPING
THIS WE NEED TO SET IT
STANDARDS. WE MAY ALSO NEED TO
HOPEFULLY YOUR PLANE YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT. TRAININGS ALSO-
FOR SMALLER COUNTIES PERHAPS
ALSO FUNDING SO THAT THEY CAN BE
SURE THAT THEIR SYSTEM SO YOU'RE
NOT TRYING TO CONSTANTLY.
CONNECT WITH THE LEGACY SYSTEM
RIGHT THAT WE ACTUALLY GET
EVERY. SINGLE OF LOCAL PUBLIC
ARE MADE UP TO A CERTAIN MINIMUM
STANDARDS AS WELL. IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU ENVISION. YES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- AND THEN THE
OTHER ISSUE IS THAT- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC HEALTH DOESN'T
STAND IN THE SILO ALONE. AND I
THINK IT BROUGHT THIS UP BEFORE
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE
LATER ON WE'LL BE TALKING TO THE
H. CHI HER RIGHT AND- THEY THEY-
THEY'RE SETTING UP THINGS LIKE-
ALL CLAIMS PAYER DATABASES AND-
HEALTH EXCHANGES AND SO FORTH.
IDEA AND VISION YOUR- YOUR AYE
IT TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM ACTUALLY
IT THING WITH THOSE TYPES OF
DATA SAID. YOU CAN EXTRACT
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA OUT OF THIS
DATA SETS. THAT WOULD BE THE
ULTIMATE CALL OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
THAT THE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
WRITE BECAUSE AGAIN- HOW THINGS
GET INTO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM OFTENTIMES ARE TAKING
REPORTING FROM HOSPITALS
PHYSICIANS OFFICES LABORATORIES
AND SO FORTH. RIGHT AND YOU AND
YOU WANT THAT INFORMATION BE
ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY AND THAT
SOMEONE'S FAXING INFORMATION
THAT SOMEONE THEN HAS TO
MANUALLY ENTER. RIGHT IT TAKES.
YOU DON'T WORK FOR IT SAID SAID
DELAYS- ETCETERA- SO I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
THAT AND ACTUALLY I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS MAYBE THIS IS
BROUGHT IN JUST A PUBLIC HEALTH
BUT THAT MAY BE A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE WHO ARE WE LOOKING AT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO. YOU KNOW IT TO YOU
THIS IS CROSS DEPARTMENTS THAT
AND I'VE I'VE ALWAYS SUGGESTED
IS THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE THAT IS
WE'RE DEVELOPING SOME THESE
OTHER IT SYSTEMS THAT INTERSECT
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME FORM OF.
COMPATIBILITY SO THAT
INFORMATION CAN AGAIN FLOW MORE
SEAMLESSLY BETWEEN THESE OTHER
HEALTH SYSTEMS HEALTH DATABASES
AND- POLICE FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES. YES THIS IS ADAM
DANDO AGENCY CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER S. S. G. WESTERN DR PADA
TODAY AND WE DID TALK ABOUT THIS
LAST WEEK WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR
MY OFFICE AND I'M WITH THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
WILL BE DOING EXACTLY THAT WE
pAND LOOKING AT THE STANDARDS AND
INTEROPERABLE WITH THE IN THE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. HAVE THIS
ENTERPRISE PERSPECTIVE ACROSS
ALL OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND EVEN INTERACTING
OUTSIDE THE AGENCY ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL. I'M REALLY TO
HEAR. BECAUSE AGAIN WITH THIS IS
ONE OF THINGS WE LEARNED
PANDEMIC WAS THAT INFORMATION
COULDN'T FLOW QUICKLY AND OF
COURSE THAT CAUSES GAPS IN
INFORMATION. THE LASER REPORTING
WHICH MEANS THAT LAYS AND BE
ABLE TO RESPOND- AND SO FORTH
AND- ALSO WE GET A FRANKLY.
HUESO SPREAD OUT THE RIGHT WORD
BUT IN SOME WAYS IT WAS- OF THE
WORK FORCE REGULARS SO BUSINESS
NO THEY NEED TO DO THINGS LIKE
IMPLEMENT PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER
AND SO FORTH YET THEY ARE DOING
DATA ENTRY. YOU KNOW MANUAL DATA
ENTRY BECAUSE THERE WITH THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO
GET THE DATA ACROSS AND OF
COURSE WE STRUGGLE WITH THAT-
IT. SO THE I GUESS THE OTHER
THING IS THAT AGAIN I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT. MUCH OF WHAT- DAILY-
SAID SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE FOLLOW THROUGH ON. WHAT
DO YOU. AND I GUESS ONE OF THE
THINGS AS- IN THIS DOCUMENT. AT
LEAST IN THE BACKGROUND PEOPLE
WE GOT AND SO FORTH AND THEN
REALIZE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO.
WEAR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE SO WE
GOT NUMBERS RIGHT HOW MANY
PEOPLE HOW MANY POSITIONS HOW
MUCH MONEY AND SO FORTH. BUT I
GUESS I HAVEN'T HEARD YET- IS.
INDEED I REALIZE YOUR PRICE
STILL FIGURING IT OUT BUT- IT IS
REALLY KIND OF LIKE WHAT THE
OVERALL IT STRATEGY IS SO I MEAN
WE- WE KIND OF CHARACTERISTICS
OF IT- BUT I'M HOPING THAT- YOU
CAN HELP- PAINT A PICTURE FOR.
US AND- LATER AND- FRANKLY WAS
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR THIS. OF WHAT WE SEE THIS
FUTURE I. T. INFRASTRUCTURE
FRAMEWORK IT'S WHAT EVERYONE
CALL THIS. IT IS EIGHT WHAT IT'S
ABLE TO DO IN THE FUTURE- THAT
AND ABOUT WHAT TIME ALL RIGHT
WHAT THE TIMELINE IS TO GET
THERE. AND SO MAYBE YOU'RE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT YOU
STILL- YOU KNOW COLLECTING
INFORMATION OR GETTING FEEDBACK
FROM FOLKS BUT I THINK THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT SO IT'S GOT TO
GO BEYOND THAT WE NEED DEL EX
MORE TWENTY MILLION EIGHTEEN
MILLION FIVE. YEAR THREE THREE
POSITIONS AND SO FORTH. AND IN
THE END SO PEOPLE CAN SAY OKAY
THIS IS THE TYPE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM. IT SYSTEM WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IN THIS IS GOING
TO BE ITS CAPABILITIES- IN TERMS
OF. FOR I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
TO PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND LIKE
THIS IS WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO IN THE
FUTURE DATA COULDN'T DO BEFORE.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT-
SO. THE NEW. ALSO CAPACITY SO
FORTH BUT REALLY PAINING VERY
SOME- A FIVE UP THE IMPORTANCE
BUILDING A RIGHT IN WALLS OR AND
THINGS- BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THAT TO THE PUBLIC
AS WELL AND CONTINUE TO BUILD
BROADER PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE
PANDEMIC HAS TAKEN QUITE A
BEATING SO- IS THE D. WHAT AT
WHAT TIME I GUESS I WOULD SAY
WHAT AT WHAT TIME FRAME COULD
WE- IMAGINE THAT- THAT THE
WEATHER TO SEE. CDPH ARE. EVER
CAN. PROVIDE US THAT KIND OF-
PICTURE. OF WHAT YOU SEE IS THIS
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- PUBLIC
HEALTH- I. T- TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO. YES NO THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND WE ARE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
ESTIMATES ARE THAT WITHIN A YEAR
TO YEAR AND A HALF WILL HAVE A
PRETTY GOOD OVERTURE STRATEGY IN
FORWARD WITH- AND AS FAR AS WHAT
IT'S GONNA DO. A HIGH LEVEL. BUT
IT HE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
DATA SCIENCE AND INFORMATICS-
WILL REALLY DEVELOP INVOLVING
RESPONSIBLE MERGING DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION STRATEGIES- THAT
DEFINES THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
TECHNOLOGY ECOSYSTEMS- AND
ARCHITECTS THE INTEGRATION OF
BETTER DATA PUBLIC THAT TO ME
PUBLIC HEALTH DECISIONS
INTELLIGENCE. OPENNESS
FRAMEWORKS ENABLE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT DATA ACCESSIBILITY QUALITY
AND COMPLIANCE. AND YOU KNOW
DEVELOP LEVERAGING FOR PURCHASE
TO BUILD ENTERPRISE ANALYTICS
SOLUTIONS THAT PROVIDE IMPORTANT
DATA LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. FROM AN
OVERALL STRATEGY AS WELL AND-
REALLY WHEN WE THINK ABOUT AND
KIND OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SORT OF CONDITION OR BODY PART
SPECIFIC PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
IDEALLY WITH THIS NEW SYSTEM IN
PLACE. WE WOULD BE ABLE TO NOT
JUST HIGHER POINT IN TIME
RETROSPECTIVE DATA MIGHT REALLY
BE ABLE TO MODEL AND PREDICT.
RIGHT OUT OF TIME SO THAT WE CAN
MORE JUDICIOUSLY. WE RESOURCE
THIS TO THE APPROPRIATE PLACE
AND SOONER AND ANY FASTER AND SO
WE GET A STRONG MENTIONED WITHIN
THE NEXT YEAR AND A HALF AND WE
SHOULD HIGH. ASSESSMENTS AND ARE
BASICALLY YOU SENSE OF OUR ROAD
MAP OF WHAT THIS SHOULD REALLY
LOOK LIKE AND WHERE IT'S GONNA
GO. AGAIN AS IT FROM THE THIS
REALLY WILL BE A HOLISTIC PLAN
TO TAKE IN ACCOUNT.
OKAY BUT WITH SO SOUNDS LIKE-
AND AGAIN I WON'T BE HERE BUT- I
AM SURE- CHAIR EGGMAN AND OTHERS
WILL BE HERE- BUT I AS IT IS A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING SOME UPDATES
AT THE STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADDRESS FROM THE CDPH DIRECTOR
NEXT SPRING IN THE STATE'S A
YEAR AND A HALF. I HOPE THAT
IT'S INCORPORATED INTO THAT THE
ADDRESS- IN I GUESS- THAT WOULD
BE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IF YOU'RE
A YEAR AND A HALF- ALIGN- THAT-
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT-
YOU CAN- THAT WE CAN GET A
FULLER PICTURE OF- I DO
APPRECIATE WHEN THINGS THAT YOU
SAID BECAUSE IT'S- NOT JUST
ABOUT COLLATING DATA AND- SAVE
YOU SAYING WHAT HAPPENED. YEAH
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST OR
EVEN WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
VERY PRESENT ALTHOUGH THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. IT'S ALSO USING
ANALYTICS MODELING- WE TALK
ABOUT A AYE IT'S CETERA TO TRY
TO. ANTICIPATE THE FUTURE RIGHT.
BOTH NEAR AND FAR AND BE SURE
THAT. WE THEN. THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO. FRANKLY PROTECT
THE PUBLIC BECAUSE PUBLIC HEALTH
IS PUBLIC SAFETY- I MEAN IT'S- I
THINK SOMETIMES WE DON'T REALIZE
THAT AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU. YOU CAN
DOT YOU DIVE A GERM YOU'RE JUST
JUST AS YOU DIVE A BULLET. ARE
AT- OR SOME OTHER CAUSE. AND AND
FRANKLY- IN PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ABOUT- TRYING TO PRODUCE YOU
KNOW BASICALLY. SAVE LIVES
PROLONG OUR LIVES AND ONLY
PROLONG LIVES MAKE SURE DOES
LIGHT THOSE ADDITIONAL YEARS ARE
HEALTHY ONES AND ONES- THAT-
PEOPLE- WILL ENJOY AND BE ABLE
TO DO THE THINGS THEY WANT. AND
SO THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- WE NEED TO
HAVE THE DATA SUPPORTS NECESSARY
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO- I'LL
KEEP IN MIND THAT TIMELINE- I
REALIZE THINGS HAPPEN- BUT- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. ALTHOUGH I
WOULD URGE I KNOW A YEAR AND A
HALF- ISN'T NECESSARY IN SOME
WAYS IS THAT LONG BUT IT IS A
VERY LONG TIME. AND I HOPE. THAT
URGE YOU TO TRY TO MOVE TRY TO
MOVE IF YOU CAN MOVE IT A LITTLE
FURTHER. FASTER THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. THANK THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN WE THINK THAT. FOR FOR
THEIR TENTS TO THIS AND- UP WITH
AN AMBER. PLAN AND WE WILL ALL
BE- INTERESTED IN TRACKING THIS
GOING. FORWARD AND I BUT I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT- HAS DOES
NOT DEPEND HAS HAS- ALLUDED THIS
IS LAST THIS. IS LAST TERM HERE.
AND WE JUST WANT TO THANK HIM
FOR ALL HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
FIELD OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AS WE
HAVE LIVED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS HE HAS
OFTENTIMES BEEN. OF THE ONLY
VOICE. OUT THERE ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT WE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE. AND THAT'S
DEPARTMENTS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
SO. WE'LL CERTAINLY MISS THAT
VOICE. THANK YOU ANNA. HOPE I'M
STILL HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AND WE WILL BE BIRD ****
THIS AND MAYBE INVITING YOU BACK
FOR A SPECIAL GUEST APPEARANCE.
THANK YOU OKAY THE YOU ALL RIGHT
- MOVING ON NOW TO THE- APRIL
FINANCE LETTER- OF TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS WE HAVE. THE BALL AT
THE MINISTRATION OPERATIONS
SECTION CHIEF FOR THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY WELCOME- AND
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY IS GONE ON BEHALF OF
THIS ADJUSTMENT I'M SO THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY WHICH IS
WITHIN FIVE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS LOOKING TO TAKE- STEPS
TO FULFILL THE STATUTORY
MANDATE- I'M TWO MINISTERS.
CHILDREN AND- APRIL HELPED.
WHICH ISN'T. WITH THE AGENT. AS
WELL AS SEARCHING. AND THE STATE
. PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE AND HEALTHCARE SERVICES-
SO WHAT WE ARE LOOKING TO DO
HERE IN OUR WAY OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH- AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S TO. EDUCATION
AND- AIMS TO NORMALIZE MENTAL.
AND REDUCE THE STIGMA FOR USE ON
THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE A LONGER
TERM THIS TECHNICAL- AT THE END
KNOCKED APPROPRIATED TO BE
AVAILABLE INCOME BRACKETS MAKES
. JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY FOUR
WILL ENABLE US TO CONTINUE TO
PROPERLY TO DESIGN AND BUILD AND
CARTER IMPROVEMENT THE PUBLIC
EDUCATIONAL CHANGE HARPER WHOLE
PURPOSE WHITEWASH THERE ARE WITH
THE- WE ARE. HIRING TAKES.
CULTURAL AND WHEN LINGO ONSTAD
TO REALLY BEGIN THE PLANNING
CREATING AND THEN FURTHER IN
FULL THAT'S BECAUSE- SHOULD. AS
BUSINESS HAVE DONE REQUIRE.
OPERATIVE IT HAS- TO BE BE GAME
CHANGER YOUR COWORKERS AN ADULT
ENTER. WITH BIRDS AGE CHILDREN
ARE TO GET TACTIC RESPOND TO
NINETY HEALTH. AND IMPACTING OUR
CHILDREN TO CROSS ON
RESPECTIVELY THANK YOU YOUR TIME
AND- LOOK TO THIS FORWARD YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FINANCE.
AFTER HEARD NEXT BILLS OUR
PLANETS AT THANK YOU. NO
COMMENTS MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
OKAY THANK CAN YOU CAN YOU TELL
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHO THE
ALREADY FOR THIS OR IS A GOING
TO BE. IS IT GOING TO THE PUB
WHO WERE THE PROVIDE THAT WILL
BE WHO BE I MEAN WHO IS THAT THE
AUDIENCE TO- THIS THIS CAMP IS
GOING TO. BURGER PAYER. ARE AND
THAT COULD BE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH PAYERS AND FAR AS
- YEAH ALSO I AS PER DAY ON
BECAUSE IN ALL TO SERVICES
AVAILABLE- FOR SEEN OUR FAMILY
ARMS. AT AS FAR AS WE ARE GOING
TO TELL I APOLOGIZE AND FRANKLY
WHEN YOU- TO SO I THINK-
CHECKING ON BUT I. FEEL ON ALL
OF THE AS FAR AS EXTENT ON-
BETTER AS WELL OKAY. I'VE JUST I
I'VE A STRONG IN THIS AND SO I
WOULD THAT SO WE'RE GONNA YOU
KNOW PROVIDE BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE WANT TO PROVIDE A LOT
OUT WE AND- BEFORE THE PROGRAM
GOES ONLINE. THAT'S WHY MY
QUESTION ABOUT WHO WHO WE
TARGETING THIS OUT TO. AND
SUPPORT THE EARLY INTERVENTION
SO- THAT WOULD BE MY QUESTION
GOING FORWARD DR PEPPER. AND FOR
YEAR- AND YET THE PREFIGURED
YOUR SO PERHAPS THE. FIFTEEN
JUST- AND I KNOW THAT LISA. AS
PUBLIC EDUCATION SO- SO LET THIS
IS THIS IS FOR. THE- EXTENSION
OF THE EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR
A PUBLIC CAMPAIGN FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT I
READ IT WRONG. CORRECT CRACKERS
. CONCERT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO OKAY
SO I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC THAT'S- I
THANK THEM MANY OF THE- L. MANY
PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC ARE AWARE.
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH STRAINS I
THINK ON THOSE IN OUR AMILIES.
BUT OFTENTIMES. THE DRESS IT WAS
STIGMAS INISH WHILE- SO IT'S
GOING TOWARD THE CRAFTY GOOD
CAMPAIGN DEBT- EDUCATES PEOPLE
THAT WE ARE DEVELOPING RESOURCES
THAT'S NOW THAT'S THAT PUT THE
LARGER TWO BILLION DOLLAR AT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
AND THEN- AND THEN ALSO ADDRESS
THE STIGMA ISSUES THAT MAY ARISE
AS WELL- IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
BEING RELUCTANT TO SEEK THOSE
SERVICES SO. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING MORE ABOUT THE NAY DATED
THIS PUBLIC CAMPAIGN THAT WERE-
DEVELOPING- WHICH I REALIZE
THAT- I'M- MAY TAKE SOME TIME TO
BUT IT'S THERE IS. URGENT RIGHT
NOW SO I'M HOPING THAT- WILL
HERE HAVE MORE REPORTS ABOUT
WHAT'S ACTUALLY BEING DONE.
VERSES EXTENSIONS OF THE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY SOME
LOOKING FOR TO ACTUALLY SOME
ACTION AND I'M SURE WORKING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
ARE IN INDIA AND SO IT IS ALL OF
THE HELP WHERE. AND HAD- FOLKS
THAT WOULD BE OUR AUDIENCE HERE
TO HELP- THIS CAMPAIGN FORWARD
AND. PARTICIPATION OKAY I AND
OUR WOULD ASSUME IT'S THE ARE
THE AUDIENCE THEN WITH WITH THE
IDEA THE FOR THEM BE ABLE TO USE
THESE NEW SKILLS THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING. THEN TWO THEN A
DISSEMINATE MORE WIDELY SO
ANYWAY I THINK WE WOULD ALL LIKE
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THAT ON THAT PLAN M. AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
RELATIVE NEWNESS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OKAY. SO LET'S MOVE
ON THEN- TO THE NEXT ISSUE WHICH
IS GOING TO BE- ISSUE NUMBER
THAT NUMBER ONE UNDER. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION. YES GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS KAREN MYSELF
UNDER THE DIRECTOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EACH KIND-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY- IF YOU WANT THIS
PROPOSAL. THIRTY TWO POSITIONS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE STAFF
RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR H. ID
IMPLEMENT MULTIPLE NEW AND
EXPANDING. OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IT'S
PROPOSAL USES EXISTING RESOURCES
TO FUND THE POSITION. THE
INCREASE OF THIRTY TWO PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THAT'S PROPOSALS
I'M OPERATIONAL CAPACITY NEEDED
TO BUILD AND MINISTER H. GUYS
HELP WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. AND THE CENTRAL
SERVICES NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM. THESE POSITIONS
WILL ALLOW H. CRISES OUR BASS
WEEKS. WORKFORCE FOR PROGRAMS
FOR FOLIO. SCHOLARS LOW BE
PAYING TYPE THE WORDS END. HI
CAREER. PRO AND AGAIN RAN AWAY
OREGON. THAT ADMINISTER HEALTH
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. THE
INCREASE CENTRAL SERVER CAN WILL
MEET UP NEEDS AND GOVERNMENT
INSTEAD OF REQUIREMENTS. IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET I
THINK WAS RECAST OF SPEECH CRY
RECOGNIZING H. GUYS GROWING
RESPONSIBILITIES ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREAS OF HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THESE CHANGES
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED H. CUTS
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS FUNDING FOR
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOR THIS. HERE'S BUDGET PROJECT
PROPOSES ADDITIONAL BILLION
DOLLARS WORKFORCE INVESTMENT FOR
EACH TYPE WITH MASTER HUGE
GROWTH LESS RESUSCITATING
ADDITIONAL STAFF. IN ADDITION TO
INCREASE FUNDING RECENT BUDGET
THAT WE INCREASE THE TYPE OF
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS H. CRAZY
MINISTRY. FOR EXAMPLE H. CHI IS
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
COUNSELORS AS WELL AS A NEW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH CLASS
CLASSIFICATION AND SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE WORK IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FIELD STUDENT CHILDREN YOUTH
YOUR BILL HAPPENS TO. OTHER NEW
WHAT WORKS WITH RECAP INCLUDES.
A HELP. EDUCATION AND TRAINING
COUNCIL. NEW RESEARCH DATA
CENTER AND BECOMING THE STATE
OFFICE OF RURAL HEALTH. IN
ADDITION THE PROPOSED TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET INCLUDES
PROGRAMMATIC FUNDING CHANGES
BEGINNING A THREE ON THE BREAD
AND THE DEPTH. OF H. GUYS HEALTH
WORKFORCE FOR. PROPOSED CHANGES
INCLUDE BUILDING A NEW COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER FOR FORCE
EXPANDING TRAINING FOR NURSING
SOCIAL WORK AND PSYCHIATRY
WORKFORCE. AND BUILDING A MULTI
LINGUAL WORKFORCE BETTER ABLE TO
SERVE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION. OUR NEXT KIND OF
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE THE POSITION
WE ARE REQUESTING THE SUPPORT
THE NEW PROPOSED TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE ACTIVITIES WE ARE
REQUESTING TWELVE MUSIC. YEAH
BUDGET APPROPRIATION EIGHT OF
THESE POSITIONS WILL DIRECTLY
SUPPORT H. GUYS EXISTING AND NEW
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND THREE
POSITIONS WILL PERFORM ESSENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT SUCH AS
IN CONTRACTS AND BUDGETS. WE'RE
ALSO REQUESTING A NEW HEALTH
EQUITY FOR NADER NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT OUR WORK TO RECRUIT
TRAIN HIRING VANCE AND
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE HEALTH YOU THIS. IS
WORKING. TO SUPPORT NEW PROGRAM
STARTED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
ARE REQUESTING FIVE NEW
POSITIONS. THESE POSITIONS ARE
FUNDED FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE APPROPRIATIONS INCLUDING FOR
EXAMPLE FROM CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE FUNDS
. THESE POSITIONS CORRESPOND
WITH THE WORKLOAD OF NEW AND
EXPANDED RECENTLY EXPANDED
PROGRAMS. THIS INCLUDES STAFF TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CHILDREN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE PROGRAMS. AND TO
SUPPORT THE NEW HEALTH
PROFESSIONS CAREER OPPORTUNITY
HIP HOP SUITE A PROGRAM. WE ARE
REQUESTING A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY FOR TWELFTH POSITION
IS TO ALIGN WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THESE POSITIONS ARE
ALREADY FUNDED FROM PREVIOUS-
APPROPRIATIONS ONGOING SEARCHES
FROM THE ON GOING SONG BROWN
GENERAL FUND AND TO HELP STATE
ENVIRONMENT PLANNING FIND UP-
I'M GOING APPROPRIATIONS. EIGHT
OF THE EXISTING REQUESTED. EIGHT
OF THE REQUESTED POSITIONS
CORRESPOND WITH EXISTING
PROBLEMATIC FOR GROWTH THAT WAS
A STARKLY SUPPORTED THROUGH
TEMPORARY POSITIONS. THIS CALL
POSITION. OUR APPROACH AND OUR
LEVEL WILL BE PAYMENT IN
SCHOLARSHIP FROM. FOR THE
REQUESTED POSITION SPORTS WITH
FOR PROGRAM SUPPORT THE
TEMPERANCE. BASICALLY PROJECT
MANAGER IT'S AND FEATURES AND
OUTREACH. AND FINALLY WE ARE
REQUEST THREE NECESSARY CENTER
SUPPORT H. SPEED WORK AND TO.
THIS POSITION ALSO FUNDED BY
FRANK AND PREVIOUS PUBLICATIONS
. TO POSITION AS WELL- OVERSEE
OF BROADER ADMINISTRATIVE AND.
OVERALL THE OPERATIONAL NEED AN
ORGANISER PLAN WHICH INCLUDE OUR
EFFORT TO IMPROVE AND RETAIN H.
WORK FOR INCLUDING WORKFORCE
PLANNING. WHAT IS THE SERVER TO
ADMINISTER SO BEING WERE FOR OUR
NEW FOR FROM. VISIT THOSE
ADMINISTER FIRED STATE OFFICE
LOCAL. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO PUT FINANCE. YES THIS IS ALSO
PART FINANCE NOTICED COMMENTS
SIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU. SENATE
GREG KOREA FROM THE L. A. O. WE
HAVE ANY CONCERNS TO RAISE ABOUT
THIS SPRING PROPOSAL EACH COW-
THE REQUESTED PAGE TO SEE WITH
EXISTING WORK. SEEM REASON TO US
GIVEN THAT. TRIES FONG THAT WERE
APPROVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
WE WOULD KNOW THAT- A PORTION OF
THAT REQUEST IS ASSOCIATED WITH
WORKLOAD THAT WOULD RESULT FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSALS- RELATED TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
APPROVED YET- BUT IF THE
LEGISLATURE SORT OF WHICH IS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE. THOSE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND- WE
FIND THAT THE- ASSOCIATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SOME CAN YOU.
EARN ISRAEL YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT A RESULT CAN YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. ANY KIND OF
METRICS THAT WILL BE IN PLACE
FOR. I MEAN WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE MASSIVE WORK FORCE
NEEDS- AND SO EACH ONE OF THESE
- IT IS GOING TO BE PUTTING
PART. TO CONTINUE TO. AND RETAIN
OUR WORK. DO WE HAVE MATCH ON ON
ON ON ANY TO THESE CATEGORIES.
THE AMOUNT OF POSITIONS JUST
STATEWIDE WE ARE DOWN AND THEN
UP PLANS ABOUT HOW HOW WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THAT GAP. WILL
THAT BE PART OF THE GOING
FORWARD. SO I WOULD SAY- IF I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION. THAT- I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK WITH YOU
ON THAT I DON'T DO NOT HAVE
THOSE CURRENT PLANS OKAY I GUESS
MY IS RIGHT WE ALL THERE'S A
HUGE WORKFORCE ISSUE- WE'RE WE
GEARING UP TO BE ABLE TO.
RECRUIT TRAIN SUPPORT- AS MANY
AS MANY AS WE CAN STRETCH ACROSS
. HEALTH BUT BUT AT ANY LEVEL DO
WE KNOW THEN THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE IN ALL OF THOSE CATEGORIES
AND THEN WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD
BE AT SOME POINT THEN DEVELOPING
PLANS TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
GOALS OF THE NEEDS. SO SO YES
FOR EACH OF THESE INITIAL WHAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT IS WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE ISSUES AROUND TO
FIND A MAN AND UNDERSTANDING
WE'VE BEEN DOING. SOME LANDSCAPE
ANALYSIS A NEED ASSESSMENT-
BURKE A VARIETY OF AREAS TO
DETERMINE WHAT THEY NEED IS. AND
THEN- WHAT WHAT OUR GOALS ARE
AND BURST OUT WISHING THOSE ARE
AS WE GO AND EACH OF OUR
PROJECTS. ALL RIGHT AND WHAT
WILL THERE ALSO. FOR THAT BE.
THIS R. X. R. X. BE. LIKE SAY.
IN THE C. ISSUES. OR UC'S. OR
EVEN THE MILITARY SYSTEM WHERE
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING THEIR
TRAINING. DO THOSE DO THOSE
PARTNERS HAVE HAVE THOUGH THE
AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
NEEDS AND OR AT SOME POINT DO WE
DO AN ANALYSIS. THE RESOURCE
THAT WE MAY NEED. TO THE WORK
FORCE THAT THE IS NEEDED- THAT'S
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE WORKING WITH THOSE
PARTNERS FOR EXAMPLE AND IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY NEED YES
AND- YOU ARE PROGRAMS WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP SUPPORT EXPANSION
OF THEIR CAP AND THE CAPABILITY
FOR EXAMPLE TO PROVIDE TRAINING.
FOR THIS WORKFORCE OKAY AND IN
SOME OF THE NEW PROGRAMS WE HAVE
TO WE HAVE TO CREATE THE
TRAINING OURSELVES CORRECT.
THANK THE COMMUNITY HEALTH OKAY.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU. YES SIR NO
THANK YOU- BUT- IF YOU CAN FIRST
QUESTION IS ARE UP. POSITIONS-
ARE ARE- AN ARM. YES REQUESTING
PERMANENT OKAY ALL RIGHT JUST
THE CLIFF- AND THEN- I THE OTHER
I HAVE- GIVEN UP HEARING WE HAD
IN TERMS OF- FOR STAFF- SO
CERTAINLY THESE. ARE IMPORTANT
FOR YOU CARRYING OUT THE WORK
FORCE WORK- AND- IN A PREVIOUS-
HEARING WE HAD TALKED ABOUT THEM
OUT OF IT SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN NUMBER STAFF. SO IS
THERE GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT IT
SUPPORT FOR THE WORK THAT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THE STAFFER WORKING ON
WORKFORCE ISSUES BY. USING
COMPUTERS AT. THAT AND SO FORTH
- IS THAT ALREADY EXISTED IN
AGENCY OR OR OR OR- WE HAVE PER
TO SOME RACIAL LIKE ONE I. T.
PERSON FOR EVERY TEN. STAFF AT
CETERA SO I DON'T KNOW FINANCED
AS A COMMENT ON THAT ARE YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON ON. ON
BASICALLY SUPPORT STAFFORD FOR
THE PEOPLE ARE DOING THE WORK- I
CAN SAY THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON ALREADY-
WITH BUILDING THE STAFF FROM
PREVIOUS SPENDING. IN THE TO
WITH THE I. D- OUR TO BE ABLE.
TO WORK THAT WE'RE DOING. OKAY
FINANCES YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT ON
THAT WE HEAR TO FOR AGAIN THE
SENATE SEPARATE AGENCY SEPARATE
THIS YEAR OUTSIDE OF THE STAFF
IT'S ERA BUT ALSO HEARD A-
COMMENT ABOUT HOW FOR EVERY TEN
EMPLOYEE. LIKE I. T. PERSON TO
KEEP THE COMPUTERS RUNNING AND
BE SURE THERE YOU KNOW ALL
SOFTWARES UP LOTS ADDRESS SO I
KNOW WHETHER THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT IS CONSIDERED IN THIS MAYBE
IT'S READY PRESENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT THEY HAVE THAT RATIO
OR IS THAT SOMETHING YOU NEED TO
AUGMENT. GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS OR
CREATING. YES SO WE WILL.
SURVIVOR THERE IS CYCLE SINCE
THAT. THIS IS BEING ADDRESSED-
IT'S NOT WILL DEFINITELY GET
BACK TO OKAY WHAT'S ON BE SURE
FOLLOWING PRACTICES WE WANT ALL
THE PEOPLE WE HIRED TO BE ABLE
TO FULLY DO THEIR JOBS AND NOT
SPEND TIME. DEALING WITH THE
SOFTWARE PROBLEMS AND HAVE
QUALIFIED PEOPLE DEAL WITH THE
SOFTWARE PROBLEM SO ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU. I THINK THAT
CAN. OKAY MOVING ON TO- THE
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WE HAVE- WITH
THE STATE DIRECTOR LANCE BURKE.
AS WELL AS SCOTT CHRISTMANN
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND RYAN
BUCKLEY CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE
DEPARTMENT WELCOME. DIRECTOR
INSPECT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND DR PANEL OF THE
FLANSBURGH FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION I JUST WANNA. THANK
DR PANDA THAT LAST QUESTION ALL
MOVED OKAY JUST A MINUTE BUT YOU
WANT TO SAY THAT WE DO HAVE A
RATIO- OURS RIGHT NOW IS
WONDERFUL OR WHERE WE ABOUT. BUT
ABSOLUTELY EVERY TIME THAT WE
ARE REQUESTING STAFF WERE ALSO
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE COMPUTER STAFF THAT YOU KNOW
FRANKLY THAT THEY- HIRE PH
VERY IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION-
OKAY MOVING ON THE- DEVELOP YOUR
BILL. SO THE OFFICE HEALTH CARE
FOR- FROM IN THE- BILL. AND I
KNOW WE DISCUSSED THIS- BACK IN
FEB- THE BILLING. SINCE THAT
TIME THE ADMIN. HAS FOR CLOSE
WITH PAN. STAFF OTHER. STAFF AND
TOGETHER ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON ON THE ISSUES.
I'LL JUST MENTION SOME OF THE OF
ISSUES WE'VE DISCUSSED THOSE
COME. GUSTS THE TREATMENT OF MAC
HEALTH COSTS IN CALCULATING
TOTAL COST OF CARE WHICH
PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE COST TARGETS. THE
BOARD STRUCTURE INCLUDING
CONFLICT OF INTEREST STANDARDS
AN ANTI TRUST ISSUES THE DATES
FOR CITING THE COST TARGETS
HEARING FROM OUR HEALTH PLAN
PARTNERS ABOUT HOW THAT WORKS
FOR THEM IN TERMS OF THEIR
CONTRACTING CYCLE. COORDINATION
BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES FOR
EXAMPLE ON QUALITY AND EQUITY
STANDARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE NOT FOR DUPLICATING EFFORTS
WE'VE DISCUSSED ENFORCEMENT
PPROACH INCLUDING THE SIZE OF
THE PENALTIES AND- AS WELL MANY
MANY TECHNICAL ISSUES AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WITH A PROPOSAL OF THIS
COMPLEXITY. WE A REVISED. EASY
P. WITH A SPRING BY LETTER
CONSIDER HERE AND THE REVISED BY
FROM WORK TOTAL OF A AND FORTY
TWO POSITIONS ONCE WE FULLY
STAFFED YOUR FREE- OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OFFENSE.
SO AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA OF THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE TIME
FUNDING OF THIRTY MILLION
INCLUDING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
WHICH SUPPORTS FIRST YEAR COSTS
AND PORTION OF THE COST FOR THE
SECOND YEAR- AND THE PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES ONGOING CHEN FUND
. PART ACTUALLY THE ONGOING
ANNUAL FOR THE- IS ONE FIVE
HUNDRED NAY OUT. SO I WILL DO
TALK ABOUT THE ADJUSTMENT MADE
THE B. C. P. IS THE TO A LOT YOU
SEE. LAST YEAR'S BE C. P. AND OF
THE READ WE FOR THE OFFICE. WE A
PLANNING AND MANAGE SECTOR WILL
WHICH WE THINK WILL BE CREDIT TO
CORE. POLICY PLANNING AND STATE
IN. ACROSS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM. SO GIVEN THAT THE
OFFICE WILL REQUIRE COMPLEX
POLICY AND STAKEHOLDER
ACTIVITIES ACROSS MANY SECTORS
HEALTHCARE ENTITIES AND POLICY
AREAS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE. DEDICATED
ORGANIZATIONAL STAFF TO PROVIDE
THESE FUNCTIONS. WE INCLUDE
WITHIN THAT SECTION ON OUR
REGION ENGAGEMENT TEAM TO FORGE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE HEALTH
CARE ENTITIES THAT WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE COST TARGETS- THE
INFORMANT WORK WITH A AND- ABOUT
INNOVATIVE ARE. TO REDUCING AS
WE ARE DEVELOPING INFORMATION.
ALFA PRACTICE FOR COST REDUCTION
BOB QUALITY EQUITY WORKFORCE AND
PRIMARY CARE INVESTMENT AND THIS
IS VERY MUCH IN KEEPING WITH
WORK THAT DOING IN BUILDING ALL
CLAIMS DATA OF A- HEALTH
PAYMENTS DATA. WE'VE OUT EVERY
SINGLE HEALTH PLAN IT WILL BE A
SUBMIT OF AND ONE YOU SAME THING
WITH THE OFFICE. WE ALSO INCLUDE
A PLANNING- AND GOT TEAM TO
CORDON PROGRAM POLICIES ACROSS
THE OF THE OF THE PRO IS THE
RIGHT. AND PROGRAMS PONTINS BUT
HE WILL SEE. THE INDEPENDENT
BOARD INCLUDE PREPARING THE-
ARRANGING TOP AND HOW. WITH
MEMBERS OF MINISTRY OF NEEDS AND
THEN FOR A THEY WERE. IT DID-
THE SECTION RECOGNIZE THE- OF
THESE PHONE. INCLUDING STATE IN
. VERSUS AN ADVISER BOARD AS WAS
IN LAST YEAR LANGUAGE. WE'VE
ALSO CREATED A WORK FOR AND CARE
YOU. WHICH WILL BE ALTAMONT AND
PROMOTING HEALTH CARE WORK FOR
STABILITY AND MEASURING AND
PROMOTING SYSTEM WIDE INVESTMENT
IN PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SOME THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A DEDICATED
ORGANIZATIONAL UNITS- TO PROVIDE
THESE FUNCTIONS. WE ALSO CREATED
AND ACQUISITIONS AND MANAGEMENT
UNIT- SO GIVEN THE PROGRAM SIZE
AND COMPLEXITY WE REASSESS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. TO THE DOCTOR
PANTS WHITE- WE HAVE RE. THE
MINISTRY OF SUPPORT NEEDED- AND
SO CREATED THIS ACQUISITION
MANAGEMENT UNIT- WITH-
SUFFICIENT ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
AND IT STAFF TO SUPPORT THIS
COMPLEX PROGRAM SO THOSE ARE THE
MAJOR CHANGES- IN THE B. C. P.
AND VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. GIVE
MUCH DEPARTMENT OF FINE. YES I
AM NO COME THANK YOU WHICH SHE-
THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN COURT
ISSUED A FROM THE WE HAVE- NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THIS ON THIS
ISSUE I AM TOOK THIRD PRINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN FIRST ALL
I WANT THANK DETER. IN INDUSTRY
FOR THE ON GOING COVER THE WAY
LOW FORWARD. HAVING AN AGREED
UPON- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
FINALLY IMPLEMENT- THIS VERY
IMPORTANT OFFICE- THIS YEAR I
KNOW OF WE WERE ABLE TO PULL IT
OFF LAST YEAR BUT HOPEFULLY THIS
YEAR WILL BE THE YEAR. I GUESS
THE- QUESTION I HAVE BEEN IN A
KNOW THAT- YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHANGES. IN TERMS
OF- THE ANALYTIC CAPACITY OF THE
STAFF- IS THERE IS THERE IS
TERE A UNIT THAT'S- AND-
INCLUDE. WELL- BACK. AND OTHER
TYPES TO BE FOR SOME WHAT THE-
WHEN THE FUNCTION OF THE OFFICE
IS TO DEVELOP THESE RISK
ADJUSTERS AND EQUITY ADJUSTERS
AND SO FORTH AND- AND ALSO
FRANKLY TO MONITOR 2 DEGREES
THAT. AS WE IMPLEMENT THOSE HOW-
VARIOUS ACTORS WILL RESPOND TO
THAT- BUT I THINK FOR MOST PART
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL BE BEHAVING
IN A WAY TO TRY TO IMPROVE
EQUITY AND- AND INCREASED FOCUS
ON. IMPROVING THE HEALTH OF
PEOPLE CHRONIC CONDITIONS BUT
THERE'S ALSO CERTAINLY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO TRY
TO GAME THE SYSTEM AS WELL. AND
SO BE ABLE TO MONITOR- NO
BEHAVIOR LIVING FOR- THAT DOES
WELL. USING THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR OFFICE CLAIMS PAYER
DATABASE AND OTHER DATA SOURCES
THAT REUSING- SO- AND I STAY AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT FOR EXAMPLE-
YOU KNOW MEDIC CAL'S- LOOKING
AT. SOME OF THIS AS WELL- WHEN
IT COMES TO IMPLEMENT TALION AND
SO FORTH SO THERE'S PERHAPS
SOME. AGENCIA. LEARN THAT COULD
. ALSO TAKE PLACES WELL BUT IN
TERMS OF- H. KIND THE OFFICE HOW
FOR THE WITHIN THE STAFF. IS
GOING TO THAT CAN YOU JUST
MAYBE. THE ANALYTICAL CAPACITY
OF THE STAFF TO ANALYZE ALL THIS
DATA THAT THIS OFFICE IS GOING
TO BE- THE ONLY HAVING ACCESS TO
BE IS GONNA HAVE TO ANALYZE IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE TYPES OF. VERY
IMPORTANT DECISIONS THE OFFICE
IS GOING TO MAKE. OF COURSE AND
YOUR FRIEND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I WILL START AND THEN
I'LL ASK MS GOT CHRISTMAS TO
JOIN- AND ADD ON. A WITH MORE
SPECIFICS BUT ABSOLUTELY IN
TERMS OF- THERE THERE'S BOTH THE
INFORMATION CAPTURE AND THEN I
THINK THE KEY IS YOU'RE FOCUSING
ON IS THE- IS THE ANALYTICS DONE
WITH THE INFORMATION SO. WE AS
YOU KNOW- HAVE MANY DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE- COLLECTING
COMPLICATED DATA AND SO WE DO
PLAN TO USE OUR EXISTING
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION.
FOR THE IN PART OF. THE DATA IN
THE SYSTEM SO THAT'S THE TEAM
THAT. HAS LONG CAPTURED. OUR OUR
PATIENT LEVEL DATA ON IS. ALL
HERE. BASED AND THEN. WE ALL
LOOK TO THE TO HELP. THE THIS.
DATE ON THE TWO COST CARE ENOUGH
DATA THE OFFICE. AND THEN
ABSOLUTELY. WE DO HAVE
ANALYTICS- STAFF BUILT INTO THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH. AFFORDABILITY
AUSTIN'S RICHMOND'S TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS BUT-
ALSO JUST WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT ABSOLUTELY WE- WILL BE.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MEDIC COW
COVERED CALIFORNIA. AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE BOTH THAT WE HAVE.
CLOSE COLLABORATION TERMS OF THE
DATA COMING IN. AND ALSO THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA IS
USEFUL TO THEM SO FOR EXAMPLE.
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS DATA. SYSTEM
WE'RE ALREADY GETTING MEDIC HELP
SPEED- WE'VE- HAD- TEACH YES
STAFF VERY CLOSELY INVOLVED IN
THE BUILD OUT AND INTO SPENT
DOING THE SAME. IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD A- OF
THE ANALYTIC. STAFF AND
CAPACITY. YEAH THIS CONGRESS GW
DIRECTOR I. JUST SENT TO REPORT
CITING. AGAIN AS- ON INDICATED
WILL WILL LET. EXIST INCREASE.
EXPERTISE FOR DECLARE DATA MAY.
SAID AND THEN. YES BILL OUT NEW
AND PASS. SPECIFIC TO THE NEED
THE NEEDS REQUIREMENTS OF THE-
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAM WE WILL BE ABLE TO BRING
TO BEAR- TO YOUR POINT DOCTOR.
WE HAVE EXPERTISE IN RISK.
ADJUSTMENT NOW BUT BASED ON YOU
KNOW OVER THE YEARS OF OUTCOME-
STUDIES WORK- YOU KNOW THAT.
SOMEONE UP LOCAL. LEAVE BUILDING
THE PAST YEAR. WAR HELP ECONOMIC
- FINANCE AND THAT KIND WORK SO
YEAH I THINK. THERE ARE- THE
NEXT WE CAN BRING TO BEAR- IF HE
ON- AND THEN CLEARLY ACT. TO WE
NEED TO BUILD OUT AS PART OF A
NEW. ANALYTICS TEAM THAT THAT WE
PLAN FOR IN IN THE IN THE B. C.
B. OKAY CAN SPEAK TO PERHAPS OF
THE GALAXY TO GO SAYS SENSE OF
CAPACITY SO- HOW MANY. AS WOULD
BE RELATED. THIS ALEX WORK. I
THINK WE HAVE IT'S I THINK WE
HAVE A TWO TEAMS SIX HAVE TO GO
AND CONFIRM FOR YOU THAT'S ABOUT
THE SIZE OF TO SPEEDING AND
WOULD BE AND FULLY GETTING. TO-
OGLE WERE WE ALSO HAVE SORT OF
COLLABORATION WITH OUR EXISTING
TEAMS THAT YOU ARE HEALTH
OUTCOMES STUDIES- IN RISK
ADJUSTMENT- IN THE WORK THERE SO
I THINK WE WILL DO BOTH IN TERMS
OF THOSE KINDS OF NEW NUMBERS
DEDICATED- BUT- FOCUS ON TEAMING
- TO BE ABLE TO BRING- BRING IN-
THOSE KINDS OF TWELVE OF- OF.
BENEFITS FROM EXISTING- EXISTING
WORKERS GOT OKAY. ALL RIGHT WELL
IT'S A I THINK THE IS GOING TO
BE A LITTLE BIT OF ALL BEING AS
WE GET THE STATE OF COURSE YOU
KNOW THE DAY COLLECTION WHO THEN
HAVE. TO CLEAN THE DATA RATE AND
SO FORTH SO YOU'RE VERY LARGE
DATA SETS AND ENDED IN THE
ANALYTICAL PEOPLE I GOT TO BUILD
THAT NO PARTS OUT THE DATA
ANSWER TO TYPE QUESTION. THAT-
POLICYMAKERS NEED TO FINALLY
MAKE THE DECISIONS THAT THE THAT
THIS OFFICE IS CHARGED WITH SO
AND IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT CAN BE REALLY
IMPORTANT SITES- SO I THINK THIS
IS THE THIS PROPOSAL BILL MOUSSA
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION THAT HE
IS GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE MONITOR YOU KNOW WEATHER
ANALYTICS TEAM IS LARGE ENOUGH
FOR NOT AND- AND THEIR CAPACITY
TO BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA. THERE'S A LOT OF DATA A
LOT OF THESE KIND OF MESSY TOO
SO THAT ALWAYS MAKES A LITTLE
HARDER TO ANALYZE IT CETERA AND
BE SURE THAT- THERE'S SUFFICIENT
SUPPORT TO MAKE THAT MAKE THAT
HAPPEN SO I JUST I'LL PUT A PIN
ON THAT SOMETHING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR CERTAINLY FOR US HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE BUT I'M SURE
YOU'LL BE WORKING ON THAT. AND
THEN OF COURSE AS YOU MENTIONED
YOU KNOW EVERY OTHER WORK GOING
ON AND OTHER AGENCIES THAT ALSO
HAVE EXPERIENCE IN OR DOING
OTHER PROJECTS TEAMMATES CD
EIGHT CS OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL
AS. AND THAT. IS THE STATE TO OF
COURSE- YOUR BILL TO MAKE IT.
THE ARE WELL FOR BY BY DATA AND-
THIS AGENCY WILL CERTAINLY HAVE
LOT OF THE- BECAUSE- IS THAT IS
IT OUR INFORMATION THE OTHER.
BUT DO WE NEED TO TURN. INTO OR
THINGS WE CAN ACT ON. AND THAT'S
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT SELL-
APPRECIATE YOUR AND- I THINK YOU
KNOW WE WERE TO KEEP. THAT
INSTANT LIKE YOUR- FROM FROM H.
CHI TERMS OF YOU KNOW DO WE HAVE
ENOUGH IS ABLE IS THAT AND DO WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THE- THE
WORK THAT'S NECESSARY TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISIONS. THANK YOU.
YEAH SO CENTER AND I'LL JUST
JUMP AND WE DO HAVE A HEALTHCARE
COSTS TRENDS BRANCH WITH. WITH A
BRANCH CHIEF FOR THE C. A. LEVEL
OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE A RESEARCH
ANALYTICS SECTION- WITH NINE
STAFF. JUST FOR THE JUST FOR THE
ANALYTICS THEMSELVES UP AGAIN
OUR EXISTING AND THEN WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL STAFF. BURKE YEAH I
BRING THE DATA AND THEN CLEANING
IT SO CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE OTHER
BRANCHES LOOKING SPECIFICALLY
EQUALITY AND EQUITY- WORK FOR
STABILITY. AND PRIMARY CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPEND OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU AS A FORMER A-
SAYS RESEARCHER WHO'S WORKED ON
SECONDARY DATA SETS. IT'S ALWAYS
A LOT. ABOUT IT SOUNDS EASY
UNTIL YOU ACTUALLY DO THE WORK
YOU KNOW THE DATA CLEAN AND ALL
THAT THAT THEY- THEY CAN TAKE A
LOT OF EFFORTS- JUST WANNA BE
SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO DO
IT. THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU-
IN NOW MOVING TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE VERY EXCITING ISSUE I- AND
AGAIN THANKS SO. OF TALK PAN-
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A THIS IS FOR
REDUCING THE COST OF INSULIN THE
CAL ARE REX PROGRAM THE
BIOSIMILAR INSULIN INITIATIVE
AND WE HAVE WITH US BUT CHAU
GHANI ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND BE ABLE
DAVID TAFELBERG PROJECT MANAGER
FOR CALORIE R. ACTS AS WELL AS
RAIN BUCKLEY CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
HOOKER H. CHI WELCOME AND PLEASE
PROCEED. WELCOME GOOD MORNING
TURN INTO POUND. BEFORE GETTING
INTO THIS BUT OF THE APRIL ON
PROPOSAL I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIVE TWO-
ENACTED IN SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WHICH CAUGHT UP
BY THE COLLAR X. PROGRAM. BUT
ONE REQUIREMENT UNDRESSED FIVE
TWO IS THAT PARTNERSHIPS FOR
GENERIC MANUFACTURING. INCLUDE
THE PRODUCTION ABOUT LEAST ONE
FORM OF DENZEL AND PROVIDED A
VIABLE PATHWAY. FOR
MANUFACTURING MORE AFFORDABLE
FORM OF INSULIN EXCESS. AS
WIDELY DOCUMENT- THE INSULIN
MARKET AS LONG THE PIT MAIS THE
MARKET FAILURES PLAGUED THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY. THIS
HAS RESULTED IN KEEPING INSULIN
PRICES HIGHER AND DIRECTLY
HARMING CALIFORNIA AND ITS
RESIDENTS. PARTICULARLY OR
UNDERINSURED DIABETICS
OFTENTIMES PAY HIGH PRICES FOR
THEIR INSULIN SPENDING THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS PER YEAR SHOW FOR
THEIR LIFE SAVING MEDICATIONS.
BASED ON NATIONAL DATA AS MANY
AS ONE FOR DIABETICS CANNOT
AFFORD THEIR INSULIN AND THUS
RATIONED FOR US SHE'S TAKING
INSULIN ALTOGETHER. THE STATE IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO REMEDY
THIS MARKET FAILURE BY BRINGING
MORE AFFORDABLE BIOSIMILAR
INSULINS TO CALIFORNIA.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIRED
PARTNERSHIPS UNDER SB EIGHT FIVE
TWO. BY MESSING FIFTY MILLION
INTO BIOSIMILAR INSULIN
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE CONTRACTOR
. FIFTY MILLION WOULD BE PAID
OUT ACCORDING TO A MILESTONE
PAYMENT SCHEDULE. THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ONLY MAKE
PAYMENTS ACCORDING TO CHIEF MEN
OF CONCRETE MILESTONES SUCH AS
INITIATIONOF CLINICAL TRIALS-
REACHING CLINICAL ENDPOINTS OF A
CLINICAL- REACHING PRIMARY END
POINTS OF CLINICAL TRIALS. M.
AND PROCUREMENT OF HANDLE EVERY
DEVICES AND FDA APPROVAL AND
INTERCHANGE ABILITY RATINGS.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
INVEST AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION. TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A CALIFORNIA
BASED MANUFACTURING FACILITY.
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF HIGH SKILLED HIGH
PAYING JOBS WITHIN THE STATE.
THIS FACILITY WOULD BE AT A
LOCATION JOINTLY DETERMINE
BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
CONTRACTOR. KELLY JAY US WILL
PARTNER WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT LEVERAGING ITS
EXPERTISE IN BUSINESS
INVESTMENT. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES SUCH AS
SIDE RUBIO PERMANENT SUBSTANCE
AND OTHER RELATED ACTIVITIES.
CALLIE JUDGE US WILL LEAN ON GO
BUSINESS EXPERTISE TO MITIGATE
REST IMPROPERLY DELIVER ON THE
PROPOSED MANUFACTURING FACILITY
. SIMILAR TO THE MILESTONES FOR
DRUG DEVELOPMENT PAYMENTS WOULD
ONLY BE MADE FOR REACHING
CERTAIN STAGES SUCH AS SITE
SELECTION AND DOCUMENTED
PURCHASES OF CAPITAL EQUIPMENT.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL COUNTERACTS
WITH IDENTIFIER PARTNER TO BRING
TO MARKET LOW COST
INTERCHANGEABLE BIOSIMILAR
INSULINS. WITH THE GOAL O
PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS WITH
ACCESS TO INSULIN PRODUCTS THAT
ARE A FRACTION OF THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR PER VIAL. WEST
PRICES CURRENTLY CHARGED BY
INSULIN MANUFACTURERS. INJECTING
SUCH STEEP PRICE COMPETITION
WOULD DISRUPT THE CURRENT MARKET
AND EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIABETICS. IN ADDITION TO THE
CONSUMER SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH
LOW PRICED CALAR EXPIRE
BIOSIMILAR INSULINS THE STATE'S
SIX THE FOLLOWING BENEFITS AS
PART OF A POTENTIAL PARTNERSHIP
. THE FIRST AS PRIORITY ACCESS
THIS MEANS CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
A PRIOR OF SUPPLY SO THAT THE
STATE'S VOLUME MADE VOLUME NEEDS
ARE MET. HOWEVER NO MINIMUM
VOLUME COMMITMENT WOULD APPLY TO
THE STATE. SECONDLY BRANDING CAL
CARRICK'S INSULIN PRODUCTS FOR
WHAT WOULD BE CALIFORNIA WILL BE
LABELED WHAT CALIFORNIA RELATED
LABELING. SUCH AS A- CAL GOLDEN
BEAR LOGO OR VERBIAGE THAT SAYS
CALAR EXPENSE LINE BROUGHT YOU
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS A
HIGHLY UTILIZED DRUGS DOES
LABELING WILL CREATE BRAND
AWARENESS AMONG STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS DEMONSTRATE THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING LOW COST
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. THIRD WE
SEEK LOW COST IMPLEMENTATION
WHERE DIRECT MANUFACTURING IN
WHICH THE STATE ITSELF WITHOUT
TOTAL OWNERSHIP OF FACILITIES
AND THE PRODUCTION PROCESS. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO USERS
TO USE CONTRACT MANUFACTURING
THIS APPROACH IS THE LOWEST COST
LOWEST RISK AND MOST
ADMINISTRATOR AT LEVI'S I'VE
FOUGHT. FOR THE STATE TO BRING A
PORTABLE BIOSIMILAR INSULINS TO
MARKET THE STATE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CONTRACT MANUFACTURER TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PRODUCT ROLLOUT
IN DISTRIBUTION. SO THAT THE
PRODUCTS ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIANS. THE PRODUCTS WOULD
BE AVAILABLE THROUGH A VARIETY
OF RETAILERS PHARMACIES AND
OTHER OUTLETS AS WELL AS MAIL
ORDER PHARMACY. TO QUICKLY
EVACUATE IN AGREEMENT WITH A
CONTRACT MANUFACTURER. STATUTORY
CHANGES ARE ALSO PROPOSED THAT
WOULD PROVIDE CONTRACT EXEMPTION
AUTHORITY FOR H. FIVE THE
IMPLEMENTING DEPARTMENT FOR
CALAR ACTS THIS CONTRACT
EXEMPTION WOULD ENABLE THE
QUICKEST PATH. FOR CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS BIOSIMILAR INSULINS IN
THE FUTURE CALAR ACTS COULD ALSO
INTRACTABLE INTO PARTNERSHIPS
FOR OTHER DRUGS IT'S
EXPERIENCING MARKET FAILURES
BESIDES INSULIN. BRINGING HELLO
SINCE WHEN THE MARKET REFLECTS
THE PRIORITIES OF BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR LOWERING
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS. THIS
MEANS BEARINGS TO BE UNINSURED
UNDERINSURED AND THOSE WITH HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PLANS- AS THESE
CONSUMERS ARE EXPOSED TO HIGH
LIST PRICES. AS WELL AS TO HELP
PLANS YOU CAN OBTAIN A LOWER
PRICE AND SO ON THAN WHAT THEY
CURRENTLY GET AND NOT PRICES
AFTER PHARMACY REBATES.
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS TO THE
BROADER BROADER MARKET- CAN
OCCUR IF OVER TIME THE BRANDED
INSULIN MARKET MAKERS TO LOWER
THEIR PRICES IN RESPONSE. FOR
PATIENT HELP THERE WOULD BE
INCREASED ADHERENCE TO INSULIN
REGIMENS THEREBY IMPROVING THE
HEALTH OUTCOMES OF DIABETICS AND
ELIMINATING ADVERSE EVENTS
RATIONING SUCH AS DIABETES
KETOACIDOSIS. IN CLOSING
STATEMENT GENERIC MANUFACTURING
REPORT INSULIN WILL PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR MILLIONS OF DIABETICS
AND GENERATE SYSTEM WIDE SAVINGS
AND ADVANCE THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES A AND
OUTCOMES EXPERIENCED BY THOSE
WITH DIABETES. THIS CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION AND I'M HAPPY WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THAT'S
JUST ALSO FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE NOTICED ALL COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY ILIO.
THANK YOU THE CHRISTIAN MORROW
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE AND OFFICE-
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST NOTE THAT
IF THE PROPOSAL IS SUCCESSFUL AT
REDUCING THE COST OF INSULIN
THAT WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFIT TO THE STATE AND ITS
RESIDENTS. PROBABLY NOT THIS
WOULD BE A FAIRLY LARGE
INVESTMENT- ONE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME WHICH
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX- BEN. THE
STATE WOULD LIKELY NEED TO WORK
WITH A PARTNER THAT DOES NOT TO
HAPPEN I WAS OVER IN A IN SOME
PRODUCTS ON THE MARKET WE NEED
AT FDA- NEEDS TO DETERMINE THAT
THE INSULIN IS NOT MEANINGFULLY
DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED INSULIN PRODUCTS AND
THAT PHARMACIES CAN SWITCH OUT
BRANDON INSULIN PRESCRIPTIONS
WITH THE PRODUCT BRINGS A
PRODUCT TO HAS BECOME MORE
STREET AND WE YEARS BUT IT STILL
CARRIES CHALLENGES. I WANT TO
PROVE AND PRODUCE THEIR COULD
ALL BE TOM TO THE PRO IS A TO
CONSUMER. AS SUCH IT IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THE STATE'S. AND LONG
TERM INTEREST OF CORPORATE. THE
NEW IN. THAT THE RELEASE OF THE
FUNDING TO THE CONTRACTED FORMER
WOULD BE TIED TO IT IN CERTAIN
MILESTONES. HOWEVER DETAILS ON
WHAT THESE MILESTONES WOULD BE
HAVE NOT PROVIDED AT THIS TIME.
AND LONGER TERM WHAT THE
CONTRACT A PLUMBER HAS RECEIVED
THE FULL AMOUNT OF FUNDING IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT LEVERAGES STATE
WOULD HAVE TO PROTECT. TRAVIS
WHAT THE MINISTRY HAS TO THAT IN
TO GO. THE PARTNERSHIP BEYOND
THE FUNDING. TO KEEP PRICES LOW.
THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP REMAINS UNCLEAR.
AND POTENTIALLY COULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL LEGAL LIABILITIES FOR
THE STATE. WE ALSO FIND THAT
THERE WAS A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
AND OVERSIGHT. BUILT INTO THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE MINISTRATION HAS
STATED THAT IT INTENDS TO WORK
AS A CONSOLE INTO MY THE
CONTRACTED PARTNERS PROGRESS.
BUT THIS INFORMATION WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC OR TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
OVERSIGHT IS FOR THE COMPOUNDED
BY. A QUEST FOR AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE STATE'S CONTRACTING
RULES THE TWENTY TWO. THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF THE PARTNERSHIP COULD
JUST FIND EXTENSION PROJECT
CONTRACTING. POWER IS UNCLEAR
WHY THE X. EXTENDING THIS
EXEMPTION IS NOT NEEDED BEYOND
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX PERIOD WHEN THE FUNDING
WHICH WINDOW EXPIRES. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CHOOSES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROPOSAL- PRIOR TO THE STATE
ENTERED INTO A CONTRACT FIRST
REQUIRED ADMINISTRATION LIVE FOR
THE NIGHT LIST OF MILESTONES
THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
CONTRACT. YOU COULDN'T STEPS FOR
PROVIDING A VIABLE PATH TO FDA
APPROVAL. SECOND REQUIRE
PROVISIONS STATE CAUGHT IN THE
CONTRACT TO PRINT THE STATE
DIRECTOR PURCHASED INSULIN COSTS
AT LEAST UNTIL STATE SAVINGS
EXCEED THE STATE INVESTMENT IN
THE PARTNERSHIP. IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- IN THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T ACTUALLY
SPECIFY WHAT THE PRICE WOULD BE
FOR THE INCIDENT PRODUCT AND
THAT LIKELY WOULD NOT BE
DETERMINED UNTIL THEY ARE FULLY
. THIRTY WE'RE EGGMAN REQUIRING
A PER IN THE- THAT PROVIDES FOR
PENALTIES IN IF THE CONTRACT.
FAILS TO MEET THE OF THE CAR. TO
ENSURE THE STATE INTERESTS
PROTECT. FOURTH WE RECOMMEND
REQUIRED A REVIEW BY CAN. SUCH
AS THE GENERAL OF THE CONTRACT
LANGUAGE FOLLOWING. THE
NEGOTIATION WITH THE POTENTIAL
HARPER BUT BEFORE THE CONTRACT
IS ENTERED INTO. WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON SHOWING THEIR
PROVISIONS FOR THAT FACT THE
STATE'S INTEREST AND MINIMIZE
LIABILITY. IT WE RECOMMEND
TAKING THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING. ON A THIRTY DAY REVIEW
PERIOD BY THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. OF THE
CONTRACT TERMS OF MILESTONES.
AND SIX RECOMMEND REQUIRING THAT
THE CONTRACTED PARVO
DEMONSTRATED ABILITY TO RAISE
SUFFICIENT CAPITAL TO COVER ANY
REMAINING POTS. ASIDE FROM THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT TO BRING IT
THE INSULIN PRODUCT MARKET. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING AMOUNT WOULD NOT BE
SUFFICIENT TO. BRING AN INSULIN
PRODUCT TO MARKET AND SELL
CONTACTED FORMER WOULD NEED-
SEPARATE. ONE THE CONTRACT IS
ENTER INTO RECOMMENDED THE LESS
RICK QUARTERLY UPDATES BETWEEN
BUDGET COMMITTEE ON PROGRESS
TOWARDS A CONTRACT MILESTONES TO
ENSURE SOME LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND OPEN CREATING
OFTEN COMPLEX SPATIAL PROVIDE
ANY NECESSARY OVERSIGHT. FINALLY
WELL THE NEED NATURE THE-
CONTRACTUAL PARTNERSHIP AS WELL
THE STATE IS R. TO BRING UP. THE
FILE SIMILAR. TO MARKET IN A
TIMELY MANNER OR- PROVIDE SOME
RATIONALE FOR BY AN EXTENSION TO
THE CONTRACTING RULES GOING TO
FORGET ABOUT PAIN. IN THE
PRODUCT- TO ENTER THE MARKET
PLACE THE LITERATURE MIGHT WISH
TO ASPEN OF THE BENEFITS AND
TRADE OFFS OF ITS PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE TO EXEMPTION STATE
CONTRACTING RULES THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY TWO AS OPPOSED TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY. OF MR
REGARDING CAN YOU SPEAK PLEASE
TO THE NEED FOR THE EXTENDED
CONTRACT. THROUGH THIRTY TWO
VERSUS JUST TWENTY FIVE. DR
EGGMAN ALTERNATE OVER TO RUN
ABOUT THEIR CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER
BUCKLEY YEAH MORNING- THE EXAM
NEEDED BECAUSE THE AGREEMENTS
WITH CONTRACTING. WILL UNUSUAL
CONTRACTS THAT DON'T SQUARELY
FITS SQUARELY WITHIN DDS IS
CURRENT RULES AND PROCEDURES.
UNLIKE TYPICAL CONTRACTS STATES
NOT DIRECTLY RECEIVING GOODS OR
SERVICES AND CONTRACTS OF THE
PERFORMED IN THE CONTEXT OF A
HIGHLY REGULATED COMPLEX
INDUSTRY. BECAUSE OF THIS
UNIQUENESS IS AGREEMENT WILL BE
DIFFICULT FOR REVIEW UNDER
NORMAL ONTRACTING PROCESSES.
WHICH MAY CAUSE SUBSTANTIAL
WASTE. THE TEN YEARS IS. IF THE
PART AGREEMENT FOR CONSOLE HAS
TO BE. BEYOND YEARS BECAUSE OF
UNEXPECTED CIRCUMSTANCES. OUR
NEXT ENTER YOUR- OTHER DRUGS ARE
EXPERIENCING MARKET FAILURES
BESIDES INSULIN AND SO IF WE TRY
TO RESPOND TO DEVELOPMENTS
EITHER- IN THIS PROGRAM ARE IN
THE MARKET IN GENERAL- THE
CONTRACT EXEMPTION WOULD ALLOW
US TO QUICKLY RETAIN- EXPERTS
AND CONSULTANTS TO ASSESS THAT-
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. TO THEM AS MR
BURKE IS THAT IS IN BAD IN YOUR
RESPONSE. ALSO THE REASON WHY WE
DON'T SEE MORE MILESTONES AND-
TRANSPARENCY WITH UPDATES- OUR
THAT IS GOOD DEVELOPING A
SPECIFIC MILESTONES ALSO CAN
REQUIRED- WORKING WITH
CONSULTANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MILESTONES FIT WITHIN THE
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT'S POSSIBLE
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY AND THAT IN
THE CONTRACT WE ARE PROPERLY
DOCUMENTED WHAT WILL HAVE TO BE
A APPROVING UP TO ESTABLISH THE
MILESTONES THAT MET. BEFORE THE
MONEY GOES OUT. SO THE INTENTION
IS TO ESTABLISH THOSE BEFORE
BEFORE THE STATE ENTERS INTO A
CONTRACT. YES BABY MILESTONES
WOULD BE ESTABLISHED BEFORE THAT
AND CAREFULLY DOCUMENTED IN THE
CONTRACT ITSELF. OKAY AND WHAT
ABOUT QUARTER QUARTERLY UPDATES
TO THE LEGISLATURE- I DON'T SEE
WHY DOES THIS COULDN'T BE DONE
OKAY. BUT IT'S TO SO WE ALL IN
IN THEIR A CERTAIN. TO THIS- BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SAYING IT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS THAT WE'RE ENTERING
INTO- IN A IN A VOLATILE
SOMEWHAT. MARKET IF YOU WILL AGE
WITH PHARMACEUTICALS. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY SO WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT MORE INFORMATION- WORK
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW TRYING TO RETAIN EXPERT
COUNCIL- WITH WITH- TRONG-
EXPERIENCING CONNECTIONS IN LIFE
SCIENCES- SO BE OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS. OKAY BECAUSE- WE ARE
ALL. VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL BUT I'M BUT I'M SURE
ALL OF US HAVE THEM YOU KNOW
HAVE A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE
HAD WITH CONTRACTING AND
TRANSPARENCY AND HOLDING-
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE WHO
FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES THEY THEY
SEE CALIFORNIAN THEY SEE IT AS A
AS A AS A GIANT ATM MACHINE-
WITHOUT BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE I
KNOW WE'RE CLOSING THE VOLUNTEER
LAB. IN QUIETLY KIND OF AS WE
SPEAK HERE- AND AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GETTING INTO ANOTHER BIG
MASSIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT THAT AGAIN WE ALL AGREE
THE OF THE GOALS ARE REALLY
GOOD- BUT AGAIN THE DEVIL IS
ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS SO I THINK
WE'LL BE HAVING A LOT MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AS WERE
THOSE YOU'RE ESTABLISHING- THE
CONSULTANT AND- BECAUSE THERE
ARE A LOT OF UNKNOWNS- WITH A-
WITH A VERY BIG PRICE TAG.
THIRTY FIFTH. THANK YOU AND-
ACTUALLY A DAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MONTH TO
CLARIFY I THINK SOME VERY
IMPORTANT POINTS HERE- SO FIRST
OF ALL I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- ACTUALLY- ARE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE PASSED SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO WHICH IS THE FOLLOW UP
A BILL TO TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION SO I THINK THAT
WORKS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
TRAILER BILL AND TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE. WELL THINGS I WANTED
TO BUILD AND- PERHAPS-
MINISTRATION CAN YOU CAN ADDRESS
THIS IS THAT- WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE I KNOW WE TALKED SO-
SOME STREET. TALK TO- THE- THAT
WERE WORKING YOU KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE THIS CONTRACT SO FORTH BUT
I THINK MORE ACCURATELY. BECAUSE
NOW MY ORIGINAL LEGISLATION
WHICH WE REFER TO- YOU KNOW
TALKED ABOUT THE STATE DURING
THE MANUFACTURING ITSELF NOW.
THE CHALLENGE THERE IS OF
COURSE- OUR STATE DOESN'T HAVE
EXPERIENCE. DRUG MANUFACTURERS
IS AGAIN A HIGHLY COMPLEX HIGHLY
REGULATED- IN THE ENDEAVOR HERE
UNITED STATES FOR APPROPRIATE
REASONS FOR PATIENT SAFETY AND
SO FORTH. AND SO THE STRATEGY
NOW IS TO FIND A PARTNER. BUT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE WORD
PARTNER OKAY AND THEN WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS THAT. FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT SIMPLY A
CONTRACT RIGHT OKAY SO WE HAVE
SOME MONEY WE CONTRACT AND
SOMEONE ELSE IS GONNA GO
MANUFACTURE DRUGS BUT THAT.
ACTUALLY WERE FORMING A
PARTNERSHIP IN FACT THE STATE
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE A GOVERNMENT
STAKE. IN EXCHANGE FOR PART OF
IT THE FUNDING. SO THAT- WEEK SO
IT'S NOT JUST THAT WE HAVE A-
CONTRACT AND IF YOU DON'T FOLLOW
THE CONTRACT WILL TAKE YOU TO
COURT OR WHATEVER ELSE WITH OLD
MONEY BUT- WE ACTUALLY HAVE. AT
LEAST SOME SAY IN DECISIONS
BEING MADE BY THE COUNTRY THE
ENTITY BECAUSE A PARTNERSHIP.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY OF A SAY IN.
ENTITY IN TERMS OF THEIR-
OPERATIONS AND DECISION MAKING
IS. IS THAT IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT MAYBE MORE
AT THE- AS THE ATTORNEY ALWAYS.
CAUTION WITH THE USE OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH MORE OF IT AND
INVESTMENTS OF WHERE I WAS FAT
INVESTMENT WOULD COME-
PARTICIPATION IN THE GOVERNANCE
AND TO BE ABLE TO- TRY TO YOU
KNOW STEER HOW THAT INVESTMENT
IS UTILIZED. RIGHT SO IN OTHER
WORDS WE WEEK WE DO ACTUALLY OF-
YEAR AGAIN OBVIOUSLY IS THAT THE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WERE
DIFFERENT AS A DIFFERENT BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT I THINK SUPPORT
HAVE REPORTS AND SO FORTH. BUT
THE STATE ITSELF AS A WHOLE IS
AN ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY. WILL
HELP MAKE INVESTMENT IT'S NOT
MERELY A CONTRACT WHERE WE'RE
SAYING OKAY WELL WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT. YOU KNOW YOU'RE FIFTY
MILLION GIVE US HOW MANY VIALS
OF INSULIN RIGHT. IT'S AND IT'S
AN ONGOING RELATIONSHIP
INVESTMENTS- OF COURSE THIS
FIRST WITH INSULIN BUT IS ALSO
PRESENTED TO DEFY OTHER DRUGS
WHERE. WE WOULD ACTUALLY AS AN
INVESTOR HAVE A SAY AS TO WHICH
ONES ARE MOST IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA AND STEER THE
DIRECTION. OF THE OF THE- OF
THIS ENTITY. TO TOWARD OUR
PRIORITIES. IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S IN FOR
OBVIOUSLY. YOU KNOW THE STATE'S
LEVERAGING STEERING THE
PROGRAMMER THIS THIS PROJECT ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER WOULD BE RELATIVE
TO THE TO THE SIZE OF THE
INVESTMENT A SLIGHTLY SURE AND-
AND OUR STAND. WELL WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT CONTROLLING STAKE
WE'RE MAKING A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT WOULD HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL SAY. THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY. I DID I DID SO IT IS SO- I
DO THINK THAT AGAIN WITH THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE STATE
ACTUALLY MANY FACTIONS ON
ACTUALLY THIS IS THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A- HYBRID APPROACH
BUT I MEAN THIS ISN'T ANYWAY.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE'RE
PARTNERING WITH AN ENTITY TO HAS
EXPERIENCE. RIGHT BECAUSE-
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW WE NEED THAT
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE RIGHT-
WE CAN JUST GET THAT FROM
CONSULTANTS- WE HAVE ACTUALLY
OTHER INVESTORS THAT LEVERAGES
OUR MONEY. RIGHT SO IT'S NOT
JUST CALIFORNIA. TRYING TO DO
THIS ON BY OURSELVES. BUT WE'RE
ALSO LEVERAGING OTHER INVESTORS
AND ALSO- THE POTENTIAL OF
COURSE OF- THE MARKET YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE A LARGER MARKET
RATE BECAUSE OTHER INVESTORS ARE
NOT JUST INTO IN CALIFORNIA. I
MEAN THIS IS ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
MARKET THESE- THESE GENERIC
MEDICATIONS STARTING WITH
INSULIN- ACTUALLY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY RIGHT- AND- AND OF
COURSE WE FEEL. IN IN IN THE
CONTRACT PART- WE'RE GONNA SET
GROUND RULES FOR THIS INVESTMENT
RIGHT ENSURING THAT. YEAH THIS
IS AT COSTS THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
IT AND SO FORTH AND THAT- AND AT
THE CHIEF'S OF. BILLS THAT THAT
WE SEE. IS THAT IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY SO TO ME
I'M CERTAINLY I.
NOW THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT-
PERHAPS ALSO. SOMETHING THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THAT PERHAPS NEED
TO BE. MORE CLARIFIED TO THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT BUT I ACTUALLY
THINK. IN SOME WAYS- GIVEN THE
NATURE OF HOW WE'RE STRUCTURING
THIS AND INVESTMENT AND
RECOGNIZING WE ARE WE ARE
VENTURING INTO. A THE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT. IN TERMS OF- ACTUALLY
BEING A L. PARTICIPANT AND THIS-
VIED SAID KIND OF A DIFFERENT
FORM OF OVERSIGHT. AS WELL THAT.
WILL ACTUALLY BE BENEFICIAL TO
THE STATE THAT IS ACTUALLY A
LITTLE CLOSER TO THE VISION OF
WHAT WE WANTED WHEN I AUTHORED
PREVIOUS BILL AND THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET. THAT
THIS REALLY IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION IT'S NOT NOT MERELY-
WELL WE- I JUST GOT A CONTRACT
THIS ALL OUT BUT ACTUALLY WE'RE
PARTNERING WITH PEOPLE MAKING AN
INVESTMENT TO AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE IN A POSITION AND ALL OF
THIS. IN WHAT COMES OUT TO OF
COURSE NOT ONLY DO INSULIN WHICH
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND WILL WAS A
PRIORITY- BUT ALSO TO ADDRESS
OTHER- MEDICATIONS OR DRUGS-
WHERE YOU KNOW THERE ARE MARKET
FAILURES BUT TO ADD TO IT. BUT
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE-
AFFORDABLE AND ALSO A RELIABLE
SUPPLY OF MEDICATIONS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO I
THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
MOVING TOWARD- TO DO- CREATE THE
WORK OF THE MINISTRATION- WE'VE
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS- THEY'LL
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT L. A.
O. SAID IN TERMS OF BEING YOU
KNOW HAVING MORE INFORMATION
BEING SHARED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT PERHAPS SOME
OF THE DETAILS- NOW MILESTONES
AND SO FORTH ALSO READ
RECOGNIZING THAT. NOW THIS IS-
IS SOMEWHAT CUT YOU KNOW AGAIN
IT'S A COMPLEX MARKET THERE'S A
LOT OF REGULATIONS THAT'S
ACTUALLY THAT ACTUALLY WORKS IN
OUR VANTAGE SOMEPLACE- MAY MAKE
IT A LITTLE SLOWER THAN WE'D
LIKE IT TO MOVE ALONG BECAUSE WE
DON'T CONTROL THAT FTA OTHERS.
OTHERS DO BUT BUT ALSO SHARES-
THIS IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LET'S SAY TYPICAL CONTRACT WOULD
SO I KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE TO
GET A LITTLE NERVOUS WELL WHO'S
WATCHING WHO'S WHO'S WATCHING
THINGS BUT- THAT THERE ARE GONNA
BE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF OVERSIGHT.
I THINK IN THIS PROPOSAL THAT-
PERHAPS WOULDN'T EXIST AND SOME
OTHER TYPES OF CONTRACTS. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT IT IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING MORE TO SPEAK TO
THAT- IN TERMS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POINT OF VIEW.
BUT YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL STRUCK.
OF HOW WE WILL HAVE TO BE WITH
OUR- COUNT. IN SEE HOW TO HAVE
BEST INCORPORATE THAT. GIVEN
THE- CARE STRUCTURE WHATEVER
PARTNER OR PARTNERS THAT THAT WE
END UP WORKING WITH. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE-
WILL BE THINKING DR PEPPER'S
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AIRSPACE FOR
YEARS TO COME ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE LOWER COST INSULIN HITS THE
MARKET. OKAY MOVING ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR SMALL RULE- HOSPITAL
IMPROVEMENT. INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY I THINK
WE'VE GOT THAT MS RESULT BACK
AGAIN. YES- GOOD MORNING- IT
APARTMENT THAT HEALTHCARE ACCESS
INFORMATION AGE CRIED REQUESTED
INCREASING EXPENDITURE GLORIA
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AN ON GOING FROM
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND TO
SUPPORT. THE TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE SMALL RURAL
HOSPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
WORSHIP. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO WHEN- ARE SPREAD WAS RECAST
AS H. HI THIS INCLUDING
CONSOLIDATION OF THE STATE
OFFICE OF RURAL HEALTH. AND ITS
ASSOCIATED FEDERAL. H. CRIED.
RESOURCES AND SERVICE
ADMINISTRATION HERSELF TO SERVE
AS THE STATE'S PRIMARY CARE
OFFICE IN STATE OFFICE OF RURAL
HEALTH- WITH THAT STATE OFFICE
OF RURAL HEALTH PROGRAM H. K. B.
C. FEATURES A GRANT FOR SHIP IN
THE MEDICARE RURAL HOSPITAL
FLEXIBILITY GRANT. THE SHIP
GRANT ALLOWS EACH TRY TO PROVIDE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY NINE QUALIFYING SMALL
WORLD HOSPITALS. TO SUPPORT THEM
IN MEETING A VARIETY OF SCHOOLS-
BECOMING ACCOUNTABLE CARE
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSITE
PARTICIPATING IN SHARED SAVINGS
PROGRAMS- PURCHASING HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY- AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES. IN THE CURRENT
ON GOING BATTLE SHIP GRANT
PROJECT CREATE. INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM TO THE
STATE OFFICE OF CIVIL HELD TO
ACCOUNT FOR ADDITIONAL SMALL
RURAL HOSPITALS AND ALLOW STATES
TO MAXIMIZE AWARDS TO THESE
HOSPITALS. SO H. K. IS
REQUESTING AN INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY THAT
CORRESPONDS WITH THE INCREASE IN
FEDERAL FUNDING WE ARE RECEIVING
AVAILABLE FOR THE CHIP PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THIS IS ALL
. FINANCE NOTICE FROM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SHE TO. THE
CENTER EGGMAN KOREA SHE TO DE
LA- I'M WE HAVE NO OR AND THIS
IS ITEM. NOR DO I DO PLAN
ANYTHING OF A MS RESULT LET'S
MOVE ON A NUMBER FOR. THIS JUST
ALSO. FINANCE ACTUALLY PRESENT
ITEMS FIRE. CANNATECH FOR APRIL
FINANCE WATER. THE H. CARE BE
REQUESTING PROVISIONAL SYSTEM
INCOME AND EXPENDITURE TO
ADMINISTER PER. FOR CHILDREN
HERE'S HEALTH INITIATIVE TO JUNE
THIRTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY INNINGS
. TWENTY TWO TWENTY STATE FUNDS
WHICH ACROSS SIX POINT THREE
MILLION WERE APPROVED IN THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AS
PART OF EACH CLIENT'S COMPONENT
OF A LARGER INITIATIVE AND THE
ABILITY TO SPEND OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS IS CRUCIAL. HI MISTER
PROGRAMS INCLUDE IT- IN THE
NATION THIS LANGUAGE WILL ALSO
ALIGN WITH EACH KIND OF SMALL
TELL YOUR STORY FOR LOCAL SYSTEM
FUNDS OFFICIATED WITH. THE
INITIAL. WELL TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FACING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER BUSH. I HAVE NO NO
COMMENTS ON THE SITE THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN OKAY HELLO
DOCTRINE OF- LET'S MOVE THEN TO
ISSUE NOT SIX. GREAT THIS IS
KEREN RIGHTS- AGAIN AND- I'LL
START- BY DESCRIBING THE HEALTH
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
ARE MEDICATIONS THE DOCTOR DID
THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL
IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
AND HOW THESE PREVIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS AND HER CURRENT
PROPOSED AUGMENTATIONS ADDRESS
THE FRAGMENTATION CALIFORNIA
TEACHER HELP WORKFORCE
COMMISSION I'M EXCITED TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY A VARIETY OF OUR
ON. GOING ACTIVITIES AND FINANCE
. EIGHT FONG APPROPRIATION IN
THE F. TWO TWENTY ONE BUDGET
RECEIVE SEE NOW ARE GOING TO SIT
THE HELP PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM OR WHAT
WE'RE CALLING HIP-HOP SUITE OF
PROGRAMS. H. GUYS BEEN PREPARING
TO IMPLEMENT A NEW PORTFOLIO
PROGRAMS UNDER THE HIP HOP
FUNDING AND STATUES. THERE A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
AND IDEAS TO SUPPORT HIGH FLYING
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAMS. AND
ACTIVITIES SO WE WANTED TO
DEVELOP A SUITE OF PROGRAMS THAT
IS POSSIBLE WELL INTEGRATED AND
SUPPORTS THE INTENT OF THE
STATUTE AND THE GROUNDWORK LAID
OUT IN THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
REPORT. SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE POINT ONE
ONE POINT TWO. WE ARE PLANNING
TO RELEASE OUR NEW APPLICATION
BY MID JUNE AND THIS PROGRAM
WILL CREATE A FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY FOR PIPELINING
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
CAREERS IN PRIMARY CARE.
BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH AND HOW IT
HELPS FOR EXAMPLE. THIS RELEASE
GETTING OF OUR WAY AND WE
CONTINUE GROWING EXPANDING OUR
WE SUPPOSED OVER TIME. WE HAVE
ALSO OR HEALTH EXPLORING FROM.
WITH OF SOME FINE TO SUPPORT A
DAY CREE EXPO GRANTS THIS
ALLOWED TO WORK THIRTY PROGRAMS
USING HIP HOP GERIATRICS AND
CHILDREN USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
CAREER AWARENESS OF PRIMARY CARE
GERIATRICS IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CAREERS. WE ALSO RECEIVED TEN
POINT FIVE MILLION A ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. I HAVE EXECUTED THE
GRANT AGREEMENT WITH THE
MANAGING AGENCY THE FOUNDATION
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR THIS PROGRAM
ANOTHER PIPE LINING CAREER
PATHWAY PROGRAM AND THAT PROGRAM
IS UNDERWAY. THIS PROGRAM ALSO
CLEARLY SUPPORTS THE WORK
OUTLINED IN THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION REPORT. ADDITIONAL
PUTTING THEM IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET INCLUDING FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR A
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR HOME HEATING
SERVICES WORKFORCE PROGRAM. WE
HAVE AWARDED A FIVE MILLION
GRANTS WITH POWERDVD FROM THAT A
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
HEALTH CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM.
WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGING WITH A
CONSULTANT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE WORK FLOOR WORKFORCE
LANDSCAPE FOR CNA'S OTHER DIRECT
CARE WORKERS. AND DEVELOP A SET
OF PROGRAM PRIORITIES WE EXPECT
TO OPEN NEW FUNDING CYCLES AND
PROGRAMS LATER IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THAT WILL TRAINED CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANTS AND BUILD THE
DIRECT CARE WORKFORCE FOR
CURRENT. WORK BUILDS AND
STRENGTHENS THE WORKFORCE
SERVING AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. AND HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. OUR
PROJECT WILL ALSO RESULT IN
ARTICULATING SUPPORTING. CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR THIS WORKFORCE.
THIS SUPPORTS THE AND RECOMMEND
. OF THE FUTURE HELP WORK CAN TO
CARE FOR ALL ADULTS. AND BUILD
THE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES WORKFORCE. ADDITIONALLY
WE RECEIVED EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN GERIATRICS FUNDING.
SO FAR THIS YEAR WITH THIS
FUNDING WE HAVE AWARDED OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR PROVIDERS SERVING
OLDER ADULTS. AND ALSO ALLOCATED
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH CAREERS
EXPLORATION PROGRAM. THE FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
REPORT IDENTIFIED GERIATRICS AS
A PRIORITY PROFESSION BY
CREATING A WORK FORCE BETTER
ABLE TO SUPPORT HEALTHY AGING
AND CARE FOR OLDER ADULTS. ARE
GERIATRICS FUNDING IS TARGETED
TOWARD THESE EFFORTS BY
SUPPORTING HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
SERVING OLDER ADULTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE RECEIVE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN SONG BROWN
PROGRAM OFTEN CATION- H. KYLE
OPEN THE PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
GRANT APPLICATIONS SPRING TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH INCLUDES THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATIONS OR- NEW PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM. WHAT A
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ON
MEDITATION IS PART REGISTERED
NURSING TRAINING PROGRAMS WE
JUST RECENTLY AWARDED TWENTY
THREE PROGRAMS OVER NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING. THE WORK OF
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM IS
DIRECTLY IN LINE WITH THE WORK
OF THE COMMISSION. BUILDING
PRIMARY CARE FACETTI PROVIDER
DIVERSITY ARE KEY COMPONENTS OF
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM AND ALSO
THE FOCUS OF THE COMMISSION. THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM SUPPORTS THE
COMMISSIONTOP TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TWO POINT TWO.
TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN AND PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY POSITIONS AND ONE OF
THEIR KEY STRATEGIES TO ALIGN
AND EXPAND EDUCATION TRAINING TO
PREPARE HEALTH WORKERS TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S. HEALTH NEEDS. I
NEXT WILL PROVIDE AN UPDATE OUR
ACTIVITIES FOR THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WAS A KEY FOCUS OF THE FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION AND
INTEGRATED INTO THE COMMISSION
STRATEGIES AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE WORK OF THE CHORE NHÌP HERE
THE NEW SHE DID SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FOCUS. INCLUDING FOR DEVELOPING
A BEHAVIOR HEALTH FIVE FLIGHT
INCREASING PSYCHIATRY AND
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS FOR EXAMPLE. FAR
WORK IN THIS INITIATIVE IS SPLIT
ACROSS TWO WORK STREAMS THE
FIRST IS CREATING A SCHOOL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH.
WORKFORCE WHERE DEVELOPING A
FRAMEWORK IN A PLAN TO LAUNCH
AND IMPLEMENT THIS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACH ROLE. IN STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH EXPERTS IN
EDUCATION AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND WILL BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION IN
EARLY SUMMER. OUR OTHER
WORKSTREAM ADDRESSES THE BROAD
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
ACROSS EIGHT OF MODULES AND
ACTIVITIES. ONE OF THEM IS TO
BUILD THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PIPELINE. AS I DISCUSS
OUR AGE FIFTY. OBSOLETED
PROGRAMS INCLUDES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CATEGORIES RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO BUILD IT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE IT SERVES A
DIVERSE CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
OTHER- ACTIVITIES AROUND
EXPANDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. H. GUYS CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT THE UC IRVINE TRAINING
TRAINERS CHECKUP PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. WHICH
PROVIDES TRAINING FOR PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS TO EFFECTIVELY
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT COMMON LANE
COUNTERATTACKING ENTRY
CONDITIONS WE HAVE AWARDED ABOUT
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION IN
FOR THAT PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS ONE OF THE
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
FIVE FIVE IT'S TO STRENGTHEN
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS I'M BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND WELLNESS USING TRAIN THE
TRAINER MODALITIES. ADDITIONALLY
OF THE INITIATIVE INCLUDES WORK
TO ENHANCE THE PURE PERSONNEL
TRAINING AND PLACEMENT PROGRAM.
WE OPEN THE APPLICATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM ON APRIL TWENTY NINTH
AND IT SUPPORTS THE TRAINING
CERTIFICATION AND PLACEMENT OF
YOUR PERSONNEL AND TO BE ABLE
HEALTH SYSTEM. YOUR PERSONAL
PROGRAM ALSO WITH ONE OF THE TOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION.
APPLICATION THREE POINT FOUR TO
SUPPORT INCREASING CAPACITY FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS YOUR
PERSONAL. YOUR PERSONAL PROGRAM
IS ONGOING HE HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING THE TRAINING FLIGHTS
MIGHT APPEAR PERSONNEL FOR MANY
YEARS TO SERVE IN THAT PUBLIC
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM AND IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. ADDITIONAL
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE AUGMENTING
OUR EXISTING H. FIVE LOAN
REPAYMENT SCHOLARSHIP AND
STIPEND PROGRAM IS SUPPORT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS. ON MAY
SIXTEENTH IT WILL OPEN THE
APPLICATION FOR FOUR OF OUR LOAN
REPAYMENTS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
SERVING CHILDREN IN NEED. THIS
WILL INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR
RECRUITING AND RETAINING ALSO
THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE. THE SUPPORT SEVERAL
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING ONE POINT THREE AND
ONE POINT FIVE TO REALLY SUPPORT
SCHOLARSHIPS AND M. SPAN FUNDING
FOR THINGS LIKE STIPENDS AND
SCHOLARSHIP. ADDITIONALLY OUR
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE EXPANDING THE
TRAINING CAPACITY FOR PSYCHIATRY
AND SOCIAL WORKERS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY H. CHI BEGAN THE
PSYCHIATRY EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM FUNDED BY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT IN
GENERAL FUND. SHE'S PROGRAM
INCREASES THE CAPACITY OF
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS TO
TRAIN ADDITIONAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS. INCLUDING
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHIATRIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. IT IS ALREADY
AWARDED THREE PSYCHIATRY
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND FOR
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER PROGRAM. INCLUDING
STARTING A NEW PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN THE COUNTY
. WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE CHILDREN'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE WE ARE AUGMENTING
THIS PROGRAM TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
PROGRAMS TRAINING THESE
PROVIDERS. THIS DIRECTLY ALIGNED
WITH THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION THREE POINT THREE
IT ABOUT A PSYCHIATRIC NURSE
PRACTITIONER PROGRAM. CREWS FROM
TRAINS PROVIDERS TO SERVE IN
UNDERSERVED RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS
RECOMMENDATION TWO POINT TWO TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY POSITIONS. WE WILL BE
OPENING YOUR FUNDING CYCLES BUT
IT'S PROGRAM TWENTY TWENTY TWO
INCLUDING A NEW PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT TRAINING OF SOCIAL
WORKERS. AFTER WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
DOING WORK ON THE CHILDREN USED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE TO
DEVELOP SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
OR PORSCHE- ERLIN APPRENTICESHIP
MODELS AND ENHANCE TRAINING TO
SERVE JUSTICE AND SYSTEM
INVOLVED YOU. IN WHERE'S AND I'M
THE- IN THE AREA WORDS WAYS TO
BUILD THE WORK FORCE TO SERVICES
DEMAND JUSTICE INVOLVED HERE THE
SUPPORT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
BUILD AND SUSTAIN THAT-
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE. OUR SIDE ACTIVITIES
ARE LIKELY TO INCLUDE SUPPORTING
NOT PROVIDER ADULTS JUST
TEACHERS AND PARENTS WITH EARLY
IDENTIFICATION EDUCATION.
INCREASING S. U. D. EDUCATION
FOR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS AND
LICENSE FOR BASE THERE BUT- AND
BUILDING AND EXPANDING OUR TO
LEARN PROGRAMS FOR S. U. V. CAL
SIX TRAINING. FINALLY I WILL GO
INTO THE WORK. IN THE PROPOSED
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- BUDGET
. BUT WORKFORCE WHERE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL ALREADY
SKIPPED INCLUDES ONE BILLION
OVER THREE YEARS. AS WITH ALL OF
H. HIS WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
THESE PROPOSALS SEEK TO INVEST
IN TRAINING AND DIVERSE HEALTH
WORKFORCE WOULD DRESS WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE
INCLUDING FOR MEDICAMENTS. THESE
PROPOSALS ALSO CLOSELY CLOSELY
ALIGN WITH AND SUPPORT MANY OF
THE FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATION. THE
GOVERNOR UDGET PROPOSES THE
FOLLOWING INVESTMENTS FOR EACH
GUY TO ADMINISTER. THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY NURSING INITIATIVE
THIS PROPOSAL WE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF REGISTERED NURSES
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS
MIDWIVES- PROVIDERS
PRACTITIONERS AND OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. THE FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION POINTS OUT
THE NURSING FACULTY SHORTAGES
IMPACT READING ABOUT CITY WHICH
IMPACTS THE ABILITY OF NURSES
ABLE TO START. THIS NURSING
INITIATIVE WOULD FOCUS ON
INCREASING THE CAPACITY TO TRAIN
FOR NURSING PROVIDE.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA'S SOCIAL
WORK INITIATIVE. THIS PROPOSAL
SUPPORT SOCIAL WORK TRAINING
PROGRAMS SHOULD PROVIDE STIPENDS
AND SCHOLARSHIPS FOR WORKING
PEOPLE TO CREATE A PIPELINE FOR
DIVERSE SOCIAL WORKERS IT MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO OTHERWISE AFFORD
THE FINANCIAL TIMES INVESTORS
FIRED TO COMPLETE THE SUBGRAPH.
AS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WAS A KEY
FOCUS THE FUTURE OF WORK FORCE
MISSION. AND THIS INITIATIVE
SUPPORTS THE RECOMMENDATION.
ANOTHER PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENT PROGRAM
WHICH INCLUDES SUPPORTING
TRAINING PSITIONS FOR SEKAI
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER PSYCHOLOGY. INTERNS
AND FELLOWS IN PSYCHIATRIC NURSE
. THIS WORK ALSO IS DIRECTLY IN
LINE WITH THE FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS OR EXPERIENCE
LIKE I TREAT. IN PSYCHIATRIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER
TRAINING AND CAPACITY AND WHY.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT PROPOSED A
PROPOSAL IN THIS AND- TWENTY TWO
BUDGET IS BUT A COMMUNITY HEALTH%
WORKER INITIATIVE. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD RECRUIT TRAIN AND CERTIFY
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. THERE
IS A LONG HISTORY OF HEALTH
WORKERS IMPLEMENT TODAS
PROVIDING CULTURALLY ONGOING.
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES AND
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO DIRECTLY
SUPPORTS IF YOU TO HELP
WORKFORCE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS THE SCALE BEING
AGE MAY HAVE BEEN HEALTH WORKERS
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS. REUTERS OR
SERVER FOR AND RAN. THE BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR ME
MULTI LINGUAL HEALTH AND SENATE
. YES WHAT EXPERIENCED SHIP AND
LOW REPAYMENT PROGRAMS AND CARE
AND SOCIAL WORK SPECIFICALLY FOR
MULTI LINGUAL APPLICANTS. WITH
THE GOAL OF INCREASING LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
THROUGHOUT THE CARE WORKFORCE.
WELL ALL OF THESE KINDS
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS POLICY TO
INCREASE. RACIAL AND LINGUISTIC
DIVERSITY THESE FUNDS WOULD BE
FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY ON
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF- MULTI
LINGUAL PROVIDERS. BUILDING A
DIVERSE AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT
WORKFORCE IS FOUNDATIONAL TO THE
WORK OF THE FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION PRIORITIES
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE COMMISSION
REPORT STATED THAT MORE THAN
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AND
WOULD BENEFIT FROM ALL QUITE
LEGAL PROVIDERS IF YOU ARE
AVAILABLE. THIS FUNDING WOULD
HELP SERVE TO BRIDGE THAT GAP
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF MULTI
LINGUAL PROVIDERS SERVING
CALIFORNIANS. ADDITIONALLY THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING COUNCIL.
THIS FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT THE
WORK OF THESE NEW COUNCIL TO
RESEARCH HEALTHCARE SHORTAGES
AND SUPPORT RESEARCH ON BEST
PRACTICES AND STRATEGIES THE
BILL THE DIVERSE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WORKFORCE WE NEED. H.
CHI ESTABLISH THE NEW COUNCIL
THIS YEAR AND THE COUNCIL HAD
ITS FIRST MEETING IN MARCH- THE
NEW STATUTES THE COUNCIL'S ROLE
IS TO HELP SET STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES ARE CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. DEVELOP HEALTH
WORKFORCE THAT MEETS
CALIFORNIANS HEALTHCARE NEEDS.
THIS CLERK WORK CLEARLY ALIGNS
WITH THE OVERALL INTENT OF THE
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION AS IT SEEKS TO BUILD
THE CAPACITY WORKFORCE NECESSARY
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR
WE ALSO ESTABLISHED A NEW HEALTH
WORKFORCE RESEARCH DATA CENTER.
WHICH WILL SUPPORT THE WORK OF
THE COUNCIL TO COLLECT AND
REPORT. DATA NECESSARY TO BUILD
NEEDED WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
FINANCIER ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THIS. ACTRESS IS ALSO PART OF
FINANCE INTERNATIONAL TASK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
SHEILA ANYTHING TO ADD TO THIS.
BUT NO CENTER GREG MONROE NO
COMMENTS TO ADD THINKING. OKAY
THEN I THINK WE'LL GO AHEAD MOVE
ON THE PANEL DISCUSSION- DAY A
VERY A RIGOROUS PLANNED
MISTRESS- I CRY I LIKE HOW WE-
WILL USE THE EXPERTS OUT THERE
TELLING US WHAT WE NEED AND WE
TRY TO MATCH OUR GOALS TO BE TO
BE ABLE TO MEET THAT- I STILL
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
BARRIERS TO. TO KNOCK DOWN TEN
YEARS SEEMS LIKE A REASONABLE
TIME FRAME TO BILL PUT THIS IN
IN A AND AN EFFECT AND YOU SEE
HOW FAR WE'VE COME THAT JUST
USING A BILLION DOLLARS JUST
ROLLS OFF YOUR TONGUE LIKE
NOTHING- OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE FIRST PANEL DISCUSSION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WORKFORCE
NEEDS AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
MERE SHOULD. FOR SHOT.
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS A TYLER. ANDY EXECUTOR
TO CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAMS
COLLINS SERVICE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND REBEKAH
GONZALEZ DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR ANY S. W. WELCOME
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU
TRANSMITTERS FOR OPPORTUNITIES
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE SAY MY
NAME'S AMBER OISIN I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF. HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AS YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC THE
EVER HEALTH CONTINUUM IS
EXPERIENCING A SEVERE WORK FORCE
CRISIS IS INITIATIVE CBH J. AS
WELL AS MANY STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
THE HEALTH CONTINUUM HAVE AIMED
TO TARGET WITH TEACHER
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE RESEARCH
HE EVER HEALTHCARE AND ALL REFER
TO IT OVER THE COURSE OF THIS
PRESENTATION. THE FOCUS
PROPOSED. A STUDY SIGNATURE
COMMISSION WITH UCSF HEALTH
WHERE CENTER FOUND ON OVER 70%
OF COUNTIES HAD DIFFICULTY
RECRUITING BEAVER HELP
PROFESSIONS. THIS SHORTAGE IS
MOST ACUTE IN THE CELGENE
VALIANT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
RECEIVE THE LOWEST RATIOS. OF
THE IRAQ OFFICIALS. IN ADDITION
TO REGIONALIST IN TO. OF WORK
FOR WE ALSO FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE YEAR ARE NOT. REPRESENT
FOR EXAMPLE. BY CAN ON PROVIDERS
UNDER IN I KIND AND CLINICAL AND
COUNSELING. SMALLER PROVIDE ARE
DIRECT IN MY- ALMOST ALL. THIS
LEADS TO. AND ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
THE HELP ME HOUSE DIVERSE TO.
AND LANGUAGE. I REMEMBER ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE MONUMENTS
POLICY CHANGE FROM ITS ROUTE.
WITHOUT THE APPROACH WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA WAS FROM TO IMPLEMENT
THE STATE'S VISION. CURRENTLY
MANY BEHAVIORAL DEPARTMENT ARE
CLOSE BITERS PURPORTED BECAUSE
HE'S ABOUT 230% THIS EVENTS THE
SUCCESS OF THE LAST UNCOVER
POLICY INITIATIVE IN THE EVER
HEALTH TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE.
INVESTING BOTH SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM FOR SURE SALUTE. THE
BOOK IS PROPOSAL OFF OF THE
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENTS EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. AND WOOD INVESTIGATIONAL
MOSTLY ONE TIME FUNDS IN ORDER
TO ONE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE BY A THIRD TO SUPPORT
AND BETTER PREPARE THE WORKFORCE
TO SERVE HIGH ACUITY CLIENTS.
THREE SURE THE WORKFORCE BETTER
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF STATE
AND THE COMMUNITIES. OF THE
SURVEY. FOR INSTANCE USED TO
SPECIALIST ARE ON. NOT HEALTH.
AND DEVELOPER BUS CYPTO AND
ACADEMIC INSTITUTE TO BE INTO
THE HEALTH. FOR ALSO THAT REBUT
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT IN SHOCK
BOTH SHORT AND LONG TERM NEEDS
WORKS FOR CAL BECAUSE WE IT
BEFORE. WHEN YOU ONLY TO RECALL
THE STATE FACED WITH OF. IT WAS
STATE'S INVESTMENTS IN VALERIE
ALONG WITH EXPANDED EDUCATION
SLOTS RECRUITMENT. THAT WORK TO
BUILD TROOPS. THERE'S NO TO
EXTEND OPPORTUNE WALL PROVIDING
GUARANTEED LEVEL WAGE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS. NUMBER OF CONTINUING
TO WORK FOR SHORTAGE MEANS THE
GREAT BARRIER TO EXPAND
IMPROVING QUALITY OF CARE. THE
EVER GROWING HEALTH NEEDS AND
THE FOLKS PROPOSAL THE CREW
FIRST STEP STATE CAN TAKE TO
MITIGATE THAT AND SHOULD BE ON
ZERO SIX WITH THE GOAL OF THE
STATE. FARM IS BECAUSE ITS HOST
SHORE AND TERM SOME STRONGLY.
URGE THE FROM FALLS LAW AND FOR
THE WORK ABOUT A EVER HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME HOW TO DANCE THE
QUESTION THAT YOU MAY HAVE TODAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. MAY
BUILD. MOVE ONTO EACH SPEAKER
AND- HERE AND THEN WE'LL BE ABLE
TO QUESTIONS COMMON- I THINK
NEXT TO SUCH TAILORING DAY. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA'S. OF ALCOHOL
DRUG PRO EXECUTIVE. GOOD MORNING
- TIRING BIG AFTER OF THE CAN.
ASSOCIATION ABOUT AND DRUG PROBE
EXACT. ARE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
STOCK. KHAKI REP. THE NETS. YOU
DISORDER FROM TO COME UP FOR SIR
. PROJECT MATTER HOW THE POPULAR
SUGGESTED SYSTEM. WORKFORCES
CRITICAL FOR USE THAT STARTED.
FROM AND IS A REAL. AND PROVIDE
MORE SO. DEMANDED BY- WITH S. U.
P. AND ME. WE HAVE TO WORK FOR
CRISIS PRIOR THE BAND. AND THIS
IS ONLY INSIDE. THROUGH OKAY
NINE. AS MY COLLEAGUE AMERICA-
WE FOR BY MEMBER SATURDAY 2230%
STAFF TODAY- COUNTY APPRECIATES
THE DEDICATION HONESTY THE WORK
FORCE THROUGH THE PROPOSED ON
TWENTY TWO MILLION OF FUNDING
FOR OPIOID PROVIDER CAPACITY.
FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE CHILDREN
AND YOU HAVE A HUMP INITIATIVE.
AND THE SIGNING EIGHTY SIX SIX
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK CELL
BY TO CREATE A STATE WIDE.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. MEANS
AND AUTHOR AGE KIND OF FUN STUFF
PART TO MEASURE ADDS- WE'VE OF
COURSE. IT THE ENGAGED BY A HIGH
THIS- TO THE STATE WENT OUR
MEMBERS. HOWEVER WITH OUR THAT
THERE NEEDS TO GET LARGE
INVESTOR INVESTING YOU WORK. I'M
FOR EXAMPLE COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE
A DAY. PRODUCTS ON FOR WORK OR
ABOUT PRESS KEY AS THEIR IT'S-
HOW. I'M UNDER THE YEAR OLD-
WORKFORCE SAID. IN TRAINING.
FIND BY THE END SIDE. I THERE
ARE RATE PAID REMAIN COW OR NOT
SO. TO ATTRACT AND- STAFF AND
THIS USE THE OUR WE ACCEPT USE
THAT COUNT. WERE TO THREE CHIU.
AND ARE MEMBERS US THAT OUR
RIGHTS TO FOR TEN WORKING ASK
YOU. IS CONSIDERED A- THIS BILL
WOULD THROTTLE ARE BUILT TO
SERVE CLIENTS AND BEHIND. TODAY
WHERE. AND DEEP WHILE WE KNOW
THAT DETAIL FAIR. WE'RE HOPEFUL
THATOR BY HIP HOP FOR BUT THE
STATE. CAN'T WELL CHIANG. AS
WELL AS THE IN A- AND WORKFORCE
ABOUT WHAT. I'M AREAS THAT WE
FIND WHEN WORKFORCE ABOUT. DOING
TAX SIMPLE WORKING TOWARDS H. C.
IT'S NOT AND- PROGRAM BUT JUST-
I WORE THE GRANT EARLIER THIS
YEAR A GRANT PROGRAM FOR PER. TO
PROVIDE INTERNSHIPS FOR EPIC.
INTERESTED IN DE INTO THE- AND-
WE FIND HOW. PAIN FIRST I AND
THE COVERAGE CONSTANT EXPRESS.
OR ERECTED ACCOUNTS TO BECOME
CERTIFIED. AND FUNDING FOR OUR-
TO BE ABLE TO COVER- OF. FOR A
SERVICE. ON THEIR PATH TO LIGHTS
THAT WORK IN OUR FIELD- I. LIKE
TO MENTION BY- SOME OF THE- THAT
ARE EXISTING. YOU THE CONCEPT OF
OUR HOW PROFESSION SHORTAGE
AREAS. WHICH APPLY YEAH I'M BUT
- WHICH WORKS IN THE- THAT NOT
HOW AND OTHER PRIMARY CARE AREAS
BUT IT DOES NOT APPLY. TO
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT THE- AND
SOUR- WE A SHORTAGE OF WORK
ACROSS THE BOARD. AND SO WE
WOULD HOPE TO SEE YOU SITUATE
WHERE OUR PROVIDERS CAN BE
ELIGIBLE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IN THE STATE- AND BAD BAD
TRAINING LOCATIONS AND PLACEMENT
SITES FOR THE WATER PAYMENT
PROGRAMS AND OTHER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES ARE
AVAILABLE TO OUR MEMBERS- THE
ONE THAT I DID MENTION ON THIS
THE STATE WATER PAYMENT PROGRAM.
THIS IS A FEDERAL ISSUE BUT DID
WANT TO RAISE. YOUR IMPORT WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO CAPITALIZE ON IT
TODAY- SO THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY. THANK VERY MUCH AND
WE'LL MOVE ON- CULLEN. HELP ME
WITH YOUR LAST NAME. WE'RE FOR
US OKAY. OKAY IT'S GOOD SENATOR
. FIRST IN LINE TO LINE COMMENTS
EARLIER THANK THEM FOR TESTING.
A GOOD MY NAME IS CALLED FOR US
OR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS TO CAL
CYCLE SEARCHERS. I ALSO LIKE TO
OUT OF HERE SPEAKING BEHALF OF
MY A SISTER OR- HI HEALTH- CALL
AT US A. M. T. CAMPS- AND KALKA
WHO WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR IT IS
AS WELL AS ANY W. R. JOIN BUDGET
PROPOSAL. COULD THE DELIVERY BE
ALSO STRAINER CHANNELS. BY THE
MIDDLE OF THE OF AND WELL IT
LIFE LOCAL PROVIDER NAMED LIKE
TO IN THAT THE THERE ON LIFE
CLINIC. ARE INCREASED AWARENESS
OF MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS DRIVEN IN
PART BY THE PANDEMIC AND ALSO BY
STATE PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE WILL
COME ONLINE SIX THE CARE COURTS
TELLING HIM. AND THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH INITIATIVE AMONGST
OTHERS ARE CREATING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES PARTICULARLY WITH A
MEDIC CAL INFUSION OF SIGNAGE
WAS FORCED INTO THE ROLE I PLAN
WILL FOSTER THE AVAILABILITY OF
PROVIDERS PUBLIC HEALTH ARENA BY
DEMONSTRABLE MAKING FUNDS TO
WORK AND THAT. WHILE THERE ARE
SEVERAL EFFORTS AND EXPAND THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF THOSE SOME
BACKGROUND MENTAL HEALTH WORK
FOR TODAY THE BASS MAJORITY OF
THIS WORK BEING DONE PROVIDING
CLINICAL AND THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS. IS
BEING DONE BY THE FOUR
CATEGORIES OF PROFESSIONAL
LICENSEES ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PSYCHOLOGISTS BILLS YES WCL
MATCHES AND ALL SIX WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT BUDGET SURPLUS
CAN BE USED PROACTIVELY TO
DEVELOPING THE FIRST WELL
TRAINED WORKFORCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STATES MENTAL. HEALTH
NEEDS PARTICULARLY FOR MANTA
CAL. OUR ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THAT
ONE TIME FUNDING APPROPRIATE
SONG WE HAVE SUGGESTED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S FALLS WHILE STATE
GOVERNMENT STAKEHOLDERS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES A MEDIC CAL GROWING
PRACTITIONERS WORKFORCE PIPELINE
BRING DISADVANTAGED MINORITY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FROM EDUCATION
TO LIFE WHICH- IS FUNDS WOULD BE
ALLOCATED ON A ONE TIME BASIS
DISTRIBUTED ON A ROLLING BASIS
FUNDS FOR EXPANDING. OUR TWO TO
ONE FOR WORKFORCE PROPOSAL IS.
MEANT TO PROVIDE DIRECT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO FUTURE
LICENSE PLATE. OTHER WINNERS IN
THIS MAY WHICH SHALL THIS
POCKETS YOUR GENERAL SPECIAL
FOR. TO TROUBLED BY BY THE BUT
WE IT AS A- MILLION DEDICATED TO
THOSE WHO MASTER AND DOCTOR
DEGREES IN THE- HOUSE FOR. FEEL
TWO HUNDRED BILLION GRANTS.
STRICKLER NEPHEW AND SHE'S
WORRIED SHE- GOING TO BE ABLE
CENTER TO HIRE RETAIN. TO
WORKING TOWARD OUR LIFE. AND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO EXPAND EXTRA
LONGER FOR WORKING SECTOR
PROJECTS. WE BELIEVE THIS FOR.
PROVIDES OUR KIND STEPS FOR
ADDRESSING STORE. SHOULD CALL.
INCLUDING A LOT OF STUDIES WITH
THE NEED REALITY RESOURCE.
BUDGET BASIS. PROVIDING LARGEST
AND STABLE LIKE OUR- TO VOTE
MULTI COMMUNICATIONS AVERAGE CAN
. CREATE FLEXIBILITY AND
GROUNDWORK FOR FROM TO MOLD LIKE
WE- GEOGRAPHIC TO IN THE FORCE-
FOLK ON SEVERAL YEARS AND
HEARING OUT. AND ALLOW THE-
ADMIN PROVIDING. PATHWAY OVER.
FOR SIX. TO GET CLINICAL OUT AND
LIKE. IN ADDITION THE- MAY WISH
TAKES TO ADDRESS SOLUTION THAT
ARE PRIME LIFE REPORT BOARDS
PSYCHOLOGY. SCIENCE INCLUDING
TWENTY FIVE MILLION APPROVED.
SUPPORT BRING PRICE WAY TIMES
FOR. OF THIRTY DAYS RIGHT NOW AT
THE BOARD CYCLE OF LOAN IT'S
MINIMUMS MONTHS. FOR MILLION
DEPLOY LIVE X. FEES CONDITIONS
IN TWENTY MILLION GRANTS TO FOR.
SUPER STRUCTURE IT'S. WE KNOW
THAT OUR STEPS THAT CAN BE TO BY
LAW. TO ASSIST CLINICIANS
DELIVERY KERRY THE PHONE BECAME
HEALTH. REQUEST WHICH CVH JERRY
MENTIONED EARLIER. BUT BELIEVE
THAT THE SOLUTION PROVIDER
FINDING AND LIFE FOR SERVICES
WOULD THE MOST OF MEDIAN. TO
ACCESS PARTICULAR FOR MEDICARE.
ARE POPPING BY LIFE. WELL TRY
AND I DO CLERK PROVIDERS THANK
YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY.
MISKIN DOLLAR. WITH INIESTA
BECAUSE- BUT MORNING. MORE MY
NAME IS REBECCA GETS ALL NEVER
NOW ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE REPRESENTS
WORKER WITH THE G. IN SOCIAL
FROM AN- SCHOOL SOCIAL WORK I
WOULD LIKE TO MY CELL ALSO WITH
THE AND PANEL. BUT ESPECIALLY
COLLINS WITH HELP CYCLE.
ASSOCIATION AS WE ARE A PARTNER
INTHE TWO ONE ONE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THE LICENSE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE. IN ADDITION TO
THE LICENSE WORKFORCE MSW LEVEL
SOCIAL WORKER ARE CRITICAL STAFF
FOR DELIVERING SERVICES. ACROSS
MANY DIVERSE SECTORS AND
PROGRAMS THAT IMPACT VIRTUALLY
EVERY CALIFORNIA. M.S. W. LEVEL
STAFF ARE CRITICAL IN SERVING
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
IMPACTED BY POVERTY ABUSE AND
NEGLECT IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. THIS INCLUDES MANY
PUBLICLY FUNDED PROGRAMS IN
CHILD WELFARE FOSTER CARE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES EDUCATION
OSPITALS SCHOOL. BASED SETTINGS
AND COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
RECENT INVEST IN HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
EDUCATION AND CHILD WELFARE AND
MENTAL PROTECTIVE SERVICES HAVE
INCREASED DEMAND FOR NSW TRAINS
SOCIAL WORK STAFF ACROSS PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE PROVIDERS. DESPITE THE
INCREASING DEMAND FOR NSW LEVEL
PROFESSIONALS AS WELL AS THE
INTEREST FROM STUDENTS IN
PURSUING SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS
THERE ARE SIMPLY TOO FEW SOCIAL
WORKERS COMING THROUGH THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM 80% S. B. S.
YOU AND UC MSW PROGRAMS REPORT
THE NEED TO EXPAND CURRENT
CAPACITY TO ADMIT MORE QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS ONE EXAMPLE FOR THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS CSU LONG BEACH
HAS RECEIVED AN AVERAGE. OF
TWELVE HUNDRED APPLICATIONS TO
ITS MSW PROGRAM I CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS. BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF MSW DEGREES BEING
OFFERED THERE IS FIERCE
COMPETITION ACROSS GOVERNMENTAL
AND NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
FOR NSW'S. ADDITIONALLY THE
PIPELINE DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO CONTINUOUSLY ENGAGE
AND SUSTAIN STUDENTS WHO
REPRESENT MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS INDIVIDUALS
OF COLOR AND THOSE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES. CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUES TO BECOME MORE DIVERSE
AND THE POPULATION SERVED BY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
REPRESENTED BY PEOPLE OF COLOR.
CONSUMERS OF THE SERVICE. SINCE
EXPRESS IT IS I ARE TO BE SERVED
BY SOCIAL WORKERS WHO REFLECT
THE POPULATION SIR I'M THE
PROPOSAL I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT IS
THE BILL CAPACITY FOR MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS AND IS
COSPONSORED BY ANY US W.
CALIFORNIA THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATIONSEIU AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
DEANS AND DIRECTORS OF SOCIAL
WORK. I WILL DO THE FOLLOWING
ONE REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF CAL
HHS IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OF THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EXPANDING
NSW CAPACITY. IN THE CSU AND UC
SYSTEM. TWO PENDING THE
COMPLETION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IT WOULD
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM AS A
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MILLION STATE
CHAMP ARE ALL SIGNS PER YEAR IN
THE NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS
AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. I PROVIDE THIRTY
MILLION PER YEAR TO BE USED TO
SEE FUNDING FOR GRANTS TO
IMMEDIATELY EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
MSW STUDENTS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
OF SOCIAL WORK. TO PROVIDE A
FIFTEEN MILLION PER YEAR TO
INCREASE SUPPORT TO COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND COUNTY AGENCIES OFFERING
FILLED INTERNSHIPS TO SUPPORT
THE REQUIRED NINE HUNDRED HOURS
BILLED PRACTICUM FOR ALL NSW
STUDENTS. AND PROVIDE THIRTEEN
MILLION PER YEAR EDUCATIONAL
STIPENDS TO MSW STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES. IN
SUMMARY THIS PROPOSAL WILL
BENEFIT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AS
WELL AS OTHER WORKPLACES AND
SOCIAL WORKERS ARTISTS FINANCIAL
WORKFORCE IN SO MANY SYSTEMS THE
MORE SOCIAL WORKERS WE GET
THROUGH THE EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE
THE MORE WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
ALL WORKPLACES INCLUDING.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND REPUBLICAN DOES
YOU SEE THIS ADDITION WHAT THE
WHAT THE IS ALREADY- THE WORK
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY DONE
AND HAS PLANNED OUT HERE IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT
ABSOLUTELY OKAY- AND YOU CAN GET
AT THE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I
KEEP TALKING ABOUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. GRADUATE
SOCIAL PROGRAMS HAVE SHRUNK
AROUND THE STATE AT THE SAME
TIME ARE THE DEMAND HAS
EXPONENTIALLY GROWN- AND SO
THERE SEEMS TO BE A REAL
DISCONNECT. BETWEEN OUR ARE
EDUCATING PARTNERS AND- AND THE
NEEDS RIGHT NOW- THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED I THINK OR WE DON'T WE
DON'T TACKLE THIS- SO I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT- MR FOREST CAN YOU
. IT HELLO HOW DID YOURSELF LIKE
YOU AND IN THE NSW ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER AND I KNOW
SENATOR WIENER ALSO HAS A PLAN
THAT HE'S WORKING ON WITH THAT
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE THERE'S
THAT LEGISLATION GOING THROUGH
REALLY AND REALLY BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THE BARRIERS TO
LICENSURE BECAUSE I ARE WE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT PEOPLE GETTING THEIR
DEGREE BUT THEN SOMETIMES A
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE AND PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO PRACTICE WITH THE
FULL SCOPE OF THEIR LICENSE- ARE
YOU PART OF THAT CONVERSATION.
YES WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FIBER CONSITUTES GBH TA AND
OTHER FOLKS IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SIDE ON. COLLISION ASK- THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS- THAT
ORGANIZATION DOES HAVE ABOUT
SOME OF THE- ISSUES WITH.
PRACTICING TO THE FULL SCOPE OF
LICENSURE WITH SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE- SPECIFICALLY CONTAINS
SANDERS S. B. NINE SIX FOUR- BUT
AS A COALITION WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE PATHWAYS. TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO THE MARKET
FOR OUR LICENSEES- SO I DID
REFERENCE IN MY SPEECH- THREE
MONTHS WAIT TIME. FOR MY FOLKS
WHO ARE WAITING TO GET
LICENSURE. I SPECIFICALLY BORDER
PSYCHOLOGY. AND I WILL GET SOME
CREDIT FOR PSYCHOLOGY HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD ON BRING THAT
NUMBER DOWN BUT- YOU KNOW I'VE
HEARD ANECDOTALLY FROM FOLKS
THEY HAVE A THREE MONTH WINDOW
TO WAIT TO GET. THEIR FIRST TEST
EVALUATION REGISTERED AND THEN
ANOTHER THREE MONTH WAIT. TO
GET- THEIR SECRETS REGISTERED
AND THEN ANOTHER THREE MONTH
WAIT AFTER THAT. TO GET THEIR
LICENSURE SO YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THREE MONTHS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A NINE MONTH.
EXTRA SERVICE WE DO BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THAT IS AFFECTED BY. THE
SAME THINGS WE SEE ELSEWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT
WORKFORCE ACCESS ISSUES- SO
THERE ARE PATHWAYS TO HELP
REDUCE THOSE BARRIERS- BUT THE
CRUX OF. WHAT OUR FOR
ORGANIZATIONS SOCIAL WORKERS
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
CLINICAL CAST TALKING ABOUT. IS
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO
INCENTIVIZE AND OTHERWISE- GIVE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS CONTROL WHEN WE
ACTUALLY CHEESE OR CHEESE COUNTY
FACILITY. TO ACTUALLY RECRUIT
RETAIN THOSE TRAINEES SO THEY
CAN WORK TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
CLINICAL HOURS. WHILE ALSO BEING
PAID TO DO SO WHICH. IN MOST
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY ARE. WE'LL
TALK ABOUT DOING THAT- PRE. OR
POST. THAT WOULD BE POST SO-
MICROTECH SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO CYCLE BECAUSE
I'M A DEBT I KNOW BACK WITH AND
ASKED SEVENTY TWO ALSO SPEAK UP
- MY FOLKS HAVE TO HAVE A
MINIMUM TWO YEARS SLASH THREE
THOUSAND HOURS OF CLINICAL WORK
BEFORE THEY'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THEIR LICENSURE- AND DURING THAT
TIME THEY HAVE TO BE DIRECTLY
SUPERVISED. AND SINCE WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS IN OTHER SETTINGS BUT
BECAUSE THE PAY RATE FOR LICENSE
CONDITIONS THAT MIGHT ACCOUNT IS
A FAR LOWER THAN MANAGED CARE OR
THE PRIVATE SECTOR- YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE WHO NOT
ONLY HAS TO BE DOING CLINICAL
WORK IN THESE MEDICAL SETTINGS
BUT ALSO. HAS TO PROVIDE SOME
SUPERVISORY WORK AND THOSE
TRAINEES TO WORK IN THE SETTINGS
ARE OFTEN NOT PAID TO DO THAT.
SO THEY ARE WORKING AT PAYING
OFF STUDENT LOAN DEBT AT THE
SAME TIME THE ALSO WILL BE TRUMP
CLINICAL LIKE SH AND SO WHAT WE
SEE IS REALLY IMPORTANT AS PART
OF OUR ATKINS HEART OF THE
LARGER FOCUS ASSETS DONE BY THAT
COALITION THAT YOU MENTION. IS
TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME DIRECT
FINANCIAL RESULTS PARTICULARLY
THE MEDICAL FACILITIES TO ALLOW
THEM TO BRING THESE FOLKS ON SO
THEY CAN ALSO SEE PATIENTS WHILE
THEY'RE DOING THEIR TRAINING
HOURS BUT THERE'S NO
RELATIONSHIP NOW BETWEEN THE
TRAINING AND NOT SO ELITE. WHICH
MAKES THEM MORE LIKELY TO
POTENTIALLY STAY ON THAT'S AFTER
THEY'RE DONE WITH THE GLOBAL
LIFESTYLE. DIFFICULT TRADING.
OKAY THAT YOU THE PER SEMESTER
THIRTY TWO HIGH- AND IN MY-
MAYBE NOT MEDICAL CLINIC FROM
EXPERIENCE IS A ARE PAY DURING-
DURING THAT TIME BECAUSE THERE
THERE BE A TO USE AS A AS A NEW
JUST WITH SOMEBODY ELSE. DOING
THE SUPERVISION- BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
IN A MEDICAL FACILITY IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. CORRECT
THERE ARE SOME FACILITIES THAT
DO. MAKE PAYMENTS BUT IT IS NOT
A UNIFORM PRACTICE. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET AROUND WITH AT ONE TIME
BUDGET OUT. TWENTY ONE SO AND I
GUESS THIS IS MAYBE TO. MISTER
MS RESULT THE I MEAN ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES I KNOW IN THE FIELD
THIS FOR SHE WAS GETTING PEOPLE
THROUGH THE LICENSURE PROCESS IS
ADEQUATE SUPERVISION OTHERS
OFTENTIMES NOT ENOUGH
SUPERVISION OR NONPROFIT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A GREAT A GREAT
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE BUT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE A- LICENSE PERSON TO
DO THAT SUPERVISION THEY CAN'T.
THEY CAN'T HIRE SURVEYED PEOPLE
CAN'T GET EXPERIENCEWAS UP. TO
CASCADING IMPACT- AND WE THOUGHT
ABOUT PROVIDING STATE LEVEL
PEOPLE WOULD WITH LICENSURE TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SEVEN THAT
SUPERVISION- THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM AND
ESPECIALLY IN OUR SMALLER RURAL
AREAS. YES AS PART OF OUR WORK
AROUND BEHAVIOR HEALTH PLEASE
WE'VE BEEN. LOOKING AT WAYS TO
SUPPORT- SUPERVISION AND IN IN A
VARIETY OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF. OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO BE-
SUPERVISOR THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON- IN
INCORPORATING INTO OUR PROGRAMS.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT HI DENNIS NO MY OWN
HOME COUNTIES IF THE ISSUE OF
HUGE IMPORTANCE- MISTER MISTER
BYRD. I'M SORRY IS IT R&D IS IT
RENDERS IT RYAN DOES IT HOW DO I
SAY THAT. RINDE BRENDA OKAY WHAT
IS THAT WHAT IS THE CURRENTLY
THE TERMINAL DEGREE FOR WHEN
WORKING IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT LICENSURE IS
THAT THEN JUST ADD. NOT JUST BUT
AN LCSW OR LICENSE I COLLEGES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON A
SEPARATE LICENSURE DEGREE
CORRECT. NO TODAY IT'S NOT A
SEPARATE LICENSURE SO WE DO
HAVE- PREDOMINATELY- USE AN LCSW
SPENT DO YOU WORK IN OUR
SUBSTANCE USE FACILITIES SO THE
ISSUE YOU MENTIONED ABOUT
SUPERVISION THAT'S ALSO PERTAIN
TO OUR SUBWAYS THIS OP. OKAY
SENATOR REID I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT ON THE STREET PROVISIONS
SIDE- WE DO HAVE TO PUBLIC
POLICY BILLS MOVING ONE FOR THE
BORDER BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. I AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME
WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY AND FOR
PSYCHOLOGY FOR PSYCHOLOGY AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SOMEONE IN A REBEKAH BAUR CHAND
THAT WOULD PERMANENTLY CODIFY
THE REMOTE SUPERVISION
CAPABILITIES. THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
ALLOWED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC-
BUT WILL GO AWAY ONCE THE
PANDEMIC OF ORDER IS LIFTED. SO
WE DO ALSO SEE TREMENDOUS VALUE
IN HAVING REMOTE SUPERVISION
WHICH ALLOWS FOR GEOGRAPHIC
FLEXIBILITY IS ALSO ACOSTA BOTH
SUPERVISORS TRAINING SO THAT IS
ALSO ONE SOLUTION THAT'S MOVING
ON THE POLICY SIDE- IF THE
ADMINISTRATION WERE SO INCLINED
PULLING THOSE BOTH INTO A
TRAILER BILL WOULD ALSO FURTHER
ACTION. SETS. OKAY THANK YOU A
AND I'M GONNA I'M NOT GONNA
ABOUT OUR COMMERCE ABOUT PRAYER
. MESSAGE PRESS. SO IT OKAY-
THANK YOU DR GRANT. THANK YOU
AND THE PRETTY THE PANELS
PRESENT- I THINK I THINK THE
CHAIR COVERED MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD BUT- I DID HAVE
A COUPLE. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
INTENDED SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY-
WAS A ROOF WORKFORCE RESEARCHER
MY PREVIOUS LIFE AS AS WELL AS
A- PROGRAM DIRECTOR AND- FOR-
RESIDENCY TRAINING SO I GUESS IS
EDUCATIONAL DIRECTOR PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF. THIS OF THE
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF- YOU KNOW
BUILDING PIPELINES AND SO FORTH
SO I GUESS ONE ONE QUESTION I
HAVE IT'S PERHAPS MORE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT. AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT
TRADE AND WE'RE YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS AND SO
FORTH. BUT WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING
AN EDUCATION PROGRAM- AND- I
THINK ALL THE EDUCATORS NO IS
THAT. ONE TIME MONEY'S REALLY
HARD TO WORK WITH. RIGHT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE STUDENTS YOU.
ARE OUR TRAINEES I SHOULD SAY
YOU KNOW- AND- AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT- YOU HAVE THAT
YOU HAVE TO FIND CLINICAL SITES
YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY PRECEPTORS
RIGHT THE- WE TALKED ABOUT THE
OVER THE MENTORS AND SO FORTH-
YOU HAVE TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FOLKS AND THEN THE OTHER
THING AND THEN- AND IT OF COURSE
TO TRAIN. ITSELF KNOWS TAKES
SOME TIME. AND IN MANY WAYS
ACTUALLY LEARNS EVEN LEARN FROM
EACH OTHER SO SAMPLE AND MY
RESIDENCY PROGRAM WOULD REALLY
HARD TO JUST HAVE ONE CLASS OR A
COUPLE CLASSES BE LARGER THAN.
THE ONES THAT WERE BEFORE AND
AFTER- AND SO FORTH SO. SO I
GUESS THE A QUESTION I HAVE THE
CERTAIN WE HAVE AN ACUTE NEED.
THAT IS. YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
WHAT IS THE THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND
CERTAINLY SITTING ON BUDGET
COMMITTEE KNOW THE YOU KNOW THE
CHALLENGES A ONE TIME AND
ONGOING AND SO FORTH AND THE
VOLATILITY SOMETIMES IN OUR-
OUR- REVENUES- BUT BUT HOW DO
WORKING WITH- TRAINING PROGRAMS.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY RAMP UP
AND THEN- AND THEN ACTUALLY FOR
DOING ONE TIME ARE ONE TIME OVER
SEVERAL YEARS RAMP DOWN AGAIN-
AND NOT AFFECT THE QUALITY OF
THE EDUCATION- BECAUSE THAT'S
CERTAINLY A STRUGGLE I'VE SEEN
I'VE- ALWAYS HAD PROGRAMS LIKE
THE ACA HAD A PROGRAM PROVIDED
THEM ONE MORE PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS THE- BED. BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE- FUNDING. IS SHORT
TERM AND MANY PROGRAMS ACTUALLY.
TURNED IT DOWN THEY WOULD EVEN
TRY BECAUSE- PLYING BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT SEE HOW THAT WOULD.
THAT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE EDUCATION
PROGRAM ITSELF TO TRY TO RAMP UP
AND THEN LYING DOWN SO- SO WHAT
WHAT KIND OF CONVERSATIONS ARE
BEING HAD- WITH WITH WITH
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF.
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY SUS YELLED TO DO THE
TRAINING AND TO CREATE THAT
CAPACITY- TO ENSURE WE HAVE
QUALIFIED YOU KNOW. THAT
QUALIFIED THAT PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH BECAUSE THEY'RE
QUALIFIED BECAUSE OF THE QUALITY
EDUCATION SO TO MAINTAIN THE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION. QUALITY
EDUCATION NECESSARY- SO. THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
SUSTAIN THE PROGRAMS THEMSELVES-
AS WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
TRAINING INSTITUTIONS TO- WE
WANT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND- BUT
WHAT THIS YOU KNOW NEEDS ARE TO
SUSTAIN IT- AS WE AS- AS YOU'RE
SAYING IS THEY BUILD UP THOSE
PROGRAMS. AND SO WE CONTINUE TO.
WORK WITH THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT. OKAY SORRY- I APPRECIATE
THE ANSWER ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SURE
REALLY WASN'T ANSWERED- I MEAN
AT SOME OF THESE THINGS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A TEN
YEAR TIME FRAMES WHICH IS- BUT
THEN THE OTHER ONES ARE LIKE
THREE YEARS OR FIVE YEARS AND-
AND DEPENDING ON THE LENGTH OF
THE TRAINING- IT. IS I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE HOW TO USE IT
RIGHT- IT IN A WAY THAT- SAYS
FULLY SO- I THINK THESE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
BUT ALSO IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT IS TO SHARE THEM WITH
THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO YEAH WE DO BUDGETS EVERY YEAR
AND SO FORTH- AND AS WERE
CRAFTING OUT HOW YOUR-
PROJECTIONS AND I GUESS THAT'S-
THANK FOR FINANCE- THAT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO WORK
FORCE. IT'S REALLY HARD TO DO
SHORT TERM THINGS THAT L.
UNLESS- BECAUSE IT'S JUST. ME
AND EDUCATION PROGRAM TAKES TIME
TO DEVELOP IT'S NOT JUST SO YOU
HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE MAY WANNA
FLY YOU CAN'T IT'S NOT. LIKE YOU
CAN SUDDENLY EXPLODE THE NUMBER
AND THEN DRINK IT AGAIN ALRIGHT
IT'S- THAT AND SO- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN WE PUT. DOWN
THESE WORKFORCE PROPOSALS THAT
WE REALLY YOU KNOW MAP OUT WHAT
HAPPENS AND THEN WORK WITH
EDUCATORS SAY WELL HOW G. FIFTY
IS THAT IF. THIS TIME FRAME
RIGHT. THREE YEAR TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR YOU TO THE FUNDING
ISN'T DEL IS GOING TO WORK FOR A
WHILE RIGHT. CETERA I GUESS FOR
THE PANEL. HOW MUCH OF AN ISSUE
IS THIS FOR AND NOT I KNOW MANY
STILL SEND SOME OF YOUR LEGIT
ADVOCATES IN ACTUALLY THE
TRAINEE ALL THE TRAINING PROGRAM
DIRECTORS ITSELF BUT- IS THIS AN
ISSUE FOR THAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM YOUR ASSOCIATIONS FROM. THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. YES GRANT CAN I SPEAK
TO THAT A LITTLE BIT SO. ONE OF
OUR SPECIAL DIVISION. IS ON
EDUCATION. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
CLINICIANS WHO WORK- IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN MANAGED CARE
SETTINGS AND THE CAL SETTINGS
AFTER IT LIKE SAY THE KIND OF.
HEALTH FACILITIES AND SO THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES WHERE- PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE OF CERTAIN TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PSYCHOLOGY-
THERE ARE CERTAIN. RESTRICTIONS
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRAINEES WERE
HAVING TO TRAVEL SOMETIMES AN
HOUR TWO HOURS. AWAY TO SEE
THEIR SUPERVISOR SO PART OF THAT
WERE HOPING. AT LEAST THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT IS KIND OF FIND
OUT WHAT'S REVISIONS TO SOME OF
THOSE CHALLENGES THERE. BUT THE
OTHER PROBLEM WE'VE SEEN AS ONE-
THAT- BACK ALLUDED TO AND
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IN THE
STUDY PROGRAMS. WE'VE SEEN WITH
US AS WELL AS- THERE'S A LIMITED
OF ANY. WAS BOTH A PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC NONPROFIT. ACTUALLY DOING
THE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
THAT'S NECESSARY TO MEET THE
CLINICAL WORK FORCE- THERE ARE
GREAT PARTNERS AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YES YOU CAN
CITIES. THAT COULD BE DOING MORE
OF THIS WORK BUT WE ALSO ARE
CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT. WITH
THE INCREASE IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION- SLOTS AS WE SEEM
PARTICULAR BERKELEY THIS YEAR
WITH SOME OF THE LAWSUIT
HOUSING. YOU'RE ALSO TALKING
ABOUT NECESSARILY TAKING SPOTS
AWAY FROM PROGRAMS- BUT WE DO
FEEL AS THOUGH THAT IS NECESSARY
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME.
SERIOUS DISCUSSION WITH STRICTLY
THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN
TERMS OF EXPANDING. WHO IS BEING
ABLE TO BE EDUCATED AND WHAT
PROGRAMS ARE IN PLACE BECAUSE
THAT IS REALLY WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS ROAD. IT ALSO HAS THE BEST
YOU GRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION- SO WE
TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY. THE HIGH DESERT THE
CENTRAL COAST THAT'S WHERE THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE UC AND CSU
SAYS. CAN REALLY BE A FORCE
MULTIPLIER IN THE WAY THAT SOME
OF OUR LARGE- PRIVATE PROPERTY
GROUP BRANDON INSTITUTIONS JUST
REALLY KICKED. IN OKAY THEN ONE
OTHER QUESTION YES. I WAS
WONDERING IF I COULD ALSO AT
LEAST ABOUT I WANTED TO ALSO
SHARED THAT. THE WORK OF THE NEW
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING COUNCIL. THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH IS REALLY ONE OF
ITS REAL GOALS IS REALLY TO LOOK
AT THOSE THINGS AND SO. ON THAT
COUNCIL WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM CSU FOR YOU SEE FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVES FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PRIMARY CARE ALLIED
HEALTH CENTER AND SO WE'RE
REALLY HOPING THAT TOGETHER
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT IS AS WE AS WE BUILD
OUT. YOU KNOW THE WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
CAPACITY FOR CALIFORNIA. OKAY
AND- ALL RIGHT WELL. IN THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
COMMUNICATE. THE RESULTS THOSE
QUESTIONS WITH WITH US ETERNAL
LIFE. OUT ALSO MAKING I MEAN I
KNOW I KNOW THAT THE ARE SOME
ROUGH TO THE- FUTURE OF CARE
WORKS COMMISSION- YEAH. I'D KEEP
IN MIND THAT THAT WAS THE PRE
COVERT- THE L. AND ONE CHALLENGE
WORK FOR. IN CHANGE AND SO FORTH
. SO YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE
DEMAND FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH I
THINK IS INCREASED- AND- SO- AND
IT'S ALWAYS CHALLENGE WITH
WORKFORCE REPORTS SISTER DONE
REFLECTING THE TIMES STORE AT NO
NOT REFLECTING. NECESSARILY THE
- NOPE THE PRESENT- BECAUSE
THINGS HAVE BEEN BERMAN HAS
CHANGED BUT- WHEN THE OTHER
GUESTS ISSUES IN TERMS OF-
BEHAVIORAL WORK WORK FOR
CERTAINLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRAINING. IS ACTUALLY RETENTION
RATE- SO WE OFTENTIMES WE TALK
ABOUT WORKFORCE WE TALK ABOUT
THE PIPELINE AND PEOPLE GOING
THROUGH TRAINING BUT ALSO THE
RETENTION AND GREAT SO WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO BE SURE THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE YOU TRAINED. ARE ARE-
BEING SUPPORTED. RIGHT AND
ANSWER RELATED TO THAT- IS THAT
FOR EXAMPLE ARE THE TEACHERS WHO
ARE TEACHING OUR FATE EDUCATION
. AB ARE THEY BEING SUPPORTED IN
A WAY THAT IT'S COMPETITIVE WITH
THEM NOT TEACHING AND JUST
SEEING PATIENTS AND HOW THAT
COMPARED TO THE PEOPLE DECIDE TO
THEN PURSUE OTHER CAREERS OR
RETIRED OR SO FORTH. SO YOU'LL
WE GOT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE WORK
FORCE YES BUT NOT ONLY THE
INPUTS BUT ALSO- BILL WHERE
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING TO AS WELL SO
ARE- AND- GIVE AND I THINK
PERHAPS. THEM THIS MAY BE AN
ISSUE WITH THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE THAT CERTAINLY WILL BE
AN ISSUE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE AS WELL
BORDERS A- VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
BURNOUTS AT PDS AND HE- THAT
SUTTER- THAT'S GOING ON AND THE
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY- AS A
RESULT OF PANDEMIC AND- FRANKLY
THE REFUSAL OF MANY PEOPLE TO-
IT HERE TO. PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES STAT- AND THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT IS OF COURSE
MORE STRAIN ON PEOPLE ON THE
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY- BUT ALSO
STRAIN ON THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
COMMUNITIES WELL- I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT REBEKAH
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. ASSEMBLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU MAY GUESS.
LOS SALARIES ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASONS PEOPLE LEAVE THE FIELD
OF SOCIAL WORK AND I CAN'T
STRESS THAT ENOUGH. AND WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT COUNTIES ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AND ENSURE
PRIVATE FUNDING FOR FOUNDATIONS
REFLECT WORKFORCE PRIORITIES AND
THEN ALSO BUILDING AND- BUILDING
ORGANIZED ORGANIZATIONAL
CAPACITY TO PRIORITIZE SOCIAL
WORK SERVICES- BUT I ALSO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE KIND OF
PROGRAMS. THAT REALLY I'M WHAT
CHANGED SOCIAL WORK STAFF AGAIN.
ONE OF THOSE IS THE FOUR PLUS
ONE TRAINING WHICH IS PROGRAM.
WHICH IS A PROGRAM WHERE I'M
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE THEIR
BSW IN SOCIAL WORK AND GET THEIR
MASTERS IN ONE YEAR AND WE HAVE
FOUND THAT IN THOSE PROGRAMS
THOSE FOLKS ARE TWO POINT FIVE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO. CONTINUE
WORKING IN PUBLIC SIX SYSTEMS
AFTER COMPLETING THEIR SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS. SO I THINK WE
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT THE KIND
OF PROGRAMS THAT WORK- DAD CAN'T
KEEP. ED TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
THESE ARE BASED ON HER RESEARCH
MODEL AND THEIR STIPEND PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE SUPPORT DURING
SCHOOL. REQUIRES SPECIALIZED
PRACTICE AND SERVICE COMMITMENTS
AND THEY'RE REALLY VALUABLE FOR
RETAINING STAFF. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR SHARING THEIR- THANK YOU
CHRIS. THANK YOU. MILLION
DOLLARS JUST A FOLLOW UP ON THAT
HOW WAS THAT IS BECAUSE FOUR
PLUS ONE HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT
FROM AT THE NEW VANS PLACEMENT
PROGRAM. IT IS THE SAME THING
ACTUALLY SO IT'S AN ADVANCED
PLACEMENT PROGRAM AND WE NEED
MORE OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA- I'M
I'M HOPING THAT AS A SENATOR
WIENER'S AND INTEL SB NINE SIX
FOUR- WE ARE WORKING ON HEALTH
LEE- WE ARE SLEEPING CRAFTING
AMENDMENTS TO MORE SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS BACK ON- HAVING MORE
ADVANCED PLACEMENT PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS WORK. AND
WE NEED THEM AND MORE SCHOOLS.
EXCEPT I KNOW TEN TO BE AS SHE-
POP. FOR A GROWING POPULATION
AND IN SCHOOLS I'M FAMILIAR WITH
AND ABOUT HOW MUCH THAT HAS TO
DO WITH C. S. W. E. THE- THE
NATIONAL ACCREDITING. VERSUS THE
LOCAL SCHOOLS YOU KNOW. WELL I
DO KNOW THAT THESE KIND OF
PROGRAMS ARE SUPPORTED BY
NATIONAL ACCREDITATION STANDARDS
AND SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M THE DISCUSSION THAT HAS BEEN
TAKING PLACE ABOUT- HAVING
EXPERT. EXPEDITE A SOCIAL WORK
PROGRAMS REALLY HAVE TO FOCUS ON
THOSE THAT ARE NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED OR ELSE THEY WILL BE
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS. OKAY OKAY
THING YOU VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
ON TO OUR PANEL DISCUSSION I
THANK YOU ALL VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR EXPERTISE THANK YOU- ARE
MOVING UNDER PANELIST QUESTION
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE NEEDS- AND
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE HAS
SUBMITTED- HAS INVITED PEOPLE
AND SUBMITTED QUESTIONS FOR THEM
TO RESPOND TO SO WE HAVE WITH US
I'M CHAU GIVENS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BETH MELANAU
SKI THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
ADVOCATE FOR SEIU CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE CLEAR AND RIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION. WE HAVE
CATHERINE SCOTT SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF A STATE RELATIONS-
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
DENNIS AB CUEVAS ROMERO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR CMA
AND- NATOLI D. AS DEPUTY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION-
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU- AND WHY
DON'T WE START IN ORDER WITH
MISTER GIVENS. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING TERM WHICH GET IN
FORGET. HIS NAME IS BUT GIVEN TO
. THIS IS STATION OF CALIFORNIA
ASKS I WANT TO THANK YOU YOUR
LEADER AND FOR. FUNDING TO
REBUILD OUR PUBLIC INTEREST.
EXPAND OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS CAPACITY OUT WE NOW
COME TO YOU ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WE COLLECTIONS PUBLIC HERO
INITIATIVE WHICH IS A SERIES OF
ONE TIME ADDITIONAL BUDGET
REQUESTS TOTALING A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION TO
SUPPORT THE RECRUITMENT.
RETENTION TRAINING- AND TRAINING
OF OUR GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS A FEW SIGNIFICANT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
CHALLENGES WHICH EXISTED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC AND SIMILARLY
THAT CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE COMMISSION REPORT
LISTED PREVENTION AND PUBLIC
HEALTH IS ONE OF THE PRIORITY
PROFESSIONS. NOTING A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF CURRENT LEADERS
WERE SLATED FOR RETIREMENT AGAIN
AT THE TIME OF THAT REPORT WAS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND THEY ALSO
REPORTED THAT AT THE TIME LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAD
SIGNIFICANT. READING AND
RETAINING ALL OF WORKERS. THE
AMERICAN OF PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO
NOTED THAT ONLY 17% OF GRADUATES
FROM SCHOOLS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WENT ON TO WORKING GOVERNMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND UNFORTUNATELY
DURING THE PANDEMIC PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS FACE HARASSMENT
AND THREATS. WHICH RESULTED IN
LEADERSHIP DEPARTURES IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE LOST OVER SIXTY
TWO LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
LEADERS. MAKING IT HARDER TO
RECRUIT WORKERS INTO
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH.
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES
CALIBRATED AND HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO BOLSTER
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE AND WE MUST CHANGE
THAT. SO WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE PUBLIC EURONET AT
PACKAGE WHICH CONSISTS OF THE
FOLLOWING. A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION TO SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. OF
THE FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR OR
COULD BE USED FOR LONGER PAYMENT
SIGN ON BONUSES LONGEVITY
BONUSES OR OTHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION STRATEGIES AS APPROVED
BY EACH HIGH. WE'RE ASKING FOR
TEN MILLION TO GO TO THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING TO AWAIT
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
CERTIFICATION FEES FOR THREE
YEARS. THESE ARE ADDITIONAL
COSTS THAT PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
IN KERR- AND THAT DOES NOT YIELD
THEM HIGHER PAYER SALARIES. I
WHERE I TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION TO SUPPORT EDUCATION
TRAINING FOR EXISTING EMPLOYEES
WHO WANT TO ENHANCE THEIR SKILLS
AND PROMOTE INTO ROLES REQUIRING
ADVANCED DEGREES. TWENTY FOUR
MILLION TO EXPAND SEAT.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
PATHWAYS TRAINING CORPS TO
SUPPORT EARLY PLACE FOR
PLACEMENT OF EARLY CAREER
PROFESSIONALS FROM THE
COMMUNITY. INTO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WAS HE PAGE WATCH
THIS TRAINING CORPS THEY HAD
OVER NINE HUNDRED APPLICANTS BUT
ONLY HAVE FORTY FIVE SLOTS. SO
THIS WOULD EXPAND COOKER SIZE
TWO HUNDRED TRAINEES PER YEAR
FOR THREE YEARS. SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION WITH EXPANSIVE BEACHES
CALIFORNIA MICROBIOLOGIST TRAIN
COHORT TO THIRTY TRAINEES PER
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS. THIS
TRAINING IS A REQUIREMENT THAT
MUST BE MET IN ORDER TO BECOME A
CERTIFIED MICROBIOLOGIST IN
THESE. ARE THE FOLKS THAT STUFF
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. AS ARE ALSO
ASKING FOR SIX POINT SIX NINE TO
SERVE SEEK. PUBLIC HEALTH LAB A
SPIRE. WHICH INTENDED TO ADDRESS
THE CURRENT SHORTAGE OF
LAUGHTER. I CAN TELL YOU FOR
THAT WE DO HAVE LEFT. THEY GONE
THROUGH THIS PRO SO IT IT'S- SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION WOULD EXPAND
CALIFORNIA'S- SEE PEACHES CAL
EIS TRAINING TWO HUNDRED FELLOWS
OVER THREE YEARS. THIS WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TRAINED
EPIDEMIOLOGIST OUR STATE MIGHT
BE SEEN FELLOW THAT CDPH AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. THIS
PACKAGE SUPPORTS VARIOUS LEVELS
OF OUR WORKFORCE EARLY CAREER
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DRAW AND FROM THE COMMUNITY.
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
AT ONE ADVANCE THEIR SKILLS. AS
SKILL POSITION THAT REQUIRE
BROADER TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
AND A FOCUS OF HARD TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN POSITIONS. WITH THIS
WE HOPE TO BEGIN CREATING A
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINE
TO CONSERVE CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS
TO COME THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MOVING ON TO OUR
SECOND SPEAKER TODAY. MY PLACE.
WITH A- YES PARK MAP MCMULLEN
ELSE BOOK. HI GOOD HAVE. SHARE
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS BETH NON
ASKING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE YEAH YOU CAL SEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN OVER A HUNDRED YOUTH
NURSES DOCTORS AND OTHER HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. AS YOU MEMBERS NO
WELL THAT WE CANNOT MAKE THE
PROMISE OF HELP ACCESS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY HEALTH EQUITY AND
JUSTICE REALITY THE CRITICAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE INDIVIDUALS HOPING TO
JOIN OR GROW WITHIN THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE CONTINUE TO FACE THE
SAME BARRIERS THAT CAN BE
SUMMARIZED IN THREE WORDS COST
LOCATION AND TIME. COLLECTIVELY
THESE FACTORS HAVE NOT ONLY
UNDERMINE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM BUT
SERVE TO FURTHER MARGINALIZE
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY OF
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TO SUCCEED
IN THIS PROFESSION ON THAT NOTE
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY SHARE WITH
USDA'S WORKFORCE PRIORITIES THAT
SPEND PUBLIC HEALTH PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY NURSING AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH. AS YOU AGE IS PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH JACK AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO GUARANTEE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THE
STAFF AND LEADERSHIP THING YET
WE BELIEVE AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION AND NEW
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED TO RETAIN
AND EXPAND PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE OF THESE NEW FUNDS
JUST OVER TWELVE MILLION ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. IS REQUESTED
FOR NEW. NOVELTY COME WORKER.
PROGRAMME TRAINING IN COMBAT.
INTO AN ROLES THEIR WORK FOR
UPSKILLING. IMPROVER TIMES BY
WORKERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
IN THE SAME ORGANIZATIONAL
EMPLOYERS LIKE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE EQUIPPED IN
TRAINING IN A WAY THAT BEST
SERVES THEM. WE MUST INVEST IN
OUR CURRENT WORK FORCE TO
ENCOURAGE A LIFETIME OF
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
WELL OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
IS KEY TO PREVENTION SO OUR
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS.
ASSEMBLY EVEN WITH RECENT
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS
CALIFORNIA'S LOSING MEDICAL
SCHOOL GRADUATES. THE TECHNICIAN
RESIDENCY SLOTS INDIVIDUALS ARE
MOVING OUT OF STATE TO COMPLETE
THEIR TRAINING AND ARE NOT
COMING BACK. THIS COUPLED WITH
INCREASING BURNOUT REALLY
RETIREMENT MEANS WE MUST DOUBLE
DOWN ON TRAINING IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT CMA IN THE
COMPANY VALUED LIKE DECISIONS WE
ASK YOU SUPPORT A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION IN NEW ONE TIME I'M A
CURRENCY FUNDING. PLAN THESE
FUNDS BETWEEN SONG BROWN COMBAT
FORCE BOTH OF WHICH AND
KRITERIEN TO GUARANTEE. RENZI
FUNDS GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES
WE- NEED. NURSING TRAINING NEEDS
ARE CRITICAL TO ESPECIALLY FOR
HOSPITALS HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
SKILLED NURSING. AND PROPERTY
CLINICS FORTY NINE THE NURSES
PER CAPITA CO BUT NINETEEN HAS
FURTHER DRIVEN BURN OUT. THIS
REASON WE'RE SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY NURSING
INITIATIVE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
THIS IS WHY WE ALSO SEE THE SNAP
QUALITY STANDARDS BOARD IS NOT
ONLY CRITICAL TO QUALITY CARE
BUT ALSO ESSENTIAL TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY INDUSTRY. LASTLY I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS USED FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND REQUEST A
THREE YEAR ONGOING INVESTMENT
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
WORKFORCE. IS FOUNDER COMPANION
TO SB TEN FOURTEEN MISINTERPRET
FOR TECHNOLOGIES THAT CURRENT
FUNDING NEEDS I NEEDED TO
BOLSTER ADDRESS. DEEPER
CHRISTOLOGY IS THAT THE RECALL
AND HEALTH CENTERS. WE AIM TO
CREATE A PATHWAY TO FROM CLINICS
TO HIRE AND RETAIN AFTER WORKERS
. TRAINING WITH 70% OF FUNDS
GOING TOWARD WAGES AND 30%
ALLOCATED FOR TRAINING AND
SUPPORTING WORKERS WELL TRAINED.
IN CLOSING WE THANK IN ADVANCE
FOR CONSIDER CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE NEEDS REPAIR FOR THE-
FY TWENTY TO TWENTY BUDGET THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR OR THAT. BUT
LET'S MOVE ON. THEN TO. CLAY AND
RIGHT INTO DIRECTOR OF THE-
HEALTH CARE FOR. WELCOMES AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON- I THANK FOR THE
OPTIONS WITH YOU TODAY I'M QUITE
RIDE DIRECTOR OF THE CHRONIC
HOLLISTER- HELLO SIR ABOUT. I'M
READY NURSE WHO. TRAINING YOU
GERIATRICS ADDITION MY DUTY AT
THE- FOUNDATION I ALSO HAVE THE
WORKFORCE POLICIES ISSUES FOR
HALF. AS A NURSE LONG TERM CARE
SETTING FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS I
KNOW FIRST HAND THE DAILY
CHALLENGES THE FACILITIES STAFF
FACE WHILE PROVIDING CARE TO THE
ELDERLY RESIDENTS. MULTIPLE FARM
IN AUSTIN COMPLICATED HEALTH
CARE NEEDS. I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH SOME FIRST HAND
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
ARE NURSING HOMES ARE FACING
REGARDING FOR SHORTAGES. IN
ADDITION I WILL ADDRESS THE TO
QUESTION. RAISED BY THE
COMMITTEE. THE SKILLED NURSING
AND LONG CARE. CONCEPT LONG CHIU
. INTO A PRO STAFF. INTO
NINETEEN TO THE END OF IT STATED
ESTIMATED CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
TWENTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS IN
THE COMING YEARS. THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THE CONFLICT THAT COULD
DEVASTATE BOB TOOK CARE
WORKFORCE. YOUR DAILY FROM CAST
MEMBERS ABOUT THEIR STRUGGLES TO
RECRUIT AND RETRAIN AND RETAIN
QUALIFIED NURSING STAFF. THIS
ISSUES ESPECIALLY IF PAIRED WITH
CNN'S THESE ARE THE DIRECT CARE
GIVERS HONORING INTERPRETER
NURSING TEAM A LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. THESE ARE THE
NURSING STAFF THAT. ARE WE ARE
MOST CHALLENGED TO FIND. NURSING
FACILITIES ACCOUNT. R. PLUMAS TO
HUNDRED. GOVERNMENT FIND WITH.
MOST NURSING RECEIVE REPORTS OF
WHICH SAID PER. OF THE PROJECT
FROM THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNMENT THE THIS. RECEIVE
PROVIDE FUNDING THE WAGES FOR
NURSING STAFF THE SUPPORT STAFF
PAYMENT FOR OPERATING. INCLUDING
UTILITIES SUPPLIES AND FOOD FOR
RESIDENTS AND RENT TO PAY FOR
THE HOUSE ACROSS FOR THE
RESIDENTS. AT THE STATE RIGHT
INDUSTRY LEVEL SALARIES AND
WAGES PER PATIENT DAY INCREASED
BY 15% TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. NURSING HOMES OF
INVESTED A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF SCIENCE RECRUITING RETRAIN
NURSING STAFF. WITH THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM DOESN'T SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS ITS FORWARD IT
DEVASTATING THESE FACILITIES. DO
THE CURRENT BY OF STOCK UNTIL OF
NURSING. THE FOLLOWING ISSUES OR
CURRENT. PROVIDERS ARE CURRENTLY
UNABLE TO ACCEPT ADMISSION
STUDENTS INABILITY TO MEET
REGULATED STAFFING HOURS THIS
WILL IMPACT INDIVIDUALS SEEKING
PLACEMENT AFTER DISCHARGE FROM
THE HOSPITAL RECURRING ARE
REQUIRING REHAB OR SKILLED CARE
. PROVIDED TO UNABLE TO ATTRACT
NEW RECRUITS TO THE SECTOR DUE
TO FEARS RELATED TO THE COMPANY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC LACK OF
PROFESSIONALISM FOR WAGES OF
LACK OF CAREER ADVANCEMENT.
PROVIDERS OF LOSING EXISTING
STAFF TO BE CUTE HOSPITAL'S
STAFFING AGENCIES AND EVEN NON
HEALTHCARE SETTINGS RELATED TO
THEIR HOUSE FOR HIGHER WAGES
BENEFITS PACKAGES BEING OFFERED
. CAFU'S SUGGESTS THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE ISSUES AMONG TRIP YOUR
FACILITIES AND IMPROVE THE
PIPELINE FOR NURSING HOME
WORKFORCE. ONE CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS WAGES MUST INCREASE
NURSING FACILITY DIRECT CARE
STAFF WITH THE CORNERSTONE OF
DELIVERY QUALITY OF CARE. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE
WAGES THAT REFLECT THE SKILLED
CARE THEY PROVIDE TO THE STATE
SECRETS RESIDENTS THIS REQUIRES
A MEDICARE PROGRAM PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY FUNDS PASSED THROUGH
FOR THE WAGE INCREASES. KAFIRS
PREFER PROPOSED THE DRIVE TO
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
SEEN A MINIMUM WAGE OF. TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE STATE INVESTMENT
CERTIFIED NURSING WORK FIRST OF
. MUSCATINE AND BE ENHANCED.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT THE STATE
PROFESORA TRIES THE RECRUITMENT
AND TRAINING OF NURSING
FACILITIES STAFF AS IT MOVES TO
INVEST IN THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
CALIFORNIA. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
PROVIDED FORTY FIVE MILLION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS INFORMATION. CAN ALSO
SUGGESTING SUSTAIN PROGRAM IF IT
TRIED TO EXPAND FINANCE SUPPORT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SOLUTIONS
TO INCREASE THE NURSING HOME
WORK FORCE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY. CNA'S NEED TO BE
PROFESSIONAL EYES THANKSGIVING
CAREER LADDER OPTIONS CNA'S
HISTORICALLY BEEN VIEWED AS
ENTRY LEVEL WORKERS WITH FEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPSKILLING
RECOGNITION OF ADVANCED
EDUCATION AND SKILLS DEVELOPMENT
WORK COMPENSATION BASED ON THEIR
SKILL. SET A WORK EXPERIENCE
CASF BELIEVES THAT THE BEST FOR
THE- FESCUE PROFESSIONALS CA
WORKFORCE THERE NEEDS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WOULD
BEST BE REPRESENTED IN OVERSEEN
BY LICENSE SUPPORT. THE CURRENT
NURSING HOMES CRISIS IS LIKE
NOTHING I'VE SEEN MY ENTIRE%
FORTY PLUS YEARS REGISTERED
NURSE THIS CRISIS CANNOT BE
SOLVED THE COMMITMENT OF THE
STATE TO INVEST THE FUNDS
NECESSARY TO HAVE STAFF WAGES.
AND DEVELOP WORKFORCE CANCER
PROGRAMS CAST STRONGLY SUPPORT
THESE INVESTMENTS WERE
COMMITTING THEIR OWN FUNDS TIME
AND EFFORTS IMPROVEMENTS IN
WORKFORCE AVAILABILITY. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OUR WORK
PRICE. CASTING DRESSED IN AS TO
SUPPORT ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AT CATS SCOTT PLEASE FOR
CALIFORNIA HAS SO SHE- GOOD
MORNING YOU FOR HAVING US HI AND
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JOIN THE PANEL ENSURE THE
HOSPITAL. SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING OUR MOST COMMON
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES AND THE
MOST EFFECTIVE STATE INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS THOSE TIMES.
HOSPITALS HAVE FACED WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES FOR YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED THE WORST
STAFFING SHORTAGE IN MEMORY AS A
RESULT OF RETIREMENT AND THE
SLOWED PIPELINE. THIS IS TAKING
A HEAVY TOLL ON HOSPITALS AND
FRONTLINE WORKERS. A STUDY
RELEASED BY KAUFMAN HALL THE
TREMENDOUS COLLECTIVE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC PUSH 51% OF
HOSPITALS INTO THE REST. OF THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS OF LOS
ABOUT TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AND
RECEIVE FREE ONLY HAVING
RECEIVED EIGHT BILLION FEDERAL.
WHEN ANALYZING THE SPECIFIC
REASONS FOR THE COST INCREASES
THEY ATTRIBUTED THE MAIN DRIVER.
TO HIGHER LABOR COSTS AND
MEDICAL. SUPPLY CHAIN SHORTAGES
MUCH OF THIS WAS A RESULT OF
WORK FOR CHALLENGES WERE
HOSPITALS HAD TO RELY HEAVILY ON
TIME CONTRACT STAFFING TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF THE PANDEMIC. AT
ALMOST DOUBLE THE RATE. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC SEAT YOU SUPPORTED
THE FUTURE THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE PATH
OUTLINED IN THE MEETING. THE
DEMAND FOR HEALTHCARE REPORT
RELEASED IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
CRITICAL STOPS STILL APPLY TO
INCREASE. UP TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE INCLUDING
EXPANDING EDUCATION AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. INCREASING
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION. AND
INCLUSION OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE I STAYED IN THE
GOVERNORS CARE ECONOMY
INITIATIVE. WHICH EMBODIES THESE
APPROACHES TEACHERS ON FULL
SUPPORT OF HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT EXPAND
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION. FULLER MEMBERS REPORT
SHORTAGES IN ALL AREAS BUT
HOSPITALS NURSING AT ALL LEVELS
ARE AND CNA'S L. B. AND- CENTS
NURSE PACTITIONERS AND NURSE
MIDWIVES ALWAYS COME UP IS A
CRITICAL NEED. ADDITIONALLY THE
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED THE
WORSENING DOCTOR SHORTAGE. OF
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS TRAIN MORE DOCTORS
THAN ALMOST EVERY OTHER STATE
ARE WE ARE NEARLY LAST IN THE
COUNTRY IN RECEIVING STATE
SUPPORT FOR THESE GME PROGRAMS.
IS COSTLY JIMMY PROGRAMS ARE
LARGELY UNDERFUNDED AND FACE
SIGNIFICANT BUDGETARY REST AS
POSSIBLE BEGIN THEIR LONG ROAD
TO FINANCIAL RECOVERY FOLLOWING
THE PANDA. CJ PROPOSED OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
EXPANSION IN STATE FUNDING FOR
GME PROGRAMS. THROUGH THE
MEDICAID HEALTH PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES THE STATE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES ALL THEIR
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT CAN BE
MATCHED A SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDING. ONLY TWENTY ONE
HOSPITALS TODAY ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE SUPPORT FOR THE MEDICARE
GME PROGRAM AND I REQUEST
EXPERIENCE THAT CRITICAL ACCESS
TO STATE AND FEDERAL SUPPORT.
FOR THE OTHER EIGHTY ONE
HOSPITALS TEACHING THE FUTURE.
DOCTORS OF CALIFORNIA. LASTLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE STATE
IS GOING TO. THE PROGRAM MAKE
ANY. FOR INCREASE DIVERSE AND
EQUITY HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE YOU
CANNOT BE DONE WITH. WHILE
CONTINUING TO UNDER COMMUNITY.
THAT PROVIDED. AMOUNT OF.
SERVICES TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES TEACHER PROPOSES
TO UNFREEZE THEIR FEE FOR
SERVICE RATES AN AUGMENT THESE
PAYMENTS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES PATIENTS. MAY BE
EXPERIENCING ALONG WITH
CONVERTING PUBLICADO RATES TO
VALUE BASED PURCHASING TO
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THESE
HOSPITALS AS THEY SUPPORT
PATIENTS AND THEIR WORK FORCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NOW WILL MOVE TO THAT. MR CUEVAS
ROMERO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR DENNIS THE MATTER WHAT THE
LEAD. LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OF PROVIDE
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS ISSUE- CMA
HAS SEVERAL PROPOSALS SEEKING TO
ADDRESS THE POSITION SHORTAGE IN
BOTH THE SHORT TERM AND THE LONG
TERM. FIRSTLY CMA IS
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
PROPOSALS. IN PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION IS FOCUSED ON THE
PROPOSED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY POSITIONS.
AS THIS COMMITTEE WELL KNOWS IT
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED THOROUGHLY
ALREADY MENTAL HEALTH WAS A
MAJOR ISSUE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND COVER NINETEEN IS
ONLY FURTHER EXACERBATED. THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM. CMA IS A AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO INVEST ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED- TO SUPPORT
GRADUATE MEDIC MEDICAL
EDUCATION. ALONG WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALLUM BORN
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO INCREASE LOCALLY
TRAINED PHYSICIANS. IN THAT SAME
VEIN CMA IS. PURSUING OUR CAT
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE PHYSICIANS
FIND THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT'S
PART OF THAT CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS BUDGET
PRIORITIES. WHICH CREATES A
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM PROVIDING UP
FRONT FUNDING FOR UNDERGRADUATE
MEDICAL SCHOOL AND RESIDENCY
EDUCATION FOR INDIVIDUALS UNDER
REPRESENTED MEDICINE. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD MAKE A SERVICE
COMMITMENT UPON COMPLETION OF
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN A RURAL
OR MEDICAL MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. OUR PROPOSAL IS
REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION TO
SUPPORT THIS INNOVATIVE APPROACH
TO DEVELOPING A FUTURE
GENERATION OF DIVERSE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
POSITIONS. ANOTHER CMA PROPOSAL
FOCUSES ON PROVIDING ANOTHER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION TOOL
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
BY CREATING A DEDICATED FIRST OF
ITS KIND LONGER PAYMENT PROGRAM
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS WE
HAVE A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR **** IN ADDITION TO A
POLICY BILL. AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. GOING BACK
TO GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT PROVIDE AN
ONGOING DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE
WHILE PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX DOES
FIND JIMMY THAT REVENUE SOURCE
IS A DIMINISHING REVENUE- BASED
ON TOBACCO USAGE- ADDITIONALLY
CMA DOES NOT HAVE A CENTRAL
PARK. SWEET CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
HAVE A CENTRALIZED PLANNING UP
TO OVERSEE AND PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON JIMMY.
CREATING A DEDICATED REVENUE
SOURCE WILL PROVIDE CONSISTENCY
TO JIMMY PROVIDERS AND PLANNING
LONG TERM AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR PANTS AND
POTENTIALLY CREATE NEW PROGRAMS
IN THE MOST NEEDED COMMUNITY
SUCH AS REGIONS OF NORTHERN
SIERRA. SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
THEN WITH THEM QUITE. FINALLY AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY- THE ISSUE
OF HEALTH CARE COULD HELP
PROVIDER BURNOUT AND MENTAL
HEALTH EFFECTS OF THE- PROVIDING
CARE DURING THE PANDEMIC IS
ESSENTIAL- THAT WE TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE- CMA IS HAPPY
TO ENGAGE AND WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP.RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES THANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S NOW MOVE TO OUR
FINAL. PANEL PERSON- THE TITAN
NOT DELETE A PLEASE. I DON'T
CARE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ALONGSIDE KENNEL STEAK.
AND PARTNER. I'M NATALIE AGAIN
THAT PETER OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE CALIFORNIA.
CARE I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
MORE THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS. THAT
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE. THAT'S ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS. THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS HAVE
BEEN VITAL PARTNERS THE STATE.
COVER NINETEEN RESPOND. BY
SERVING ON THE FRONT LINES INTO
HEARING FOR THE STATE MORE
VULNERABLE PATIENT POPULATION.
THE PERSON WHO. SO WE NEED YOUR
HELP. HEARING HEALTH CENTERS ARE
IN THE BOOK TO. THE TO THE ON
PRETTY THIS. PORTION BY THE
WRITING THE FOR NINETEEN RESPOND
AND THE CLINICAL PROFESSIONAL.
OVER PAST TWO YEARS WE THINK
INCREASE RATES OF BURNOUT EARLY
RETIREMENT A TIGHT LABOR MARKET
COMPETITION AND RISING COSTS. I
THANK YOU WHERE RELYING ON ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CARE TEAM REMARK
ADDITION FOR NURSING. IT WILL BE
SENT. TO WORKERS IN DENTAL. AND
MORE. THEY ALL PROVIDE A
CRITICAL IN SERVING THE
UNDERSERVED. THERE'S A STRONG
NEED TO DEVELOP ALL DISCIPLINES
AND ALSO. CAN HELP INDUSTRY
ATTACKED ADS HAVE BEEN. DURING
THE MEETING. IF THEY RECOGNIZE
THE THIS ARE NOT UNIQUE TO CAN
HEALTH CENTER. ARE OPEN BY OTHER
DELIVERY SYSTEM. SUCH AS- I AM
VERY WHO ARE RECOGNIZED THE
OTHER SIDE FONG FALL. WE ARE
EXCITED THAT THE GOVERNOR IN A
CAR HAS THING AND- SUPPORTING
THE DEVELOPING. OF A ROBOT IN
THE HEALTHCARE WORK. THREE
ADDITIONAL. WORKING DONE TO
CLOSE THE GAP IN THE HEALTH
WORSE FOR AND PROVIDE MORE. AND
ENTRIES IN HELP ABOUT. AS A
RESULT THE BCA ALONG OUR
ATTITUDES IT CALIFORNIA OF
ADVOCATES. STATED A WORK I DID
ASK OLYMPIC AND HOPE TO. SECOND
FIFTH ONE DOLLARS IN NEW STATE
INVESTMENT. OUR GOAL IS TO.
PRIMER CARE ALLIED HEALTH AND
BECAUSE HOLD STUDENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL FROM OUR LOOK
COMMUNITY. ENTER TRAIN AND
PRODUCT. WITHIN UNDER POPULATION
SUCH AS THOSE. HI COMMITTEE
CENTERS ARE WORK FOR STATE THE
HOUR OF A UP INTO THREE AREAS. I
MEAN I POINT THREE MILLION
SCHOLARS AND REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
THE FEMALE BROADBAND PROP
CLINICIANS PRO. AND FIVE POINT
MILLION FOR GRAD MEDICAL. BUT BY
CLINTON IN THE NUMBER OF
HEALTHCARE WHO ARE VITAL TO THE
HEALTH DELIVERY. IMPROVE AND
HELP. SHE DID MANAGE TO AN
INCLUSION AMONG THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. YOU COULD NOT AND
WILL ALSO INCREASE CARE FOR. THE
FOR. WE'RE ASKING THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK
ALLOCATE THESE IN THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE CALLS
STATE BUDGET INCREASE CLINIC
CRITICAL HEALTHCARE WORK
SHORTAGE. WE RECOMMEND THAT THEY
NEEDED AND THEIR THE AGE CRIED.
AND MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED ENERGY NEEDS I THIRTY
HEALTHCARE TRAINEES AND
PROFESSIONALS. ALSO KNOWLEDGE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
AROUND REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED BY EIGHT EIGHT
AT THAT EITHER AN ISSUE GIVEN
THE IMPORTANCE OF EXPANDING THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WORKFORCE IN THE
PREVIOUS YOU KNOW. WE'RE EXCITED
BE LEADING ASKING THREE UPWARDS
ALONGSIDE OUR PARTNERS INCLUDING
LONG TODAY AND. THANK YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HAPPEN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
AND THANK YOU TO THE PANEL THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR- YOUR- OF YOUR-
OF YOUR STRATEGIES IN YOUR
PROPOSALS AND- ALL OF THOSE WILL
BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION. FOR
ITS IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE
HAVE ANOTHER HEARING COMING UP A
DOCTOR PAN YOU WANT TO START OFF
WITH QUESTIONS FOR THIS. OKAY
THANK YOU I'M SURE AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS I THINK- IT DID
BRING UP THE POINT TO BE REAL
HEALTH PANEL THE TASSEL PLIGHT
OF THIS PANEL- BUT I GUESS- THE
FIRST OF ALL. I DO AYE KNOWLEDGE
THE- YEAH- OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. THERE'S RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS SO AT THAT WE TALKED MORE
BROADLY ABOUT THE STRESS AND THE
FRANKLY- POSTER MAX STRESS
DISORDER THAT'S BEING
EXPERIENCED BY THE OVERALL
HEALTH WORKFORCE BECAUSE OF
COVIDIEN- THE STRUGGLES OF. OF
MANY OF THE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
FRONTLINE. FOLKS BUT I DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT- ACTUALLY DOES
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE HAS BEEN EVEN
MORE IMPACTED SO SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH. PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
IS ON THE FRONT IS ON THE FRONT
LINES AND- UNFORTUNATELY- HEALTH
CARE WORKERS OVERALL BUT
PARTICULARLY PUBLIC HEALTH.
WORKERS HAVE ALSO BEEN SUBJECT
TO PERSONAL ATTACKS HARASSMENT-
NOT JUST IN THE WORKPLACE BUT
EVEN AT THEIR HOMES- SO WE'VE
SEEN CERTAINLY. HEALTHCARE
WORKERS- AND HOSPITALS AND OTHER
PLACES BEING ATTACKED AT THEIR-
WORK PLACE- UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
MISINFORMATION OR DISINFORMATION
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT
HAVE INCITED- NOT BE OF COURSE-
DELIVERS THAT HARM. PATIENTS BUT
ALSO FACTUALLY LED TO VIOLENT
ATTACKS. AGAINST HEALTH CARE
WORKERS BUT- PUBLIC HEALTH-
WORKERS THEMSELVES HAVE. ENTERED
THESE ATTACKS AT. AND SOMETIMES.
PROBLEMS AND- SO- BUT IT WAS
THAT WE ALSO THAT SO VERY THAT.
TRY TO- SUSTAIN THAT WERE FORCE
EXPAND I THINK THAT CERTAINLY
APPLIES TO THE OTHER WORKFORCES
AS WELL- PERHAPS- MAYBE I'LL
JUST OPPOSE ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
IS SAID BECAUSE WE'RE SHORT ON
TIME IS. YELLOW AGAIN THERE'S A
LOT PROPOSALS FOR PIPELINE
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE SUPPORT OF
THOSE BUT CAN YOU SPEAK TO
PARTICULARLY RETENTION. EFFORTS
TO HELPS SUSTAIN OUR CURRENT
WORK FORCE- MANY OF WHOM
UNFORTUNATELY ARE EITHER LOOKING
TO RETIREMENT SOON OUR- JUST OR
JUST BASICALLY LEAVING BECAUSE
IF THEY'RE FED UP- SO CAN WE
TALK ABOUT RETENTION EFFORTS
THAT- WE SHOULD BE PURSUING IS
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP THE-
WORKFORCE WE HAVE. CONTINUING TO
GO TO CONTINUING TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE NEED.
WHAT'S THAT YEAH. AND YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES. YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD PLEASE YOU KNOW AND
PERCENT I JUST THE SHEET THE
COMMON THAT YOU MADE IT
KNOWLEDGE IN THE HER CHALLENGES
THAT WORKFORCE IS IN TOWARD I
THINK IT ALSO NOT- ONLY IS KIND
OF THE LINE RIGHT AS ARM ARE
WORK SEASON LEADERSHIP LEAVING
THE THAT WERE ABOUT SUCCEEDING
IN LEADERSHIP OR MAYBE MY
DIFFERENT CHOICES AND EXPLORING
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE OF
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STATEMENT THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IT'S A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION EIGHT THE REASON WHY
WE'RE DOING THAT IS THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED A MIXTURE OF LIKE
NEW WORK FORCE BUT ALSO
RETAINING OUR EXISTING WORKFORCE
AND SO. PART OF THIS IS PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES ARE BEING OFFERED
SIGN ON BONUSES FROM OTHER
ENTITIES LIKE COME OUR WAY AND
SO COULD WE NEGOTIATE A
LONGEVITY BONUS FOR THESE NURSES
ARE AGREEING TO STAY WITH US FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS SO THAT WE CAN
RETAIN THAT KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL
SET SIMILARLY WITH LAB DIRECTORS
AND SO FORTH AND THE OTHER THING
THAT WE REALLY TRYING TO BE
THOUGHTFUL LINE IS REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE HELP FOLKS
ADVANCE IN THEIR CAREERS WHILE
THEY'RE ALREADY IN THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THAT IS
WHAT. THE TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IS DEDICATED TO REALLY
ALLOWING OUR EXISTING WORKFORCE
LET'S SAY YOU'RE YOU'RE IN BUT
YOU WANT TO BECOME AS SOMETHING
THAT REQUIRES A MORE ADVANCED OR
SKILL DEGREED MAYBE A LAB
ASSISTANT YOU WANTED IT TO THE
LAB DIRECTOR LEVEL WE WANT TO
HAVE. FOR YOU TO CONTINUE YES
THE SKILL SETS THAT YOU STAY
WITHIN THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
LASTLY I WOULD JUST MENTION A
NUMBER OF THE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES EVEN THAT THE
PATHWAYS PROGRAM RATES GRABBING
EARLY CAREER INDIVIDUALS THE
INTENT IS TO GIVE EXPOSURE INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HOPEFULLY THAT
MAKE FOLKS STAY IN JUST AS AN
ASIDE I WILL TELL YOU I SPOKE
WITH THE PATHWAYS COHORT AND ONE
GENTLEMAN MESSAGED ME ON THE
SIDE IS THAT I AM THE OLD BASED
BUT I AM NEW TO PUBLIC HEALTH I
LOVE WHAT I'M DOING RIGHT NOW IT
WAS JUST THE EXPOSURE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT ALLOWED. HIM TO
REALLY REALIZE THAT SO WE WANTED
TO HAVE THAT MIXTURE OF THINGS
THAT COULD BRING PEOPLE AND DRAW
THEM AND RETAIN THEM IN OUR
WORKFORCE AND THEN ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT FOLKS CAN
BE FILLED AND GET THAT THE
CAPACITY AND SKILLS THEY NEEDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I SEE A. BUNCH OF BOOKS
OTHER HAND UP SO WE'LL GO NOW
HOW TO. MISS- MELANAU SKI. THANK
YOU- AND JANICEK THE COMMON MADE
BY MR AGAIN AS RELEASED THE
HEALTH AND BEST SOMEWHERE RIGHT
AT THIS TIME WE THINK ABOUT
UPSCALE THAT IS A FANCY WAY OF
SAY RETAINING AND SO RAPIDLY
COMMITTED TO THAT AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE CAN WORK CREATING-
THE IN. AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO STAY
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
THE DURATION OF THEIR CAREERS.
ADDITIONALLY I JUST COME IN A
FEW OTHER- ELEMENTS- WE THINK
ABOUT THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
NURSING NITIATIVE I THINK ONE
THE THINGS THAT EXCITES US. IS
THINKING ABOUT THAT NURSING
PIPELINE- AND THE POTENTIAL THAT
IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL IN BUILDING
OUT THAT PIPELINE WITH SOMEONE
STARTS OUT- IN A CERTAIN.
POSITION WITH THE NURSING THEY
CONTINUE TO GROW TO THE NEXT
LEVEL MAYBE THERE ARE IN TODAY.
AND THEY WENT B. AND P. IN THE
FUTURE JUST THINK AGAIN BUT HOW
DO WE RETAIN INDIVIDUALS IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. THE
CERTAINLY ALSO UNDER INTEREST ME
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE COULD BE
DOING DIFFERENTLY WITH SKILLED
NURSING- AND RECOGNIZING THAT
THE POTENTIAL THE QUALITY
STANDARDS BOARD IS THINKING
ABOUT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. HOW
DO WE GROW- SKILL UP OR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES STAFF. AGAIN
THEY ARE PROVIDING CARE FOR
DECADES TO COME. AND LASTLY
AUTISTIC KNOWLEDGE AS RELATES TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND ACCURACY
IS- PRIOR TO MY- TERM AS YEAH
YOU I SPENT MANY YEARS WORKING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION LET THINGS THAT WE
OBSERVE. THAT HEALTH NEEDS WERE
BECOMING THE TRAINING GROUND FOR
THE REST OF DELIVERY SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND RESOURCES-
TO INCREASE PAY. TO DO- TRAINING
ON THE JOB I'M SURE. ELEMENT OUT
OPPORTUNITIES WE WERE LOSING OUR
WORK FORCE THE REST THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO THE REASONS WHY SB I
USE NOW COMMITTING. FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND REQUEST TO
GET OVER THREE YEARS THINK ABOUT
NEW WAYS TO SUPPORT OUR CALL
CENTER. WORKFORCE. AND KEEP THEM
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH. THANK YOU
VERY- MYSTERIOUS. ADL AND ADDING
ON TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE ALSO JUST WANT TO
BUILD UP IT BY EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING YOU KNOW AN
OVERALL PACKAGE WHICH IS THE ONE
THAT WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD THAT
REALLY TARGETS MULTIPLE AREAS IN
THE WHITE WINE OR IN THE
BACKGROUND OF AN INDIVIDUAL YOU
KNOW TRAINING AND- PRACTICE. AND
THAT'S REALLY A LARGE PART WHY
WE WALKED OUT HOW WE CAN BUILD
SOMETHING HAD AFFECT THE
TRAINING RIGHT BECAUSE EVEN MY
FRIEND NOT AS SOMEONE IS
TRAINING FOR EXAMPLE IN A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER WE'RE
TRYING TO AND YOU KNOW ALSO GET
THEM FAMILIAR WITH HER STUDYING
AND. YOU KNOW. NINETY NINE
SHARPIE POP. AND IN BY THE-
WATCHING BACK IN FRONT STATE OUR
SETTING WANT. AND WHEN WE COME
THAT SMALLER SHIPS LAUNDRY.
RIGHT REALLY MAKING SURE WE CAN
THAT CONNECTION. WITH THOSE IN
THE AND THEY INTO PRACTICE THE
OPRAH. SOME OF THE- YOU KNOW
WITH MANTA AROUND I'M FEELING
AND- CENTER LONG TERM RETURN.
WITHIN OUR- YOU KNOW. THANK YOU
FOR THE ADDITION. OF MR CUEVAS
FROM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
FROM PHYSICIAN PREFER I FOR US I
AS AS BOOKS WELL NO WHERE YOU
TRAIN IS ALL WHERE YOU END CRACK
SEEN- AND SO IN CREE SEEN-
TARGETED YEAH YOU KNOW JIMMY COO
CREE PROGRAMS CAN UNDER
COMMUNITIES BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOT SELFISH RIGHT
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW. IF THE PAY
REMAIN ANAK OR INEQUITABLE TO
URBAN AREAS I THAT'S ALL GOING
TO BE A FOR RURAL AND UNDER
COMMUNITIES SO- YOU KNOW THE
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
INCREASING THE INCREASING THE
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE- THE
FINDINGS FURTHER LOAN REPAYMENT
BECAUSE THOSE PROGRAMS ARE OFTEN
IMPACTED- AND YOU KNOW THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS ARE I THINK ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT A LASTING I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW FURTHER DE
STIGMATIZE SCENE- OUTREACH AND
GETTING SUPPORT WHEN- PROVIDERS
AND PHYSICIANS HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- BECAUSE THAT IT'S
CRITICALLY. IMPORTANT YOU CAN'T
CARE FOR YOUR PATIENTS AND YOU
CAN'T CARE FOR YOURSELF AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE WHERE WE WE'VE TAKEN
SOME POSITIVE STEPS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR-
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN
POSITION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS ENTER. I APPRECIATE
THEM HAVING TRYING TO SPEAK MORE
TIME BUT WHEN IT WAS LIKE TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT THIS. <c.cyan>/C IN</c>
A.'S THAT THE WE HAVE IN OUR
LONG TERM CARE. THE LONGER
THEY'RE WITH US THE BETTER JOB
THEY DO THE BOND RESEARCH OR
RESIDENTS IF THEY STAY FOR FIVE
YEARS THAT MEANS THAT THEY WERE
DOING A GOOD JOB FOR THEM. USING
THEM AS UPON AS A CAREER LADDER
THAT THAT'S JUST A STEPPING
STONE IS A DISSERVICE TO THE C.
N. A.'S THAT WANT TO BE CNN'S.
AND IT'S A DISSERVICE TO OUR
RESIDENTS. AND FRANKLY IT'S A IT
TAKES A REAL TOLL ON NURSING
HOMES BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR
TRAINING GROUND. YOU CAN'T JUST
CONSTANTLY TRAINING UP WE WANT
TO RETAIN THEM WE WANTED TO STAY
WITH US. AND IF THEY'RE GOOD CNA
WE WANT THEM TO BE REWARDED IS
BEING A GOOD SEEING. SO US UPS.
VALUE WHEN THEIR SKILLS VALUING
THEIR AND SHIPPING THEM HE IS
CONTINUING EDUCATION CREDITS THE
EMPHASIZE THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
SKILLS THAT THEY'VE LEARNED
BEYOND BASICS. I THINK WOULD BE
VERY VERY VALUE TO OUR SECTOR
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY WE WERE
SUGGESTING THAT THERE ACTUALLY
IS A LICENSURE BOARD RATHER THAN
BEING NESTLEDIN CDPH BUT IN
ADDITION TO THE- TO. INCREASING
RATE WE TO REALLY BILL THE WORK
THAT STAYS WITH US FROM PERIOD
TIME AND THEY FEEL. AND VALUED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY US OF
THE OF THE NOBILITY- OF THE
WORKED AT C. N. STUDENTS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT JOB
ESPECIALLY IN OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND IF ANYBODY'S EVER
TRIED TO DO THAT A COUPLE I
INVITE YOU TO WORK COUPLE CHEFS-
AND UNDERSTAND. THE COMPLEXITIES
IN A STRAIN ON. SPENT
EMOTIONALLY SPIRITUALLY
PHYSICALLY. ON TO SOMEONE ELSE
AS THEY'RE ENGAGING IN THAT-
SEND THEM ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES UP WITH CARING FOR THE
WORK FORCE I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO TALK TO ABOUT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS. AS
THEY REALLY BEEN ENGAGING IN
THIS WORK AND SOMETIMES A- ABOUT
THE FRUSTRATIONS WITH THEM-
SOMETIMES WITH THE FRUSTRATIONS
WITH THE PUBLIC SOMETIMES
FRUSTRATIONS WITH OUR SYSTEMS-
THAT ARE PUT IN PLACE. FOR LIKE
YOU KNOW THIS MORE TIME DOCUMENT
DOCUMENT THINGS THAN THEY ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING CARE SO.
ALWAYS REALLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND ABOUT HOW WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. AND
NORMALIZE PEOPLE SEEKING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THEMSELVES.
AS A STRUGGLING WORK. SCOTT YOU
HAVE YOUR BAND UP FOR A FINAL
REMARK JUST REALLY QUICK I THINK
FIRST WE ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH MANY OF THE PREDECESSORS
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO THE
INCUMBENT WORKFORCE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING PATHWAYS
TO OUR WORKFORCE- IN THE
HOSPITAL ENVIRONMENT. BUT ALSO
BELIEVE WOULD BE REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T POINT OUT APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE OFTEN- SEE THIS IS A
VERY- IN ALL OF OUR ENVIRONMENTS
NOT JUST RULED URBAN EXCEPT FOR
OUR HOSPITALS ARE INVESTING MORE
IN THIS FIGHT. IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT OUR WORKERS RECRUIT
WORKERS- TO THE TO THE WORKFORCE
SO JUST JUST FELT LIKE IT WAS
ONE AREA WHERE JUST BECOMING
MORE AND MORE REALITY FOR OUR
WORKFORCE YEAH. YEAH THANK YOU
WE- WE LIVE IN AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX WORLD ONLY. AND THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
TRYING TO PROVIDE- THE HEALTH
CARE TO KEEP US ALL HEALTHY- ON
ALL LEVELS. TWEET AS WE
TRAVERSE- AS WE TRAVERSE THE SO.
I THINK THAT WILL BE IT FOR
TODAY WE REALLY REALLY THANK THE
PANEL AND I GUESS. THE MEASURE
IS A WHAT DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS EVERYONE ELSE GOT SAY
SOME LASTING. NO THANK YOU- NO I
THINK YOU. NEED TO LEARN FROM
ALL OF THE OTHER PALACE TODAY
AND I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT-
YES WE- RECOGNIZE ESPECIALLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RETENTION
THAT THOSE THAT ARE TRAINED IN.
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND SERVING
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO STAY AND- ALL OF OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS UP WITH AS OUR
EDUCATION ATTY TRAINING
PROGRAMS. HAVE A REAL PRIORITY
AND FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE ARE TRAINED IN THESE
AREAS AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. SPEND TIME AND SERVE OUR
COUNTRY- WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF UNDERPAYMENT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS AND- AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO ENHANCE THEM TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANT. SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELOR VARIETY OF
PROVIDER TYPES THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ESSENTIAL. TO BE
ABLE TO. RETAIN THE NEW. THE
WORK FORCE THROUGH THE ONLY
PAYMENT BUT ALSO. TO HELP YOU GO
THROUGH. THEIR THERE ARE
TRAINING WILL. COMING OUT WITH
THAT THAT GIVES A OF A NOT. TO
BE ABLE TO STAY. IN THE PLACE
THAT THEY ARE- THEY ARE WORKING
. I'M AND THEN FINE BEGIN THE
WORK OF OUR WAY. EDUCATION
TRAINING HEALTH- AS WE- EMBARK
ON THE WORK WHEN OF THE AREAS OF
FOCUS IS AROUND. MANY AT- AND-
THE WORKER BACK COUNCIL BE
REALLY EXAM INTAKE A LOOK. AT
THE G. THE I CAPACITY AND- IN.
ALONG WITH THE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING IN OTHER AREAS- AND SO
WE ARE WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
WORK OF THAT COUNCIL REALLY TALK
START TAKING OUT STATEWIDE BOOK.
AT SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT ALL
OF THE- HEARING ABOUT. YOU OKAY
. THANK YOU ALL MUCH- FOR PER US
- BETWEEN YOU AND DEPARTMENTS WE
WILL WE WILL COME UP WITH SOME
THINGS- SO THINKING EVERYBODY
AND NOW WE WILL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS- IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM. TWELVE HUNDRED THAT
WISHES TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
. I SEE NONE- I WILL TELL IN
TURN TO THE PHONE RIGHT LINE'S
MODERATOR OR USE THEIR- I AM
HERE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND FIRST WE WILL HEAR FROM LINE
FOURTEEN THE BILL HAS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER
DIANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION I'M CALLING IT AN
ISSUE NUMBER Q. THE OPPOSITE
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CREATION OF THE-
HCA IN SUPPORTING THE BTC
REQUEST FOR. THE THREE THIRTEEN
PERSONNEL INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE STAFFING SUPPORT TARGET
SETTING ENFORCEMENT IN GENERAL
MINISTRATIONS OF THE MARTIN
PROGRAM EVERY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER WITH PRIVATE INSURANCE
IS BEING HIT BY THE RISING COST
OF HEALTHCARE AND FEELING THE
IMPACT OF STAGNATING STAGNATING
WAGES. ANY FORGOING CARE THEY
CAN OF IT. THE DATA SHOWS AGAIN
AND AGAIN MAIN KERR REFERENCE.
IS AND HOW YOU. BUT HIGH. IN
THOSE HAVE ARE NOT POORLY WITH
MORE OR BETTER. FOR THESE
REASONS REPEAT THAT OUR OF CARE
FOR. IN THE C. PETER TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR ARE COMMON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLORFUL. WELL I
TWENTY TWO. HELLO AFTERNOON THAT
AND SHE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WARNED TEACHER COME HAVE A WHICH
YOU'LL CAL IN SUPPORT OF FEWER
AND THAT OF HEALTH CARE ACT FROM
FIRST SUPPORT AT ISSUE THE
HEALTH CARE FOR. WE BELIEVE THAT
QUICKLY AT THE OF TACKLING COST
HEALTH CARE AT ITS AND THE ZIPPO
IN THE AND CARE ACT BEFORE YOU
TODAY TRANSPARENT WILL BE IN
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR COST GROWTH
AND MOVED TOWARDS REWARD FOLLOW
OF CARE AND PATIENT OUT. THIS IS
HUGE STEP FOR THE STATE AND RELY
IT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS ACT
EQUITABLE FOR HIGH AND IT BEEN A
BELIEVE. SECOND CALL IN SUPPORT
AT ISSUE THREE THE COW ARE AT
I'M WE ALL KNOW THAT HIGH COST
THE PLAN HUNDRED EIGHTY HOW FOR
THOSE WITH DIABETES IN THE CAR
FOR MANY FOR CAN BE RIGHT.
CONTINUING THE SPECIAL FEATURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY. TWENTY SIX. SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ACT AGAIN- JUST WANTED
TO WEIGH IN ON ISSUE ONE CHECK
THE PORT OF MY THE HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT SHE AT THE STATE
LEVEL. IT THERE IS ANY KNOWLEDGE
MAY THAT CHANGE THAT THE STATE
WILDER. AND THE SYSTEMS THAT
LOCAL HEALTH. HE AS A LITTLE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO NOT ONLY
BEING. IN PLANNING AFFECTS ALSO
IN PRIOR. OF WHICH TEETH. ARE
ARE REALLY BEING FOCUS UPON- AND
THEN WE ALSO NEED TO BE
PRIORITIZED IN THE FUNDING AT
THE STATE UPDATE THE SYSTEM AND
LOCAL SYSTEM THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE UPDATED WE ALSO NEED THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT AND SO WE
ASK THAT. ANY ASSESSMENT MOVING
FORWARD OF THE IT INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDE THE COSTS FOR THE LOCALS
AND F. PLAN TO SUPPORT THAT AS
WELL. WE ALSO WANT TO JUST MAKE
SURE- AND UNDERSCORE THE
COMMENTS WERE MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT ENSURING THAT. THE CHANGES
TO THAT I HATED FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SIDE DO YOU INTEGRATE.
AND ARE TAKING TO ACCOUNT AND
LARGER ITM. FRAMEWORK COMERS. AT
THE STATE. BEING DATA EXCHANGE.
IN POPULATION HEALTH MAY. AMONG
OTHERS. WE APPRECIATE BEING ABLE
TO BE ENGAGED IN THAT
CONVERSATION LOOK FOR TO MORE
DETAIL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS COLOR PLEASE. ALLIED
SEVEN. DR THIS ADRIAN SHELTON
WERE THE CAL LIFE AND FAMILY
REPRESENT A KNOCK COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION SIR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH AND SYSTEM WE WANTED
TO COME ON ISSUES AND THIRTY
THANK EACH CAR FOR THEIR LEADER
AND WORK FOR YOUR HELP LOOK. FOR
WE SHOULD ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVEST GIVEN
THE CREDIT THAT WE- A PRETTY ONE
TO CALL IT. TO THE SKYROCKETING
THE IN FIELD OF CALIFORNIANS YOU
TO BE TO BE A GIRL CARE AND
SUPPORT. BOB SERVICE. WHICH IN
MANY AREAS OF THE IT'S THE FULL
OF THE CRITICAL THREE FIFTY FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH. IF THEY THE WORK
RIGHT. ADVOCATE A PROVIDER ARE
SOME OF THEIR HIGHEST COULD BE
ANSWERABLE. ARE EVER AT WHEN THE
BOTH VULNERABLE TO IN CALIFORNIA
NEEDING SUPPORT SO YOU NEED ALL
THESE BACK THAT ARE. AND BOARD
AND ALL TO INSURE. THAT THE FAR
. PATIENTS ARE REPORTED TO
NETWORK THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NASCO PLEASE.
HI CARICOM THE WORK FORCE
PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY TO
COMPREHEND. ENERGY TO INCREASE
THE SOCIAL WORKERS IN A MORE
FAVORABLE HEALTH ISSUE THAT.
HELP THE HAVING COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROVIDER LIKE A
RECYCLING FIND MAINTAIN TO
EXPAND PROGRAM TO MEET THE
GROWING NEEDS FOR COMING BASED.
BUT GOING POPULAR OF AND CHRIS
THIS. ONE OF THE SURE THE PAGE
PROVIDERS HANDLE WERE CAN THE
PROGRAMS SERVICES. MARIN COURAGE
FOR TALK TO A PART THANK YOU
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR
PLEASE. A LINE THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH WEST
CENTER ON LONG TIME WE SUPPORT
THE ESTABLISH AND ONGOING OF THE
OF CARE. DEPEND ON A CONSISTENT
IMPACT A LITTLE WAY TO WHO ARE
STILL EXPECT TO CONTRIBUTE MORE
AT THE RATE HEALTH COVERAGE
MEANING THE COFFEE CARE BENCH
COUNTY UNIVERSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NAY COLOR PLAY.
LINE THIRTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOSH DUGGAR ON OF THE TOWN HELP
AND WILL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
TELL URBAN AND RURAL COUNTIES
THE ADDITION INVESTMENT AND
HELPING YOU SERVICES WORK COUNTY
DISTRICT TO COME THE PRICE
SECTOR TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
WORKERS ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF
THE PART SERVICES BY COUNTY
PROVIDE COUNTY HOSPITAL AND
CLINICS SYSTEM PUBLIC HELP TO.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENT THAT
SERVICE AGENCIES WOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT WORKFORCE SHORTAGES COULD
HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE
GLOBAL CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
SENIORS SERVED BY PUBLIC
AGENCIES URBAN COUNTIES ARE ALSO
SUPPORTED ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE INDIAN MASTER OF
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS OUTLINED BY
PANEL SIX THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND PIEPER
SERVICE PAYMENTS FINALLY THE
URBAN COUNTY CALIFORNIA WILL
COUNTY. BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA AND BEEN
TURRET COUNTY THE FOURTEENTH
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT PUBLIC
HERO INITIATIVE TO INVEST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IN
PIPELINE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND WE HAVE A
HEARING STARTING IN TEN MINUTES
SO I KNOW THERE ABOUT FIVE
CALLERS LEFT PLEASED AT BREVITY
WILL BE APPRECIATED. AT THIS
POINT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY
THIRTY. ANYONE WITH A IN
CALIFORNIA CALLED INTO THE
PROGRAM THE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABLE PEOPLE DOWN CALL
OFFICE OF CORPORATE NUCLEAR
THANK FOR AND THAT'S THE MORE BY
BIKE TRAIL TO ADDRESS THE WORK I
NEED AND THEN LASTLY BEFORE OF
NATURE OF BAGGAGE THAT ARE
CRITICAL OF THE CALL FAMILY
BOARD WHICH WOULD BE OF WITH THE
FOR GOT AGENCIES AND RESIDENTS I
FOR FEDERAL STANDARD- IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE A LOCAL SB THAT THE
BANK CARE QUALITY. OF LIFE.
LICENSURE PIPELINE MY BIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MR
SWEARS BUSINESSES CAN DOLLARS
EARLIER DURING THE HEARING. OF
CAMP PLEASE THAT THE CURRENT
BUDGET SURPLUS CAN BE USED
PROACTIVELY DEVELOP A PERSONAL
TRAINED WORKFORCE SUPPLEMENT OUR
STATE. GROWING MENTAL BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS. CLEARLY FOR MEDIC
BY LAW PLATE TO COP PROVIDERS-
WE ALSO THE INCLUDE OF AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. AND WE- ALSO
SUPPORT MY SB NINE SIX SIX- THAT
WILL HELP IMPROVE TRAIN ACCESS
AND FQHCS. RHC CLINICS NUMBER
ASSOCIATE MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
AND SOCIAL WORK TRAINEES THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DOCTOR AND A APENNINE EMERGENCY
MEDICINE RESIDENT POSITION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE I. R. S. U. U. I'M
HERE TODAY AND SUPPORTING
FUNDING TO GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FOR PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCIES ARE REQUESTED THAT
WE PUT IN SIXTY MILLION UP ONE
TIME FUNDS INTO FONG BROWN AND
SIXTY MILLION IT'S COMMON FOR
OUR TOTAL TWENTY MILLION EXPORT
BENEATH THE PHYSICALLY PERFECT
ACTUALLY AS WELL I FUNDING ARE
COMING SPECIALTY THE STRUGGLING
PROVIDE THE OF A COMMUNITIES
THERE. IS INCREASE FUNDING
MAKING A PROGRAM INCREASE IN
PEACE THAT SHE KEEP. SERVING ARE
MOST IN NEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M I'M GONNA AND
IT REYES THERE- I WE MAY HAVE A
COUPLE CALL. LEFT BUT I INVITE
YOU TO PLEASE. THE COMMITTEE.
WITH ANY FURTHER IMPORT. WITH A
PRE. HERE FROM. TO ENDED UP- WE
HAVE ANOTHER HEARING STARTING IN
THE SUMMER ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
AND WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
THIS MEETING.